[Music]
hey everyone welcome to this video on
aws full course
we'll begin this full course video with
what aws is
and how aws services work and we will be
looking at a bunch of aws services like
ec2
lambda s3 im cloud formation ecs
route 53 elastic beam stock vpc
sagemaker cloud front auto scaling and
redshift
after this we will do a comparison of
popular cloud providers that is aws
azure and gcp
moving further we will see how
kubernetes is implemented on aws and how
to become a solution architect
we will also guide you through aws
certification exams and in which we have
explained how to choose the right
certification for your career
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help every
individual crack an interview
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your aws career related
queries would have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced aws specialist
sam and rahul together we will take you
through the various topics of aws
so let's start with an exciting video on
aws full course
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
meet rob he runs an online shopping
portal
the portal started with a modest number
of users but has recently been seeing a
surge in the number of visitors
on black friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors
that the servers were unable to handle
the traffic and
crashed is there a way to improve
performance without having to invest in
a new server
wondered rob a way to upscale or
downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
market
before we see how aws can solve rob's
problem
let's have a look at how aws reach the
position it is at now
aws was first introduced in 2002
as a means to provide tools and services
to developers
to incorporate features of amazon.com to
their website
in 2006 its first cloud services
offering was introduced
in 2016 aws surpassed its 10
billion revenue target and now aws
offers more than 100 cloud services that
span a wide range of domains
thanks to this the aws cloud service
platform is now used by more than 45
of the global market now let's talk
about
what is aws aws or amazon web service
is a secure cloud computing platform
that provides
computing power database networking
content storage
and much more the platform also works
with a pay as you go pricing model
which means you only pay for how much of
the services offered by aws
you use some of the other advantages of
aws are security
aws provides a secure and durable
platform that offers end-to-end privacy
and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices
born from amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
os language
database and other services easy to use
users can host applications quickly and
securely
scalable depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up
or down aws provides a wide range of
services across
various domains what if rob wanted to
create an application for his online
portal
aws provides compute services that can
support the app development process
from start to finish from developing
deploying running to scaling the
application up or down based on the
requirements
the popular services include ec2 aws
lambda
amazon light cell and elastic bean stock
for storing website data rob could use
aws storage services
that would enable him to store access
govern
and analyze data to ensure that costs
are reduced agility is improved
and innovation accelerated popular
services within this domain include
amazon s3 ebs s3 glacier
and elastic file storage rob can also
store the user data in a database with
aw services
which he can then optimize and manage
popular services in this domain
include amazon rds dynamodb
and redshift if rob's businesses took
off
and he wanted to separate his cloud
infrastructure or scale up his work
requests
and much more he would be able to do so
with the networking services provided by
aws
some of the popular networking services
include amazon vpc
amazon route 53 and elastic load
balancing
other domains that aws provide services
in are analytics
blockchain containers machine learning
internet of things
and so on and there you go
that's aws for you in a nutshell now
before we're done
let's have a look at a quiz which of
these services are incorrectly matched
one two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comment section comment below with your
answer
and stand a chance to win an amazon
voucher several companies around the
world have found
great success with aws companies like
netflix
twitch linkedin facebook and bbc have
taken advantage of the services offered
by aws
to improve their business efficiency and
thanks to their widespread usage
aws professionals are in high demand
they're highly paid
and earn up to more than 127 thousand
dollars per annum
once you're aws certified you could be
one of them too
hello everyone let me introduce myself
as sam a multi-platform cloud architect
and trainer and i'm
so glad and i'm equally excited to talk
and walk you through the session about
what aws is and talk to you about some
services and offerings and
about how companies get benefited by
migrating their applications
and infra into aws so what's aws let's
talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case
how life was without aws so let's
walk back and picture how things were
back in 2000 which is not so long ago
but a lot of changes a lot of changes
for better had happened
since that time now back in 2000 a
request
for a new server is not an happy thing
at all because a lot of money a lot of
validations a lot of planning are
involved in getting a server online or
up and running and even after we finally
got the server
it's not all said and done a lot of
optimization that needs to be done
on that server to make it worth it and
get a good return on
investment from that server and even
after
we have optimized for a good return on
investment
the work is still not done there will
often be
a frequent increase and decrease in the
capacity
and you know even news about our website
getting popular
and getting more hits it's still an
bittersweet experience because
now i need to add more servers to the
environment which means that
it's going to cost me even more
but thanks to the present day cloud
technology if the same situation were to
happen today
my new server it's almost ready and it's
ready instantaneously
and with the swift tools and
technologies that amazon is providing
uh in provisioning my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of
it and making my storage and server
secure you know creating a durable
storage
where data that i store in the cloud
never gets lost with all that features
amazon has got our back so let's talk
about
what is aws there are a lot of
definitions for it but
i'm going to put together a simple and a
precise definition
as much as possible now let me iron that
out cloud
still runs on and hardware all right and
there are certain features in that
infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure
that makes cloud cloud or that makes aws
a cloud
provider now we get all the services
all the technologies all the features
and all the benefits that we get in our
local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity
and databases and in fact you know we
get even
more cool features like content caching
in various global locations around the
planet but again out of all the features
the best part is that
i get or we get everything on a pay as
we go model the less i use
the less i pay and the more i use the
less i pay
per unit very attractive isn't it right
and that's not
all the applications that we provision
in aws are very reliable because they
run on a
reliable infrastructure and it's very
scalable
because it runs on an on-demand
infrastructure
and it's very flexible because of the
designs and
because of the design options available
for me in the cloud
let's talk about how all this happened
aws was launched in
2002 after the amazon we know as the
online
retail store wanted to sell their
remaining
or unused infrastructure as a service or
as an offering for customers
to buy and use it from them you know
sell infrastructure as a service the
idea sort of
clicked and aws launched their first
product first product in 2006 that's
like
four years after the idea launch and in
they held a big sized customer even to
gather inputs and
concerns from customers and they were
very dedicated
in making those requests happen and that
habit is still being followed
it's still being followed as a reinvent
by aws
and at 2015 amazon announced its revenue
to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016
aws launched products and services that
helped migrate customer services
into aws well there were products even
before but this is when
a lot of focus was given on developing
migrating services
and in the same year that's in 2016
amazon's revenue was 10 billion and not
but not the least as we speak amazon has
more than 100 products and services
available for customers and get
benefited from
all right let's talk about the services
that are available
in amazon let's start with this product
called
s3 now s3 is a great tool for internet
backup
and it's it's the cheapest storage
option in the object storage
category and not only that the data that
we put in s3 is retrievable
from the internet s3 is really cool and
we have other products like
migration and data collection and data
transfer products and
here we can not only collect data
seamlessly but also
in a real time way monitor the data
or analyze the data that's being
received
that they're cool products like aws data
transfers
available that helps achieve that and
then we have products like
ec2 elastic compute cloud that's an
resizable computer where we can anytime
anytime after the size of the computer
based on
the need or based on the forecast then
we have
simple notification services systems and
tools available in amazon to
update us with notifications through
email
or through sms now anything anything can
be sent through email or through sms if
you use that service it could be alarms
or
it could be service notifications if you
want stuff like that and then we have
some security tools like kms key
management system
which uses aes 256 bit encryption to
encrypt our data at rest then we have
lambda
a service for which we pay only for the
time in
seconds seconds it takes to execute our
code and
uh we're not paying for the
infrastructure here it's just the
seconds
the program is going to take to execute
the code for the short program
we'll be paying in milliseconds if it's
a bit bigger program we'll be probably
paying in
60 seconds or 120 seconds but that's
not cheap lot simple and lots
cost effective as against paying for
service on an ugly basis which a lot of
other services are well that's cheap but
using lambda is a lot cheaper than that
and then we have services like
route 53 a dns service in the cloud and
now
i do not have to maintain a dns account
somewhere else and
my cloud environment with aws i can get
both in the same place
all right let me talk to you about um
how aws
makes life easier or how companies got
benefited by using aws as their
it provider for their applications or
for the infrastructure
now uniliver is a company and they had a
problem right and they had a problem and
they picked aws
as a solution to their problem right now
this company was sort of spread across
190 countries and they were relying on a
lot of digital marketing
for promoting their products and their
existing environment
their legacy local environment proved
not to support their changing id demands
and
they could not standardize their old
environment now
they chose to move part of their
applications to
aws because they were not getting what
they wanted in their
local environment and since then you
know rollouts were easy
provisioning new applications became
easy and even provisioning
infrastructure
became easy and they were able to do all
that in push button scaling
and needless to talk about backups that
are
safe and backups that can be securely
accessed from the cloud as needed
now that company is growing along with
aws because of their swift speed in
rolling out deployments and being able
to access
secure backups from various places and
generate reports
and in fact useful reports out of it
that helps their business
now on the same lines let me also talk
to you about kellogg's
and how they got benefited by using
amazon now
kellogg's had a different problem it's
one of its kind
now their business model was very
dependent
on an infrared that will help to analyze
data
really fast right because they were
running promotions based on the analyzed
data that they get so they're being able
to respond to the analyzed data
as soon as possible was critical or
vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on hana
environment is what they needed
and uh you know they picked that service
in the cloud and that's
sort of solved the problem now the
company does not
have to deal with uh maintaining their
legacy infra and
maintaining their heavy compute capacity
and maintaining their
database locally all that is now moved
to the cloud or
they are using cloud as their i.t
service provider and
and now they have a greater and powerful
ita environment
that very much complements their
business let me start the session with
this scenario
let's imagine how life would have been
without spotify for those who are
hearing about spotify for the first time
spotify is an online music service
offering
and it offers instant access to over 16
million
licensed songs spotify now uses aws
cloud to store the data and
share it with their customers but prior
to aws they had some issues
imagine using spotify before aws let's
talk about that back then users were
often getting errors because spotify
could not keep up with the increased
demand
for storage every new day and that led
to users getting upset and users
cancelling the subscription
the problem spotify was facing at that
time was their users were present
globally and were accessing it from
everywhere and
they had different latency in their
applications
and spotify had a demanding situation
where they need to
frequently catalog the songs released
yesterday today
and in the future and this was changing
every new day and the songs coming in
rate was about 20 000 a day and back
then
they could not keep up with this
requirement and needless to say they
were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
aws
and it was a perfect fit and match for
their problem aws
offered at dynamically increasing
storage and that's what they needed aws
also offered
tools and techniques like storage
lifecycle management and trusted advisor
to properly utilize the resource so we
always get
the best out of the resource used aws
address their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the aws environment
very easily how easily one might ask
it's just
a few button clicks and aws solved
spotify's problem
let's talk about how it can help you
with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is aws first and
then let's bleed into
how aws became so successful and the
different
types of services that aws provides and
what's the future of cloud and aws in
specific let's talk about that
and finally we'll talk about a use case
where
you will see how easy it is to create a
web application with aws all right
let's talk about what is aws aws or
amazon web services
is a secure cloud service platform it is
also
pay as you go type billing model where
there is no upfront
or capital cost we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available
well the service will be available in a
matter of seconds
with aws you can also do identity and
access management that is
authenticating and authorizing a user or
a program
on the fly and almost all the services
are available
on demand and most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak
amazon offers 100 plus services and this
list is growing every new week
now that would make you wonder how aws
became so successful
of course it's their customers let's
talk about the list of well-known
companies that has
their idea environment in aws adobe
adobe uses aws to provide
multi-terabyte operating environments
for its customers
by integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on
deploying and operating its own software
instead of trying to you know deploy and
manage the infrastructure
airbnb is another company it's an
community marketplace that allows
property owners and travelers to connect
each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and
the airbnb community users activities
are conducted
on the website and through iphones and
android applications
airbnb has a huge infrastructure in aws
and they're almost using
all the services in aws and are getting
benefited from it another example would
be autodesk
autodesk develops software for
engineering designing
and entertainment industries using
services like
amazon rds or rational database servers
and amazon s3 or amazon simple
storage servers autodesk can focus on
deploying or developing
its machine learning tools instead of
spending that time on managing
the infrastructure aol or american
online uses aws
and using aws they have been able to
close data centers and decommission
about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach
and save millions of dollars on energy
resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their
portfolio of software's include
antivirus and anti-spyware products
bitdefender uses ec2 and they're
currently running few hundred instances
that handle about
five terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to
load balance the connection coming in to
those instances across
availability zones and they provide
seamless global delivery of servers
because of that the bmw group it uses
aws for its
new connected car application that
collects sensor data from
bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated
map information canon's office imaging
products
division benefits from faster deployment
times lower cost and global reach by
using
aws to deliver cloud-based services such
as mobile print
the office imaging products division
uses aws
such as amazon s3 and amazon route 53
amazon cloudfront and amazon im
for their testing development and
production services
comcast it's the world's largest cable
company and the leading provider of
internet service in the united states
comcast uses aws
in a hybrid environment out of all the
other cloud providers
comcast chose aws for its flexibility
and scalable hybrid infrastructure
docker is a company that's helping
redefine the way developers build ship
and run
applications this company focuses on
making
use of containers for this purpose and
in aws the service
called the amazon ec2 container service
is helping them
achieve it the esa or european space
agency although much of esa's work is
done by satellites
some of the programs data storage and
computing infrastructure is built on
amazon web services
esa chose aws because of its economical
pay as ego system
as well as its quick startup time the
guardian newspaper uses aws and it uses
a wide range of aws services including
amazon kinesis
amazon redshift that power an analytic
dashboard which
editors use to see how stories are
trending in real time
financial times ft is one of the world's
largest
leading business news organization and
they used
amazon redshift to perform their
analysis a funny thing happened
amazon redshirt performed so quickly
that some analysis thought it was
malfunctioning they were used to running
queries overnight
and they found that the results were
indeed correct just as much faster by
using amazon redshift
fd is supporting the same business
functions with costs that are 80
percentage
lower than what was before general
electric ge
is at the moment as we speak migrating
more than 9000 workloads
including 300 desperate erp systems to
aws
while reducing its data center footprint
from
34 to 4 over the next three years
similarly howard medical school htc imdb
mcdonald's nasa kellogg's and lot more
are using the services
amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it
and this huge success and customer
portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws
and if we let aws answer that question
this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption
of the data and storage experience we
can also rely on
aws way of doing things by using the aws
tools and techniques
and suggested best practices built upon
the years of experience
it has gained flexibility there is a
greater flexibility in aws that allows
us to select the os language
and database easy to use swiftness in
deploying we can host our applications
quickly in aws beat a new application or
migrating an existing application into
aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement
cost saving we only pay for the compute
power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any
long-term commitments now let's talk
about the different types of services
that aws provides
the services that we talk about fall in
any of the following categories you see
like
you know compute storage database
security
customer engagement desktop and
streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably
is because aws is creating it as we
speak now let's look at some of them
that are very commonly used within
computer services we have amazon ec2
amazon elastic bean stock
amazon light sale and amazon lambda
amazon ec2 provides compute capacity
in the cloud now this capacity is secure
and it is resizable based on the user's
requirement
now look at this the requirement for the
web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2
can expand its environment to three
instances and during
no load it can shrink its environment to
just one resource
elastic beanstalk it helps us to scale
and deploy web applications
and it's made with a number of
programming languages elastic beanstalk
is also an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services deployed between java.net
php node.js python ruby docker
and lot other familiar services such as
apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon lightsail
is a virtual private server which
is easy to launch and easy to manage
amazon lightsail is the easiest way to
get started with aws for developers who
just need a virtual private server
lightsail includes
everything you need to launch your
project quickly on
a virtual machine like ssd based storage
a virtual machine
tools for data transfer dns management
and a static ip
and that too for a very low and
predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level
it allows us to pay only for the compute
time no need for provisioning and
managing servers
and aws lambda is a compute service that
lets
us run code without provisioning or
managing servers
lambda executes your code only when
needed and scales automatically
from few requests per day to thousands
per second you pay only for the compute
time you consume there is no charge
when your code is not running let's look
at some storage services that amazon
provides like amazon s3 amazon glacier
amazon abs and amazon elastic file
system amazon s3 is an
object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere
websites mobile apps iot sensors and so
on
can easily use amazon x3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and destroy any amount of
data from anywhere
with its features like flexibility in
managing data
and the durability it provides and the
security that it provides
amazon simple storage service or s3 is a
storage for the internet and glacier
glacier is a cloud storage service
that's used for archiving data and
long-term backups and this glacier is an
secure durable and extremely low-cost
cloud storage service for data archiving
and long term backups amazon ebs
amazon elastic block store provides
block store volumes for the instances of
ec2
and this elastic block store is highly
available and
a reliable storage volume that can be
attached to any running instance that is
in the same availability zone
abs volumes that are attached to the ec2
instances are exposed
as storage volumes that persistent
independently from the lifetime of the
instance an amazon elastic file system
or efs provides an elastic file storage
which can be used with aws cloud service
and resources that are on premises an
amazon elastic file system
it's an simple it's scalable it's an
elastic file storage
for use with amazon cloud services and
for on-premises
resources it's easy to use and offers a
simple interface that allows you to
create and configure file systems
quickly and easily
amazon file system is built to
elastically scale on demand without
disturbing the application growing and
shrinking automatically as you add and
remove files your application have the
storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases
the two major database flavors are
amazon rds and amazon
redshift amazon rds it really eases the
process involved
in setting up operating and scaling a
relational database in the cloud
amazon rds provides cost efficient and
resistable capacity while automating
time consuming administrative tasks such
as hardware provisioning database setup
patching and backups it sort of frees us
from managing the hardware
and sort of helps us to focus on the
application it's also cost
effective and resizable and it's also
optimized for memory
performance and input and output
operations not only that it also
automates most of the services like
taking backups you know monitoring stuff
like that
it automates most of those services
amazon redshift amazon redshift is a
data warehousing service that enables
users to
analyze the data using sql and other
business intelligent tools
amazon reshift is an fast and fully
managed data warehouse that makes it
simple and cost effective analyze all
your data using standard sql
and your existing business intelligent
tools it also allows you to run
complex analytic queries against
petabyte of structured data using
sophisticated query optimizations and
most of the results they generally come
back in seconds
all right let's quickly talk about some
more services that aws offers
there are a lot more services that aws
provides but are we going to look at
some more services that are widely used
aws application discovery services help
enterprise customers
plan migration projects by gathering
information about their on-premises data
centers in a planning a data center
migration can involve thousands of
workloads they are often
deeply interdependent server utilization
data and dependency mapping are
important early first step in migration
process and this aws application
discovery service
collects and presents configuration
usage and behavior data
from your servers to help you better
understand your workloads
route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an
highly available and scalable cloud
domain name
system or dns service and amazon route
53 is fully compliant with ipv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes
incoming application traffic across
multiple targets such as
amazon ec2 instance containers and ip
addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a
single availability zone and also across
availability zones aws auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain
steady and predictable performance at a
lowest possible cost using aws auto
scaling it's easy to set up application
scaling for multiple resources across
multiple services in minutes auto
scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services
and resources securely using iam you can
create and manage aws users and groups
and use
permissions to allow and deny their
access to aws resources and moreover
it's a free service
now let's talk about the future of aws
well let me tell you something
cloud is here to stay here's what in
store for aws in the future
as years pass by we're going to have a
variety of cloud applications born
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence
serverless computing and so on cloud
will also expand into other markets like
healthcare
banking space automated cars and so on
as i was mentioning some time back
lot or greater focus will be given to
artificial intelligence
and eventually because of the
flexibility and advantage that cloud
provides we're going to see a lot of
companies
moving into the cloud all right let's
now talk about
how easy it is to deploy and web
application
in the cloud so the scenario here is
that our users
like a product and we need to have a
mechanism to receive
input from them about their likes and
dislikes and
you know give them the appropriate
product as per their need
all right though the setup and the
environment it sort of looks complicated
we don't have to worry because aws has
tools and technologies which can
help us to achieve it now we're going to
use services like route 53 services like
cloudwatch
ec2 s3 and lot more and all these put
together are going to
give an application that's fully
functionable and an application that's
going to receive the information
like using the services like route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated
about the happenings and the new comings
in the market and to fulfill this
requirement here is all the services we
would need
ec2 here is used for provisioning the
computational
power needed for this application and
ec2 has a vast variety of family and
types that we can pick from
for the types of workloads and also for
the intents of the workloads we're also
going to use
s3 for storage and s3 provides any
additional
storage requirement for the resources or
any additional storage requirement for
the web applications and we are also
going to use
cloudwatch for monitoring the
environment and cloudwatch monitors the
application and the environment
and it provides trigger for scaling in
and scaling out the infrastructure
and we're also going to use route 53 for
dns and route 53 helps us to register
the domain name
for our web application and with all the
tools and technologies together
all of them put together we're going to
make an application
a perfect application that caters our
need all right so i'm going to use
elastic beanstalk for
this project and the name of the
application is
going to be as you see gsg sign up and
the environment name is
gsg sign up environment one let me also
pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that
and the application that i have is going
to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance
it's going to launch the monitoring
setup or the monitoring environment
it's going to create a load balancer as
well and it's going to take care of all
the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url
which is what we gave and it's now
having
an default page shown up meaning all the
dependencies for the software
is installed and it's just waiting for
me to upload the code or in specific the
page required so let's do that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code and that's going to take
some time
all right it has done its thing and now
if i go to the same url
look at that i'm being thrown an
advertisement page
all right so if i sign up with my name
email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information
and it's going to send an email to the
owner saying that
somebody had subscribed to your service
that's the default feature of this app
look at that email to the owner saying
that somebody had subscribed to your app
and this is their email address stuff
like that
not only that it's also going to create
an entry in the database and dynamodb
is the service that this application
users to store data there's my dynamodb
and if i go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with
name samuel and email address so and so
has said okay or has shown interest in
the preview of my site or product so
this is where this is how i collect
those information
right and some more things about the
infrastructure itself
is it is running behind and load
balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created
an auto scaling group now that's the
feature of elastic load balancer that we
have chosen
it has created an auto scaling group and
now let's put this
url you see this it's not a fancy url
right it's an amazon given url a dynamic
url so let's put this url
behind our dns let's do that
so go to services go to route 53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the dns name right so that's a dns name
all right
all right let's create an entry and map
that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me to that
application
all right look at that i went to my
custom url
and now that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more let me help you understand
about aws ec2
a compute servers in the cloud through
this video
somewhere far in the country a scientist
has a lab far
in the woods and at one day he stumbled
on a calculation
that he had trouble solving and he was
very certain that his computer can
handle it
and he asked his computer to do the math
or the calculation for him
and the computer thought about it for a
while then took couple of hours
in trying to process the data and
eventually at one point
it gave up and died due to low memory
and this old scientist is now
clueless about how he was going to
finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend aws as
you see on the screen
aws was very handy in replacing his old
machines
and it was able to give him the service
that he wanted at that moment
aws has been around for a while helping
people with their computer needs and now
this new scientist friend in need is
welcomed
by the new and trendy id technology aws
and sure enough his new aws friend
welcomed and
walked him through the new way of
computing and this new
happy-faced aws friend talked to this
scientist
about aws ec2 in specific and walked him
through about
all the new innovations in it and in
cloud
that he had been missing all these days
so his new friend
aws started the conversation about
explaining
how there is no need for any hardware
units
no managing hardware or provisioning in
aws
and secondly it explained increasing and
decreasing
the capacity as per the demand is just a
click away
and the best part here is that there is
no upfront commitment and we only pay
for what we have used just like we pay
electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side in other words the whole
key for this infrastructure
is with us and as if this was not enough
all this comes with
enterprise great security that's beyond
imagination in
on premises and if this still does not
excite you
then this definitely would you can work
from anywhere in the world
now this really made the scientist to
get excited
especially when he thought about working
from home working from home
there is nothing like it isn't it now
this person the scientist is not tied up
to a particular environment he can work
from home
work on the fly work from anywhere still
the data and everything else in his id
environment
is secure and safe now let's move to the
next level of discussion
let's talk about what is ec2 and some of
the use cases of ec2
and this use case we're going to talk
about are this architecture we're going
to talk about
it notifies a group of users about a new
letter and the components or resources
this architecture would need
the first ec2 instance then sns
a simple notification service and
coupling
ec2 and s3 service together that's all
it would require
to get an architecture that notifies a
group of users about a new newsletter
and now i think it would be a good time
to talk about
what ec2 is aws offers plenty of
services
offered under different domains like you
know compute
storage database migration network
management tools
media services security business
productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity
so what is ec2 ec2 is a web service
which aims to make life easier for
developers for providing secure
and resizable compute capacity in the
cloud with ec2
it is very easy to scale up or scale
down
our infrastructure based on the demand
and not only that
this ec2 service can be integrated well
with almost
all the services in amazon and out of
all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case
a use case here is that a successful
business owner
has a bunch of users and a successful
product that's
running and now he has developed few
more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like
now how can he advertise his product
to his new and prospective customers or
the solution for this question
can be addressed by aws in aws
we can use services like simple
notification service sns
and ec2 for compute and s3 for storage
we can in a way integrate them all and
achieve
this business use case and that sort of
got this business owner very cheered up
and now he wants to use the service and
he wants to get benefited from the
service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users
every time the company creates a
newsletter all right so let's talk about
what it would take to get this
environment up and running
or what it would take to connect the
environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an aws account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance
and here's how we go about doing it the
first thing
is to create an ami which is amazon
mission image that's really the
softwares
and the application packages we would
need to run our application
and the second is to choose the hardware
in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intents of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and
finally we would configure the instances
and how many instance do i want you know
which subnet do i want them
in and what's going to be the in a stop
or terminate
a behavior of the instance and do i want
to
update any patches when the instance
starts running all those pieces of
information go in here when we configure
the instance and then the first three
steps is really about the os volume and
the basic hardware
now it's time to add additional storage
to the ec2 instance that would be step
four here we add additional storage to
the ec2 instance
and then tags we use tags or we would
configure tags to
easily identify an ec2 instance at a
later point you know we give it some
meaningful names
so we can identify like you know which
team it belongs to which
billing department it belongs to what's
the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that
in an environment where we run 700 to
800 or even more
instances identifying an instance and
trying to understand
you know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6
we would configure the firewall which is
also called
security group for the ec2 instant and
this
is where we would allow or deny
connection
from external world to this particular
ec2 instance
well it works both ways from outside and
from inside
out this firewall blocks the connection
based on
port number and ip address and finally
as step 7
we review all the configurations that
you have done and we make sure that the
configurations is what we wanted and
finally click on submit
that's going to launch an ec2 instance
all right this was just an overview of
how to create an ec2 instance
now let's talk about each and every step
in detail
so to begin with let's talk about how to
create
an ami well the ami is just
a template a template that's used to
create
a new instance or an new computer or a
new vm or a new machine
based on the user requirement the things
that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system
the additional applications that get
installed in it stuff like that
the ami will also contain software
information
you know information about operating
system information about access
permission
information about volumes they all
compact in the ami
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined
amis are called amazon provided amis
the other one would be custom amis the
amis that we create and if you're
looking at
a particular ami that you don't want to
create but still
want to get it from amazon there is a
place or a portal
called ami marketplace there we get
like thousands of amis in there
available for us to shop and use them on
a pay as you go
business model and use them as pay as
you go billing
so there you can search ami that you're
looking for
most probably you'll be able to get it
there now let's talk about choosing the
instance type the instance type is
basically the hardware specification
that's required
for a machine that we're trying to build
and the instant types
is categorized into five main families
they are
to begin with it's compute optimized now
compute optimize
gives us lots of compute power or lots
of
processing power so if my application is
going to require
a lot of processing power i should be
picking compute optimized instance
and the second one is memory optimized
now this is very good
for application that require in-memory
caching
you know there are some application that
performs well with
cash or through cash or the application
would create a lot of data that it wants
to keep in cache
for rereading or for processing you know
for lengthy processing stuff like that
for those type of application this
memory optimized
instance that comes with in memory cache
is a very good use case
and the third one is the instant that
comes with the
gpu otherwise called gpu optimized
gpu stands for graphical process unit
and this is
very good for application that deals
with gaming
this is very good for application that's
going to require
large graphical requirements and storage
optimize is the fourth option just like
the name says this is
a very good use case for storage servers
and the fifth family type is
general purpose just like the name says
it's for general purpose
if you're not particular about the
family then
you generally would end up picking the
general purpose because here the
services are sort of
equally balanced you know you'll find a
balance between the virtual cpu
and the memory and the storage and the
network performance it's sort of
balanced
all the components all the features that
needs to go in a computer are sort of
balanced in general purpose now these
instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's
hardware based we buy hardware we do not
have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware
and these instant types are divided into
five main families
they are compute optimized memory
optimized gpu enabled
storage optimized and general purpose
then as third thing
we have to configure the instance now
here is where
i have a lot of options about purchasing
you know what type of
purchasing do i want to do do i want to
go for a spot instance do i want to go
for a
reserved instance do i want to go for an
on-demand instance these are different
billing options available and that's
available under configure instance
not only that here's where i'm going to
put the ec2 instance do i want and
public ipads assigned to it do i want an
im
role attached to it im role is
authentication
what kind of authentication am i going
to provide and the shutdown behavior
the shutdown behaviors include do i want
to stop the instance
when the user shuts down the machine
from the desktop or do i want to simply
terminate
the instance when the user shuts down
the instance from
the desktop so those things go in here
just like the name says
configure instance a lot of instance
configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced
details or advanced tab under configure
instance
i can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run
in the instance before it actually comes
online let's say you're provisioning the
instance
for somebody else you know instead of
you launching the instance and then
logging in
and running some commands and then
handing it over to the other person
you can create bootstrap shell scripts
and
you know paste it in a console option
available under configure instance and
amazon is going to take those commands
run it on the instance before it hands
over
to the user that initially requested for
that instance now
it could be a different user or just you
it sort of automates you know software
installation
procedures in the instance that we will
be launching and not only that there are
multiple
payment options available under
configure instance
the user can pick an instance under
normal price and
that instance would apply normal rates
applied to it and there are also options
like reserved instance
where the user can pay for an instance
upfront
before a year or before months you know
for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less
per hour for using that instance not
only that
you can also go for spot instance like
bidding
for those instances whoever bids more
they get the instance for that
particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand
instances and through bidding and buying
you can keep the instance as long as
your bid price doesn't exceed the price
that amazon
is proposing and as the fourth step we
will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have
bunch of storage options i can go for a
permeable storage
which is free or i can go for an
external
elastic block storage also called ebs
which is paid and it's a permanent
storage or else i can integrate
my ec2 instance with s3 for its storage
needs
and the best part about storage is free
subscription users
they get to use 30 gigabit of ssd
storage
or magnetic storage for the whole year
in this page
where we are ready to add storage we
will have to mention
or provide the size in gigabit and the
volume type
is it going to be an uh provisioned
volume is it going to be
an general purpose volume is it going to
be a magnetic volume
stuff like that they are volume types
and we also need to give
inputs about where the disc will be
mounted
and whether this volume needs to be
encrypted or not so all these options
are all these inputs are received from
us under
the adding storage section and then the
fifth option would be adding
tags like we discussed some time back
tags are very helpful to identify a
machine
in an environment where we have 700 or
1000 vms running
and security groups are the actual
firewall
that sits in front of ec2 instance and
it protects that ec2
instance from unintended inbound and
outbound traffic now here is where i can
fine tune the access to my ec2 instance
based on
port numbers and based on ip address
from which it can be accessed
and finally we get to review the whole
changes or the whole configurations that
we have made to find out whether they
are intact with the requirement and then
click on submit that's going to launch
an ec2 instance
but hold on we're not done yet when
we're about to launch or
before the amazon console actually
launches
the ec2 instance it's going to give us
an option to
create a keypad remember i said it's key
pair you know key pair
is two things one is public and private
the
private key is downloaded by the user
and is kept with
the user and the public key is used by
amazon
to confirm the identity of the user so
just go ahead and download the private
key
and keep it for yourself and this
private key
gets downloaded as a dot pem file
it's a format of the file and it gets
downloaded as dot pen file
and our next step is to access the ec2
instance and
because the instance that we have
launched in this example
let's assume it's linux instance and
that's going to require a tool called
putty
to be able to access it and this putty
tool is
really needed when we are trying to
access and linux instance
from windows instance most of the time
windows instance will have
putty installed in them but in some rare
cases they do not come with putty in
those cases we can go ahead and download
putty
and put the generator and we can start
using it
to access the linux instance now you
might ask well
i understand putty watch putty generator
now the file that we have downloaded is
in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format
as input you know it has to be converted
into a different format called ppk
and putty gen is a tool that helps us to
convert the dot pem file
into ppk file so the quick way
to do it is download generator open it
up
click on conversion and insert the dot
pem key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and
this when we save the private key it
gets saved as
a dot ppk type private key and when
that's done the next
very step is to open puti and try to log
in
and the way to login is to open putty
put that ip address here
and then click on auth you know this is
where we would
input the file that we have created so
click on auth and then click on
browse and find the dot ppk file that we
have converted and stored
browse it and upload it and then click
on
open now that's going to open up a login
screen
for us and the amis comes with a default
username
depending on the ami that we have picked
the username
might differ in our case we have picked
an ami
for which the username is ec2 hyphen
user
and this is the default by the way let's
put the username ec2hyphen user
and hit enter and that's going to open
up the linux instance
using cli there are a few other things
that we can do with the terminal
that will explain it a little later all
right so we have successfully launched
an ec2 instance
and yeah give yourself a pat on your
back
launching an instance was just one part
of the solution
so let's actually talk about how we can
notify our customers
sns or simple notification service is a
service
or a product in amazon that helps us to
notify customers
through email so navigate to sns in your
account
and create a topic and we're going to
use this topic for public notification
so let's make it public and then add
subscribers to it
now these subscribers these subscribers
are the people
who you want to be notified about the
newsletter
so we already have the email database in
there add them
to the subscribers list and then they
will start
getting new newsletters as in when we
post them
to the topic and as next step create a
bucket
in s3 where you can store content and in
that bucket
create an event that triggers a
notification to simple notification
service so this is how it'll be set up
and notification will be sent to our
subscribers
anytime we put something in our s3
bucket
so s3 bucket is going to create an event
for the notification and the
notification is going to make sure that
it's delivered to your end customer
because they're already subscribed
to the topic as subscribers and finally
let's connect
the s3 with ec2 so the bucket
and the aws instance are in sync so we
put some content in the s3 bucket
our email system notifies our customers
and the customers can go online
to a website that's hosted in ec2
and because s3 and ec2 are in sync the
items that we put in s3 will also show
up in ec2
see how this is all connected and it's
working together
and once this is all connected our
subscribers
will regularly be informed anytime we
put
new content in the s3 bucket and the
same content will be made available in
ec2 instance
through the website let me welcome you
to this new video learning
where we're going to learn about lambda
one day at office
in a growing company there was
discussion going on
between two it personal it was about the
new role that his colleague jessica has
taken
benjamin the guy standing here wants to
know about it
and jessica's job is new different and
dynamic and interesting too she scale
and manage
servers and operating systems and apply
security patches onto them
and monitor all of these at the same
time to ensure the best
quality for application is given to the
users
and benjamin was awestruck with the
amount of work jessica is doing
and with the time it would take to
complete all of them but
jessica being a very dynamic person very
suitable for the job
said it was easy for her to handle all
of it and even more
but that easiness on the job did not
last longer
as the environment grew more and more it
being a startup company
jessica was getting drained and was not
really happy about all her job
as she used to be jessica's manual way
of scaling and environment did not last
long
and she was also finding out that she
missed to scale down
some of the resources and it's costing
her a lot
she needs to pay for the service that
she was not at all using
she sort of felt that she was at the end
of the road and there was no way out
from this manual task she was very
desperate
and that's when benjamin suggested
something and that brought back the
peace and joy jessica initially had
benjamin suggested about a service
called
lambda that can ease the work that
jessica
is doing at the moment and lambda as
happy as it looks like
it's a solution that solves the manual
repetitive work
and lot more and lambda introduced
itself as the problem solver
and started to explain the following
things the very same thing
that we're gonna learn about in this
series so in this section we're gonna
learn about the
features of aws lambda and we're going
to talk about
what lambda is and then we're going to
talk about where lambda is being used
in the it or in the cloud environment as
we speak and then we're going to talk
about
how lambda works and some use cases of
lambda
and we're going to be particularly
discussing about the use case
about automatically backing up the data
that's put in the cloud storage
let's talk about lambda in detail lambda
automatically runs our code
without requiring us to provision or
manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to lambda and lambda will
take care of it that means that we don't
require any server to run
or to manage and all you need to do is
write the code
and upload it to lambda and lambda will
take care of it which also means that
we can stop worrying about provisioning
and managing service
the only thing lambda expects from you
is a code that's working
aws lambda also automatically scales our
application
by running code in response to each
trigger our code runs in parallel
and processes each triggers individually
scaling precisely with the size of the
workload
scaling here is done automatically based
on the size
of the workload lambda can scale the
application running the code
in response to each and every trigger
that it receives
billing in lambda is metered on the
seconds we only pay for the amount of
time
that our code is running which means
that we're not charged for any of the
servers the only payment required
is for the amount of time the code is
computed
with aws lambda we are charged for every
100 milliseconds
we are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code
executes and the number of times our
code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not
running let's talk about what is aws
lambda now lambda is one of the servers
that falls under the
compute section or the compute domain of
services that
aws provides along with ec2
ebs elastic load balancer lambda is also
a service that comes under the bigger
umbrella of compute services in aws
and lambda allows us to execute code for
any type of application with
aws lambda we can run code for virtually
any type of application or
backend services all we need to do is
supply
our code in one of the languages that
aws lambda supports
as we speak the languages that are
supported by aws lambda are
node.js java c-sharp go and python and
lambda can be used to run code in
response to certain events from
other services and based on the event it
can
run functions and those functions can be
of node.js
java c-sharp etc now let's talk about
where is lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for
lambda and there are many ways aws
lambda
is used specifically in the business
world let's talk about some of them
one use case is aws lambda is used to
process
images when it is uploaded in an s3
bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
sd bucket
in a format that we don't expect it to
be which means
the file needs to be formatted so it
gets uploaded in a raw format
and aws lambda is triggered anytime a
new object is added to the bucket
and the images are processed and
converted into
thumbnails based on the devices the
other end device that would be reading
the data it could be an pc it could be
an apple
machine it could be an android phone it
could be an apple phone it could be a
tablet
what not so based on the devices
different formats
lambda can get triggered and convert the
video or
convert the picture into the different
format that it requires
another use case for lambda is to
analyze the social
media data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag
trending data and the data is received
and it's added into the kinesis stream
to feed into the amazon environment and
lambda
action get triggered and it receives the
data
and then the data is stored into the
database which can be used
by businesses for later analysis
and some of the companies that have
gotten tremendous benefit
using lambda are thomson routers
benchlings
not storm coca-cola robot are some of
the companies
to name at the moment that have received
tremendous amount of benefit
by using lambda let's look at how lambda
works
in other words let's look at how the
complicated function
behind the scenes work in a simple and
in a seamless way
so here clients send data now clients
send data to lambda and clients could be
anyone who's sending requests
to aws lambda it could be an application
or other amazon
web services that's sending data to the
lambda and lambda receives the request
and depending on the size of the data or
depending on the
amount or volume of the data it runs on
the defined number of containers if it
is a single request or if it is less
request it runs
on a single container so the requests
are given to the container
to handle and the container which
contains the code
the user has provided to satisfy the
query would run
and if you're sort of new to containers
then let me
pause here for a while and explain to
you what container is now container
image is a
lightweight standalone executable
package
of a piece of software that includes
everything
needs to run it like the codes the run
times the system tools the
system libraries and any other settings
needed
and it is at the moment available both
on linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless
of the environment it's running on and
containers
isolate software from its surrounding
for example
there could be difference between a
development and staging environment so
that's sort of isolated and this helps
in
reducing the conflict between the teams
running different
software on the same infrastructure all
right now that we
know containers needed to understand
lambda
so if there are a few requests it sends
to
a single container but as and when the
request grows
it actually creates multiple containers
shares the multiple requests to the
different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions
the more number of containers are
provisioned so to handle those
requests and when the requests reduce
the number of containers reduce
as well and that helps in saving costs
we're not running any resources and
paying for it
when we're not using them and in fact
we're not at all paying for the
resources
we're only charged for the amount of
time a function
is running inside these containers now
consider a situation where you have to
set up a temporary storage
and as a system to backup the data as
soon as the data is uploaded
which is a near real-time backup
now a near real time manual backups
are nearly impossible and they're not
that efficient too
and near real-time manual backups that's
what
the business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that to a manual one
that's not at all efficient
even if we come up with a solution of
manually backing up close to near
real time that's not going to be
efficient looking at the amount of data
that will be put in
and looking at the random times
the data will be put into the source
bucket and there is no way we can
do a manual backup and they keep it as
real as possible
but if that's still your requirement we
can use aws lambda
and set things up so aws lambda manually
handles the backup
in other words for an impossible or a
difficult situation like that
aws lambda comes for the rescue and this
is what we do create a 2s3 bucket one
would be the source bucket
where the data will be uploaded and the
other one is and destination bucket
where the data will be backed up from
the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an im
role
and then for the automatic copy it's
going to require an
lambda function to copy the files from
the source bucket to the destination
bucket
and what triggers the lambda function
the lambda function is triggered
every time there's a change in the
metadata for the bucket and this data
is then uploaded into the destination
bucket
and after setting all this up we can
literally test it by putting a data in
the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from the source bucket to the
destination bucket alright let's see how
we can
replicate data between two buckets well
we have a feature
to cross region replicate in s3 that's a
feature that comes along with s3 what if
you want to replicate between
two different buckets in two different
accounts in those cases we can use
lambda to replicate the data between the
buckets so you put one data
or you put data in the source bucket and
that data gets replicated to the
destination bucket
and let's see how that's done the
procedure here would be to have two
buckets
to begin with and then create an iem
role that lets you access to pull
data from the source bucket and put data
on the destination bucket
and then create lambda files or lambda
event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime
a new data gets added lambda gets
triggered copies the data from the
source bucket and moves the data to the
destination bucket and it uses the iam
role and policy
for the needed permissions and in just a
couple of clicks
we have set up a temporary backup system
that can run
seamlessly without any manual
intervention
and that can be as near time as possible
all right that's the concept and let's
see how it is done real time through
this lab
so to begin with we need two buckets so
i have here
a source bucket and a destination bucket
and the source bucket as of now do not
have any data in it
so as the destination bucket all right
so that's one down the second
would be to create an im role right so
let me create an im role and the role is
going to have
this policy in it a policy that's
allowing get object on the source bucket
and a policy that's
allowing put object on the destination
bucket and
here i'm going to use or i'm going to
paste my source and destination buckets
arn
all right go to services go to s3
source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket they are in
so that would be the source bucket
arn all right on on the destination
bucket
copy the destination bucket arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket arn so with this
i'm going to create a policy all right
go to im
and create a policy
now i i have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket arn
and a policy is available with the name
s3
bucket copy lambda attach the policy to
the role
right go to roles create a role lambda
is the service
that's going to use it in here attach
the policy
that we have created
right give it a name and then create a
role now i have
a role created as well
all right copy lambda and that's having
the policy that we have created sometime
back
now create a lambda function right so go
to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right choose the role
that we want to use right that's the
rule that we want to use
copy one two create a function
all right and in here
we're to use node.js code right i have a
sample code
this can be used as template here
replace the
source bucket with the name of the
source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code
that gets run when an event gets
triggered now what's an event
anytime there is a new object placed in
the s3 bucket
it creates an event and the evil
triggers lambda and
lambda checks this source s3 bucket
picks the data
puts it in the destination bucket all
right paste it here
paste it here and click on save
right now before you click on save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
roles defined that's all you got to do
click on save all right now i already
have
created a lambda function
all right which is the same thing
same code and the role is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test
go to s3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and in theory those data
should be present
in the destination bucket as well there
you go
it's all done by lambda i'm going to be
touring you with
different s3 features and technical
details in this section
so what are we going to learn we're
going to learn about
what is cloud storage in general and
then
the types of storage available in
general in the cloud
and how things were before anybody
adopted
using s3 that's something we're going to
learn and then we're going to
immediately dive into
what is s3 and then the benefits of
using s3 over other
storage and then we're going to do a
couple of labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an
object what is bucket how to create a
bucket stuff like that
and then we're going to talk about how
amazon s3
generally works now it comes with a lot
of features it comes with a lot of
promise
um how does this all work how does
amazon able to keep up with the promise
we're going to talk about that
and then we will talk about some
features add-on features that comes
along with the
amazon s3 so what is cloud storage in
general
cloud storage is a service that provides
web services
where we can store our data and not only
that the data
can be easily accessed and the data can
be
easily backed up everything over the
internet
in charge if you could store your data
if you could access the data if you
could back your
your data everything you do through the
internet
then that's a good definition for cloud
storage
and the additional definitions are in
cloud storage we only
pay for what we use and no commitment
no pre-provisioning is you know
pay-as-you-go type subscription and the
best part is
we pay on a monthly basis you know we
don't rent a hardware for the year
or we don't give commitment for the
whole year it's pay as you go
and pay on a monthly basis and these
cloud storages are
very reliable meaning once you put the
data in it
it's never going to get lost and these
cloud storages are scalable
assuming i have a requirement to store
100 times of
what my actual data sizes and i want it
now
it's available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data
data virginity they need to be secure
and amazon provides
tools and technologies through which we
can secure our data
and these are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage
in general so s3 is a cloud storage in
aws
and then we have elastic block store now
elastic block store is actually the
ssd hard drives that gets attached to
our ec2 instance you know it's like the
c
drive it's like the d drive it's like
the e drive that gets attached to our
instances now efs is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but
it differs from ebs in a way that ebs
can be accessed only by the system
that's attached to it meaning the e
volumes and the d volumes we spoke about
they can be accessed only if there is an
instance
connected to it but these efs are
actually
shared file systems elastic file system
all right they are shared systems they
can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from
inside the amazon environment it can be
accessed from on-premises equipment as
well
glacier is actually the archiving
solution in the cloud if you
want to dump a data and try to keep them
in the low cost as possible then glacier
is the product we should be using and
then we have storage gateway if i
want to safely move my data from my
local environment
to the cloud environment and also want
to keep a copy of the data locally so
users locally can access them and in a
cloud users or internet users can access
the data from the cloud if that's your
requirement
then storage gateway is the one we would
be choosing and then we have
snowball snowball is really an
data import and export system
but it is actually an hardware that gets
shipped to our
premises where we can copy our data into
it and then
ship it back to amazon and amazon would
copy the data
into whatever destination we give them
in our account
and if the data is really huge then i
can call for a snowmobile
which is actually a data center on a
truck where amazon would send me and
truck loaded with the data center as you
see that has compute capacity lots and
lots of storage capacity
and electricity ac and lot more
so they get come parked near our data
center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it
send it back to amazon and they would
copy it to
our account in whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is
really really huge then i would be
calling snowmobile snowmobile is not
available in all the regions
all right let's take this example how
things were before
s3 was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and
one of them is finding it very difficult
to
sort of manage all the data in the
organization
well if the data is small it can be
easily managed but as companies grow
and we are living in an era where data
is everything
we want data to back up every idea we
want data
to back up every proof of concept that
we provide so data is everything so
this era it's all about uh collecting
data analyzing them and
saving you know not losing logs you know
saving them analyzing stuff like that so
coming back to our discussion
here one person finds it very difficult
to store and manage
all the data that they have so some of
the data
that this person is having problem uh
storing is
data's that application used to running
and then
data that gets sent to the customers and
data's that the websites require the
data that are because of
the email backups and a lot more other
storages
that an enterprise can have and this
person is having problem
backing up all those data and even if
we think of increasing the local storage
capacity
that's going to cost the fortune and few
things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity
in-house is you know we will have to go
and
pay heavy to buy hardware and software
to run these storages and
we need to hire a team of experts for
maintaining them
the hardware and the software and
anytime if there is a dynamic
increase in the storage capacity the
on-premises or in-house hardwares won't
be able to scale
and data security data security is very
costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of
it so the other guy in the conversation
was sort of quietly listening
everything the manager was saying and
then he slowly introduced him
to s3 because he knew that all the
problem that this manager was worried
about
can be solved to estimate in other words
all the scalability
all the data security all the
not being able to provision hardware and
software
components are all available with s3 so
that actually brings us to the
discussion about what
s3 is s3 is simple storage
service it actually provides an object
storage
service let me talk to you about object
and block storage
object storage is where you can store
things into drive all right
you can't install anything in it and
this object storage
can be accessed directly from the
internet whereas block storage is
something that
needs to be attached to an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's
a high level difference between object
storage and block storage and s3 is an
object storage
what does that mean we can store data
from the internet we can retry
from the internet but we can't install
anything
in s3 all right so so s3 is an object
based storage and it's it's really built
for
storing and recovering or retrieving any
amount of
data or information from anywhere in the
internet
few other things you need to know about
s3 is that this s3 is accessible
through the web interface the storage
one type of accessing or
one way of accessing s3 is by dragging
dropping content into it and another way
of retrieving
data from s3 is go to a browser click on
download that's going to let you
download
any content and the data can be 5
in size now we're talking about one file
you know you can have hundreds or
thousands of files like that
one file can be as big as five terabytes
in size
and s3 is basically designed for
developers
where they can push logs into s3
or retrieve logs anytime they want
instead of storing locally
in the server they can use s3 as code
repositories
you know where they can save the code
and have the applications read the code
from there and lot more if they want to
safely share the code with another
person
with a lot of encryption and security
added on top of it that's possible as
well
so there are a few things about s3 and
on top of
all these s3 provides 11 9 durability
and 4 9 availability meaning durability
is
if i store the data will it get lost
amazon is like
no it's not going to get lost you're
going to have the data because we
provide 11.9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it
we have 99.99 availability and when you
request the data
we will be able to show the data to you
all right so let's talk about the
benefits of
s3 s3 is durable as we saw it provides
9 durability s3 is low cost out of all
the
storage options in amazon s3
is the cheapest and s3 is very scalable
like we were saying that there's no
required
to pre-provision a storage capacity you
know if you need more go ahead and use
more if you need even more go ahead and
use even more
and once you're done some data needs to
be removed just
remove the data so that particular month
you will be paying less so it's very
scalable in nature and it's very
available as well
s3 isn't regional service you know it's
not based on one availability zone so
one availability zone going down
within amazon the whole availability
going down it's not going to affect
your ability to access s3 storage and s3
is secure a lot of security features
like
bucket policy a lot of security features
like encryption and then
mfa authentication are possible with the
s3 that actually adds a very good
security layer on top of the data that
we have stored in s3
and not only that this s3 is very
flexible in terms of cost
flexible in terms of where i want to
store the data
in terms of cost there are a lot of
pricing tiers within s3
s3 itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of pricing tiers
depending on the durability
so i can always choose to put data on a
different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in the region i can always choose
any of the region available in the
console or in the s3 console to put my
data to
there is no restrictions on where i can
or cannot put the data
in the cloud as long as there are
regions available for me to
move the data to and data transferring
with s3
is very simple all i have to do is
browse to the bucket
upload the data and the data gets
uploaded and
we can also upload data using cli
commands are very similar to linux
commands are very similar to
what we would use in the run command
prompt in windows
and what we would use in the run command
prompt in the powershell
all right let's talk about a basic
building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data and
bucket is the folder where the objects
get stored
let me give you a new definition for
objects so object is
the actual data plus some information
that reference
the data like is it a jpeg file the name
of the file
and at what time it was added to so
they're called metadata
all right so object is actually data
plus metadata and
bucket is actually a container that
receives
the data and safely stores in it and
when we add a data
in a bucket amazon s3 creates an unique
version id and allocates it to the
object so we can easily
identify it at a later point let me show
you a quick lab on s3
all right i'm in the s3 console if
you're wondering how i reached here
go to services under storage and s3 is
right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so i really doubt if simply learn will
be available
let's let's check it anyway
all right it's doesn't seem to be
available so
um let me pick another name or
let's call it simply learn dot
and i'm going to put this in mumbai
or i can choose oregon let me choose
oregon
argon
yes let me choose oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an
object into the bucket
and you know these objects can be as
big as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right
here is a bucket
right here is my bucket and within that
is my object now object is
the actual file plus what type of file
it is
and then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added
and the storage class it is in at the
moment
so if i have to access it
i can simply access it through the
internet so let's talk about how does
this s3 bucket
work anyway all right so how does it
work a user creates a bucket
they will specify the region in which
the bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy
in all the regions amazon provides s3
service
you know beat not virginia beat mumbai
beat tokyo beat sydney
beat argon and we chose aragon to be the
destination region
where we want to create bucket and save
our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case
we picked the default which was a s3
standard
as we saw on the object data it was on
s3 standard
so that's the basic thing later once the
object gets added we can always add
a bucket policies you know policies
define who access it and who should not
access it
what can they access are we going to
allow users only to read
or to read write as well stuff like that
so that's bucket policy
we're defining the life cycle or the
life span
of the data in the s3 bucket now over
the time do you want the data to
automatically move to a different
storage tier and
at any point do you want to sort of
expire the data
you know get the data flushed out of
your account automatically
and those things can be configured in
life cycle policies and version control
is
creating multiple versions if you're
going to use s3 for
a code repository creating multiple
versions
let's say if you want to roll back to
whatever you had
before a month how are you going to do
it if you kept updating the file and
never took a version of it
so version control helps us to keep
different versions
and it helps us to roll back to the
older version
anytime there is a need so let's talk
about the different storage classes
in s3 the different storage classes in
s3
begins with s3 standard now this
is the default and it's very suitable
for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example
if you want to access the data of
students attendance
you would retrieve them very quickly as
much as possible so
that's a good use case to store data in
s3
let's understand the different storage
classes in amazon s3 now let's take
a school for example and uh
the the different data is present in a
school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example
and there are different storage options
in s3 let's take
s3 standard for example and what would
be the actual
candidate data that can be stored in s3
standard let's talk about that so s3
standard in general is suitable for
use cases where the latency should be
very low and
in here the good example or the good
candidate
file that can be stored in s3 is a data
that needs to be frequently accessed
and that needs to be retrieved quickly
something like
students attendance report or student
attendance sheet which we access daily
and then it needs to be
retrieved immediately as and when we
need it the other type of storage chair
in
s3 is infrequent access or infrequent
data access just like the name says
the use case for that is less frequently
accessed
data i mean the candidate data that
should go in
infrequent access data is a student's
academic record
you know which we don't need to access
on a daily basis but if there is a
requirement
we might want to go and look at it and
that's going to be quick so
it's not a data that we would access on
a daily basis
but it's data that needs to show up on
your screen
real quick and the third option is
amazon
glacier now glacier is really an
archival solution
in the cloud so for archives high
performance
is not a requirement so let's talk about
some candidate
data that can go into archives something
like uh students admission fee
and it's not critical also now anytime
if you want to look at the data you can
always
wait to retrieve the data so in other
words you know put it in the archive and
retrieving from the archival takes time
so
students old record are a good candidate
to be put in the archives
the other options are one zone ia
storage class
where the data is infrequently accessed
and the data is stored in a single
availability zone for example you know
by default
amazon stores data in multiple
availability zones
and there is a charge for that now it's
not an option
but the charge includes storing data in
multiple availability zones but if your
data requirement
is you want to keep the charges in a low
even further
you can choose a one zone ia storage
class
where it stores data in one availability
zone
and the candidate data that can go in
one zone
in frequent access is students report
card
and the other option with amazon s3 is
standard
reduced redundancy storage it is
suitable for cases
where the data is not critical
and the data can be reproduced quickly
for example
you know take a copy of the library book
take a copy of the pdf library book
for example now we would have a source
pdf
and we would make copies of it and then
we make it available for
the readers to read the other option in
s3 is reduced redundancy storage
uh here the use case is data that's
not critical and data can be reproduced
quickly for example books in the library
are not that critical and we always have
a copy of the book we're talking about
pdf
so if the customer facing or the student
facing book gets deleted i can always
copy the same pdf
put it in the destination folder and
make it available for the users to read
that would be a very good use case for
reduced redundancy storage
all right let's summarize everything
that we learned about
different uh storage options in s3 so s3
standard
it's for frequently accessed data it's
the default storage if you don't mention
anything the data gets stored in s3
standard
it can be used for cloud applications
you know content distribution gaming
applications big data analytic
dynamic websites they are a very good
use case for
s3 standard frequently accessed data the
other one
on the contrary is s3 standard
infrequently
accessed data just like the name says
the use case
is this is good for data that will be
less
frequently accessed and and then the use
case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data glacier on the
other hand is
very suitable for archiving data which
is
infrequently accessed and the walt lock
feature is the security feature of the
glacier
that also provides a long-term data
storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
tier
with an s3 the other options are one
zone
infrequent access storage class just
like the name says it's infrequently
accessed and it is stored in
just one availability zone and use cases
are
any data that doesn't require any high
level of security
can be stored here in one zone the fifth
storage tier
is reduced redundancy storage this is
good for
data that's frequently accessed it's
good for data that is
non-critical and that can be reproduced
if it gets
lost and reduced redundancy storage or
rrs
is an highly available solution designed
for
sharing or storing data that can be
reproduced quickly all right let's
compare and contrast a couple of other
features that are available in
s3 for example durability availability
ssl support first byte latency and
life cycle management so in standard the
durability
is 11 9 durability it's the same for
standard standard ia one zone ia
glacier except for reduced redundancy
the durability is
11.9 and availability of all the storage
classes
is all the same except for one zone ia
where the availability zone is
99.5 percentage all of these products
support
ssl connection and the first byte
latency of these products are most of
them
provide access with millisecond latency
except for glacier it provides a
retrieval
time of couple of minutes to a maximum
of
hours and all of them can be used for a
life cycle
management you know moving data from one
storage tier to
another storage here that's possible
with all of these
storage options all right now that we've
understood the different
types of storage options available in s3
let's talk about some of the features
that are available on s3
lifecycle management now lifecycle
management
is a service that helps us to define a
set of
rules that can be applied to an
object or to the bucket itself life
cycle
is actually moving the data from one
storage tier to another storage chair
and finally expiring it
and and completing the life cycle of the
object with life cycle management we can
manage
and store our objects in a very cost
effective way
it has two features basically transition
actions and expiration actions
let's talk about transition actions with
transition action
we can choose to move the objects or
move the data from one storage class
to another storage class with lifecycle
management we can configure s3 to move
our data
from one storage class to another
storage class at a defined
time interval or at a defined schedule
let's talk about transition actions in
more detail let's say we have our data
in s3 at the moment and
we haven't used the data for quite some
time and
it's that's how it's going to be for the
rest of the time
so that data is a very good candidate to
move to the
infrequent access because s3 standard is
a bit costlier and s3 in frequent access
is a bit cheaper
than s3 standard so the kind of usage
sort of
fits very well for moving that data into
infrequent access
so using lifecycle transition or
lifecycle management i can move the data
to s3 infrequent access
after 30 days and let's say that the
data stayed in infrequent access for 30
more days and then now i realize that
nobody is
looking into the data so i can find an
appropriate storage tier for that
particular data again
and i can move it to that particular
storage chair which is glacier so in
this case
after 30 days or in a total of 60 days
from the time the data got created the
data can be moved to
glacier and what does this really help
us with the lifecycle management help us
to automatically migrate
our data from one storage cost to
another storage cost
and by that it really helps us to save
the storage cost
lifecycle management can also help us
with the
object expiration meaning deleting the
object
or flushing it out after a certain
amount of time let's say that
our complex requirement requires that we
keep the data for seven years
and we have like thousands and thousands
of data like that
it would be humanly impossible to check
all those
or keep track of all the dates and you
know when they need to be deleted stuff
like that but
with life cycle management it is very
much possible i can simply create a data
and set up lifecycle management for the
data to expire after seven years and
exactly
after seven years the data is going to
expire meaning it's going to be deleted
automatically from the account
all right let me show you a lab on
lifecycle management and let me explain
to you how it
it's actually done so i'm into the
bucket that we have created
and here's our data into the bucket i
assume we have thousands and thousands
of data in the bucket
and that requires to be put in a
different storage tier
over time and that requires to be
expired after
seven years let's say so the way i would
create a lifecycle management is
go to management from inside the bucket
and click on
lifecycle and then add and lifecycle
rule just give it a name
name like expire so all the objects
that's present
in this bucket meaning the current
version of it set a transition
for it so the transition is at the
moment they are in s3
so here i would like to put them in
infrequent access after 30 days
and then after it's been an infrequent
access for 30 days
i would like to move it to glacier all
right plus 30 days so
how do you read it so for the first 30
days it's going to be in
glacier so how do we actually read it
after i put the data in s3 the data is
going to get
moved to standard ia and then it's going
to stay in standard ia
and after 60 days from the data creation
it's going to get moved to glacier so on
the 31st day it's going to move to
standard ia
on the 61st day it's going to move to
glacier let's say if i want to
sort of delete the data if i want the
data
to get deleted automatically after seven
years you know being in a glacier
how do i go about doing it let me open
up a quick calculator
365 into seven that's
2 55 days right after that
the data is going to get deleted pretty
much
i have created a lifecycle so after
on the 31st day it's going to get moved
to infrequent access and on the 61st day
glacier and after seven years is over
any data that i put in the bucket
it's going to get deleted all right
let's talk about bucket policies
bucket policies are some permission
files
that we can attach to an bucket that
allows or
denies access to the bucket based on
what's mentioned in the policy so bucket
policy is really an im policy
where you can allow and deny permission
to an s3 resource with bucket policy we
can also define
security rules that apply to more than
one file in a bucket now in this case
you know we can create an user or let's
say there's already a user called simply
learn
we can allow or deny that user
connection to the s3 bucket
are connecting to the s3 bucket using
bucket policy and bucket policies are
written in json script
and let's see how that's done all right
there are tools available for us
to help us create bucket policies what
you're looking at is a tool
available online that helps us to create
a bucket policy
so let's use this tool to create a
bucket policy i'm going to create a deny
statement i'm going to deny
all actions to the s3 bucket and what is
the arn
to which we want to attach the arn of
the resource is
actually the name of the bucket but it
really expects
us to give that key in a different
format so the arn
is available right here copy bucket arn
so this is actually going to deny
everybody
now we wanted to deny a user just one
user
now look at that now we have a policy
that has been created
that's denying access to the bucket
and it's denying a user called simply
learn pretty much done so i can use
the policy and go over to
bucket policies so once i save it only
the user called simply learn won't have
access
to the bucket and the rest of them will
have access to it
so once they save it it gets added and
only the user simply learn will not have
access to the bucket because we're
denying
them purposefully the other features of
s3
include data protection we can
protect our data in s3 with
now one of which is bucket policy i can
also use
encryptions to protect my data i can
also
use im policy to protect my data so
amazon s3 provides
a durable storage not only that it also
gives
as unprotected and scalable
infrastructure
needed for any of our object storage
requirements
so here the data is protected by two
means one
is data encryption and the other one is
data versioning
data encryption is encrypting the data
so others won't get access or even if
they get access to the file they won't
be able to access the data without the
encryption key
and versioning is making multiple copies
of
the data so let's talk about them in
detail what's data
encryption now data encryption refers to
protecting the data while it is being
transmitted
and protecting the data while it is at
rest
now data encryption can happen in two
ways
one is client encryption encryption at
rest and server side encryption
encryption
that's in motion client-side encryption
refers to
when client sends the data they encrypt
the data and send it across
to amazon and server side encryption is
when the data is being transferred they
get encrypted
and stay encrypted throughout the
transfer versioning is another security
feature
let i mean it helps us so our
unintentional edits are not actually
corrupting
the data for example let's say you
edited the data
and now you realize that the data is
incorrect
and you want to roll back now how do you
roll back without worsening it's not
possible
in other words only with versioning it's
possible so versioning
it can be utilized to preserve recovery
and restore
any early versions of every object that
we stored in
our amazon s3 bucket unintentional
erases or
overrides of the object can be easily
regained if we have
versioning enabled and it's possible
only if we have
one file with the same key name and
anytime
we update the file it keeps the file
name but
creates a different version id take this
bucket and data for example
in a photo.pmg is a file that was
initially stored
it attached a version id to it and then
we edited it let's say we added some
watermark
uh we you know added some graphic to it
and that's now the new version of it
when we store it
we store it with the same file name it
accepts the same file name but
creates a new version id and attaches it
anytime
we want roll back we can always go to
the console
look at the old versions pick the
version id and roll back to the old
version id
all right let's take this example now
i'm in a bucket that we've been using
for a while
and let me upload an object now before
we actually upload an object
this bucket needs to be versioning
enabled so let me version enable this
bucket
from this point onwards this bucket is
going to accept
versioning so let me upload an object
photo.jpg
let me upload it alright it successfully
got uploaded
good enough it's uploaded now
let me upload another object
with the same file name now look at that
it was uploaded at 7 40 35
am let me upload another object with the
same file name
that i have it stored right here that
got up to
uploaded but with the same name
all right so that's the other photo now
what if if i want to switch back
the way i would switch back is simply
switch back to the older version
look at that this is the latest version
and this is the
old version that i have i can simply
switch back to the old version that was
created at such and such time
and i can open it that's going to open
the old file so in short
it creates different version of the data
that i
create as long as it's with the same
name
and at any point i can go and roll back
to the original data this is a very good
use case if you want to use s3 for
storing
our codes let's talk about other feature
like
cross region replication now cross
region replication
is an very cool feature if you want to
automatically keep
a copy of the data in a totally
different region
for you know data durability for any
additional data durability
or if you want to serve data to your
customers
who live in another country or who are
accessing your data from another country
if you want to serve the data with low
latency cross region replication is a
very cool feature that you can use and
get benefited from
and let's see how that's done so before
we actually do a lab on cross region
replication let's put together a proper
definition for it
cross region replication is a feature
that provides automatic
copying of every object uploaded to
our bucket or your bucket source bucket
and it automatically
copies the data to the destination
bucket which is in a
different aws region as you see here in
the picture
i put data only in region 1 it's going
to copy the data to region
2. and for us to use cross region
replication
versioning must be turned on so it
creates
versions and copies the versions as well
if tomorrow
the original region goes down let's say
the other region
will be active and it has the complete
data
that was present in the original region
or at any point if
we want to simply you know cut the
region
replication and use the other bucket as
in standalone bucket
it can be used as well because it
already has all the data
that was present in the master or all
the data that was present in the
original
replication bucket let's see how that's
done so there are two things needed
one is worsening and another one is roll
when we transfer data from
one bucket to another bucket we need
proper permissions
to do so and these roles they give us
proper permissions to transfer data from
one bucket
to another bucket let's see how that's
done right so here's
a bucket a bucket in usr again
let's create another bucket
in mumbai
call it dot mumbai dot com
and put it in uh put it in mumbai
or create that bucket in mumbai there
you go we have one in oregon
we have one in mumbai we're planning to
replicate
or create application between these two
right
create replication between these two
buckets so go to the first bucket go to
management
and start a replication add a rule so
all content in this bucket is going to
get replicated this is my source bucket
it's quite simple select the destination
bucket now my destination bucket is
going to be
simply learn.samuel.mumbai.com
all right it says well you have
versioning enabled in your source bucket
but not on your destination bucket
do you want to enable it now without
which we won't be able to proceed
further so let's go ahead and
enable versioning through the console
that shows up
and then like i said it's going to
require permission
to put data onto the other bucket now i
can
create different roles these are
different roles
that are used for different other
services i can also choose to create a
role
that specifically gives permission only
to
move the data from one bucket to another
bucket
three months it's done so if i go over
to my source bucket
and if i add some data to it
let's say index.html assuming
i'm adding some files to it in theory
they should move to the other region
automatically they go i'm in the mumbai
region
and the data's they got moved to the
other region automatically
let's talk about the other feature
called transfer acceleration
now it's a very handy and a helpful tool
or a service to use
if we are transferring data which is
very long distance from us meaning from
the client to the sd bucket let's say
from my local machine which is in india
if i transfer the data over to
oregon let's say it's a long distance if
it is going to go through the internet
it's going to go through high latency
connections
and my transfer might get delayed if it
is an
uh one gigabit file it's okay but if
we're talking about
anything that's uh you know five
terabyte size
and if you're talking about anything
that's a five terabyte in size
then uh it's not going to be a pleasant
experience so in those
cases i can use transfer accelerator
with which in a secure way but in a fast
way
or a fastest way transfers my data from
the laptop or from client to the s3
bucket and it
makes use of a service called cloudfront
to transfer
or to enable the data acceleration so
the way it would do it
is instead of copying the data directly
to
the location instead of copying the data
directly to the
destination bucket it copies the data
locally
into a cloudfront location which is
available very local
to whatever place we are in and from
there
it copies the data directly to an s3
bucket not going through the internet
that helps eliminate
a lot of latency that could get added
when transferring the data
so let's see how that's done right here
i'm in the s3 bucket
and under properties i can find transfer
accelerator and if i enable transfer
accelerator
so i'm in another bucket let me go to
properties
and let me go to transfer accelerator
and enable transfer accelerator
so now if i put data into this bucket
they're going to get copied to the
local cloud front location and from
there
they're going to get copied to the s3
bucket from the cloud front
now if i need to compare you know how
the speed is going to be
compared to directly putting the data to
the internet and using cloudfront
there is a tool available that actually
runs for a while and then comes with
a report that tells me how much
will be the improved speed if i use
transfer
accelerator and it shows for all the
regions available
in amazon so from the source to the
destination if you want to put
you know what's the normal and what's
the accelerated speed when you transfer
the data
those results we will get in the screen
so at the moment this tool is going
through it
testing like uploading some file through
the internet and uploading some file
using cloudfront
and it has come up with the calculation
that if i'm uploading
file to san francisco compared
to uploading through the internet and
through cloudfront it's 13 times faster
so
similar way it's going to calculate for
all the regions available
and it's going to give me a result
welcome to this new learning series
called
i am a service in aws for security
here in this section we're going to talk
about
what is security in aws and then we're
going to
slowly or gradually move on to the other
topics like
types of security available in aws out
of all the services
why i am is the most preferred one and
then we're going to talk about
what is im in general how it works the
building blocks are components and im
and the features it the the attractive
features that it provides
that makes iam stand out from the rest
of the services available we are going
to talk about that and then we are going
to end today's session
with a demo about how iam gets well
interacted with the
other services in amazon and help create
a secure environment in the cloud let's
talk about aws security now cloud
security
is the highest priority in aws and when
we host our environment in the cloud
we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement
of the most security sensitive
organization
and this high level of security is
available to us
on a pay-as-you-go type meaning there is
really no
upfront cost that we need to pay and
the cost for using the service is lot
lot cheaper than
what it is in an on-premises environment
so aws cloud provides an
a secure virtual platform where
we can deploy our application now
compared to the
on premises with aws the security
level is very high and the cost involved
in using or attaching that type of
security to our application
is very low compared to on premises
there's really no upfront cost
and the cost is very lower whatever cost
that we pay is
very lower than what it would be in on
premises
and all this contributes to the secure
environment we can get through im in aws
cloud
there are really many types of security
services
available in aws to name a few
are to name the familiar ones im
stands first followed by a key
management system kms
and then we have cognito that's another
service
and web access firewall vaf is another
security service
in aws now let's start our discussion by
talking about
im and that's what this whole series is
about now
i am or identity and access management
it really enables
us to manage access to aws services
and aws resources in a very secure
manner with im
we can create groups we can actually
allow those users
or groups to access some service or we
can sort of deny them uh to access the
service whichever we want that's all
possible through identity and access
management and this
feature comes with no additional charge
now let's talk about how things were
before aws
before aws or before i am in general
it was not that safe in a copyright to
share the password over the phone or
through the email that was the practice
that was
existed at that time now we all can
remember the days when we need to switch
to a different account or
we had just one admin password commonly
stored in a location or one person would
reset it and maintain it and any time or
we need to login we call the person
ask for the admin password or the phone
and then we try logging in now that was
not secure at all
back then you know somebody could walk
by and sort of eavesdrop you know get
the password
now they walk away with the password
with them so they're all possible
when we share the password over the
phone and through the internet or email
now with aws a lot of options are
available
that i'm not sharing password over the
unsecure medium now
a slack is a third-party product
available with
aws it's not an aws product but slack is
in third-party application that's hosted
on
aws and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share
documents so now we're not sharing the
password over the phone
rather through the applications and no
eavesdrop
person can really catch the password and
you know try it in their system to
access our environment that's not
possible so you see the difference now
back then
sharing password was only through phone
and email and you would write it on a
paper and you give it to somebody but
now
technology is providing provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way
we're still talking about i am im as an
web service
for securely controlling access to the
aws resource now it really helps us to
authenticate or
sort of limit access to a certain set of
users
accessing the aws account or certain set
of users
accessing a certain set of resources in
aws account
now you see this picture we have an im
administrator
who is trying to allocate permissions to
different group of people so we have
group one on the top and group two
in the middle and group three uh towards
the end the administrator using iam
or iam empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what i
am is all about now let's talk about the
building blocks or let's talk about the
elements that make and complete im so
the elements
are categorized into six different
elements
we have the principle in iam the
authentication
the request the actual request coming in
the authorization
allowing denying access actions what are
the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy too is it
rds is it s3 bucket so what resource
these actions are applied to
so they are the basic elements of an iem
workflow let's talk about principle for
example
an action on aws resource can only be
performed by
a principal an individual user they can
be a principal
a role in aws im it can be a principle
as well
in other words a principal is an entity
that can take an action
on an aws resource you know a principle
can be
an user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the aws environment
secondly
authentication now authentication is a
process of
confirming the identity of the principle
trying to access the aws
environment now how do we get
authenticated or how does a user get
authenticated by
providing credentials or the required
keys to validate that
this is what he or she is as per what's
in the record
so all principle must be authenticated
and we get authenticated using
the username and password to log into
the console if it is cli or we get
authenticated using the access key
and the secret access key the other
component that makes up
im is request when a principal tries to
use
the aws management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is
sending a request to the aws environment
and the request will have the principal
actually wants to perform is it a put
request or is it a get request or is the
delete request
stuff like that and it's also going to
carry information about on which
resource
the action needs to be done is it done
easy to one is it on
s3bucketsimplylearn.com stuff like that
so it has
a specific action that it wants to
perform and the resource
on which it wants to perform and also
some information about
from where the request is originating
from is it within an aws environment or
is it
with another cloud service provider or
is it with on-premises stuff like that
so these information will be
present in the request authorization now
this iam
uses information from the request
context
to check for matching policies and it
determines it takes a decision
whether to allow or to deny the request
now here it has a logic
by default all the resources are denied
and im authorizes your request only if
every part of the request is allowed by
a matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic
that says by default all requests are
denied and if there is an explicit
allow then it overrides the default deny
and if you are explicitly denying a
service
then all the allow statements gets
overridden and
all the other statements gets
overwritten and this explicit deny
stands
by default only the aws account root
user has
access to all the resources in that
account so
if you're not signed in as a root user
then
we must be specifically granted
permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy
now let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request
aws approves the action that we are
about to take now using action
we can view the content we can create
a content or create a bucket or create
an ec2 instance
i can edit content or even i can delete
a resource that's all based on the
action that i'm allowed to do
now that was about actions now where is
the action performed the action is
performed on the resources
a set of actions can be performed on a
resource
and anything that's not mentioned in the
action or anything that's not
tagged with the action and the resource
they don't get to complete
for example let's say if you attempt to
delete an im role
and you also request to access the ec2
instance for that role then
the request gets denied now let's talk
about some of the other
components of im so the other components
are im
are the basic building block is an user
and then
many users together they form a group
and then policies
are the engines that allows or denies
a connection you know based on policy
one gets to access or
gets no access to a resource and then
roles roles are another component rules
are
temporary credentials i would say that
can get assumed to an instance
as and when needed let's talk about this
component called
user in an im with im we can
securely manage access to aws services
and we can create an im user anytime
there is a new employee
joining our corporate so it's a
one-to-one mapping you know one user or
one employee get a username
directly attached to them and a username
or a user is an account specific thing
you know it's very local to that
aws account that we are using so for in
detail
an iem user is an entity that
we create in an aws environment to
represent
a person or a service that interacts
with aws environment
and this user is going to have some
credentials attached to them
and by default they do not have a
password
and they do not have any access key or
secret access key attached to them in
fact
literally no credentials of any kind now
we must create an user and we must
create
the type of credential that gets
attached to the user
do they want to access cli so based on
that we would be adding
credentials to them a user by default is
not authorized
to perform any action in aws
and the advantage of having one-to-one
user
is that we can assign permissions
individually to that
user for example we might want to assign
administrative permissions to few users
who can administer our aws environment
and users are
entity within an aws account users don't
have to pay separately
you know they start using their servers
and that get bills under the account
they are attached to so separate users
doesn't mean that separate
payment for those users they are just
users in our account and
you know the whole account gets to pay
for the resources that they provision
again
the im user does not always represent a
person
an iem user is really just an identity
with associated credential and
permissions attached to it
it could be an actual person who is a
user and it could be an application also
a who is a user next we'll talk about
groups talking about groups or
understanding group is very easy a
collection of
user forms an iem group and we can use
iam group to specify permission for
multiple users so that any permission
that's applied to the group
is also applied to the users who are at
add to that group now there are few
things you might want to know about
group a group
can have many users and a user they can
belong to
many groups but groups can't be nested
meaning group can only have users
you know a group cannot have a group
inside a group that's not possible
and there's nothing called a default
group that sort of automatically
includes all users in the aws account
if you want to have a group then we will
have to create
a group now let's take this diagram for
example now this is a diagram
of an small company now the company
owner creates an
admin group for users to create and
manage other
users as the company expands every day
and the admin group
creates a developer group and a test
group each of these group consists of
users
users who are a people users who are
application that interact with aws
environment so the different types of
users
we have are jim is a user brad
is an user and dev app one is a user
and and so on so each users have an
individual set of security credential
like i said it's one
to one and the uh 10 users that we see
on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account
and managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group
and that permission gets applied to all
the users automatically in the group
and after we applied the policy
if i add another user to the group the
new user will automatically inherit
all the policies all the permissions
that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden
about user a privilege or user
permission management is
sort of taken out with im all right the
next thing we will want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission
and controls the access to aws resource
and
the policies this permissions and
controls are stored in
json format a policy is a very clear
document
it defines who has access to a resource
and what are all the actions
they can perform so in other words
policy is an entity in aws
that when a policy gets attached to an
identity or
a resource you know it really defines
the permission what they can
and cannot do and aws it evaluates these
policies
when a principal such as a user makes an
request and the permission statement and
the policy it really defines
whether the user is allowed to access a
service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this
example now we have a task the task is
to give
paul who's a developer access to amazon
s3 environment
and what you're looking at is a snippet
of what a policy would look like so
these are some questions we will have to
answer or these are some questions the
policy
tries to answer and once it found an
answer
then it becomes a complete policy so who
wants access
to the service it's paul who wants
access to the service
and what action do paul want now paul
wants to
download or paul wants to upload objects
in s3
in json language it's otherwise called
paul wants to
get information paul wants to put
information otherwise paul wants to get
object
paul wants to put object in s3 and which
resource does he want
now in this case every bucket the star
symbol represents
all buckets in x3 so which resource it's
all bucket in x3 so
we can stop reading already from the
data present here so who wants access
paul wants access what action does he
want he wants to get he wants to put
and what's the resource that he's trying
to access or you want to give him access
it's all the bucket in aws and
when does he want these additional
statement that goes
in a policy so since when does he want
that access
he wants access till march 2nd 2019
so all this who all this action all this
resource
you know till the time all this gets
allowed so this is
the statement that really defines now
does this all refer to an allow
statement or does this all refer to a
deny statement if we had deny here it's
the direct opposite of what we discussed
but we have
allow that means ball is allowed to get
and put access in an s3 bucket
and all the buckets in s3 till march 2nd
he's allowed to access the resources so
if we
put together put all the information
that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in a json format this is
how it's going to look like
so the effect is allow
or deny here it's allowing and the
principle uh
is any now who can access it it's any an
action it's any bucket in s3 any action
in s3 put get request and the resource
is
any bucket in s3 so that's how a basic
policy would look like or that's how a
basic policy is formed by answering
those basic questions
so let's talk about the types of
policies so we have two broad categories
managed policy and
inline policy now manage policy it's the
default policy
that we attach to multiple entries be
users be it groups and
beat roles in our aws account on the
other hand
inline policy are the policies that we
create and manage them and these
policies are embedded directly into a
single user
group or a role so if i need to brief
it a little bit more then a managed
policies
are standalone identity based policies
that we can attach to multiple users
groups and roles
in our aws account we can use two types
of managed
policies in other words managed policies
they themselves have two categories
uh one is aws managed policies which is
created and managed by aws and the other
one is
customer managed policies just like the
name says it's managed
by the customer now we can create and
edit an im policy in visual editor or
simply create a json policy document
directly
and upload it in the console and start
using them so that's
manage policy on the other hand inline
policies
are policies that we create and manage
and that are embedded directly into a
single user group or role
let's talk about this next component
called role now this
role is very similar to everything that
we discussed so far
it's a set of permission that defines
what actions are allowed and denied by
an entity in an aws console
the role is very similar to an user
i said very similar i didn't say it's
the same as the user but i said it's
very similar to the user and the
difference is that
user is hard coded user permissions are
hard coded
but the role permissions are accessed by
any entity you know beat a user or a
beat and aws service and moreover the
role permissions are temporary
on the other hand user permissions are
permanent and the role permissions are
temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to
a user in that it's an aws entity
with permission policies that determines
what the identity can
and cannot do in aws now instead of it
being uniquely associated with one
person
a role is intended to be assumable by
anyone who needs it roles generally do
not have an
long term credential you know password
or access keys associated with it you
know it does not have
long term credentials it only has
temporary credentials
created dynamically and provided to the
user as in when
the user assumes a role and wants to
access
any service roles can be assumed by
users
roles can be assumed by applications
roles can be assumed by services that
normally you don't have
access to aws resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your aws
account
access to your resource that they do not
normally have or grant users in one aws
account access to resource in another
aws account now this is something that
we don't have by default and this is
something we may not need
all the time or you might want to allow
a mobile app to use
aws resource but you do not want to save
the key or save the credential or save
the passwords in the mobile app
or sometimes you might want to give
access to resources who
already have identities defined outside
of
aws like a user who's already and google
or facebook authenticator
if you want to give them some service or
if you want to let them to access some
of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose
or you also might want to grant access
to your account to a third party
a consultant or an auditor so they can
for some time get some temporary access
to audit our
aws resources remember they're not
permanent users just temporary users
they want some temporary
access to our environmental the audit is
over so for those cases
roles are a very good use case so let's
take this
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles
give permission to other services so
here is a scenario where
where an ec2 instance wants access to an
s3 bucket by default though both of them
were created by the same username or the
same admin
they do not have access by default so by
default they don't have access
and i also do not want to give permanent
access you know one-on-one hard-coded
permanent access instead i would like to
create and share access so that's
possible to
roll so coming back to the discussion uh
the scenario here is that an ac2
instance
wants to access data in an s3 bucket so
the first thing is to
create a role or a permission we saw how
that's done right using policies
roles use policies policy is the actual
working engine for any permission
related actions
right so create a role with an
appropriate policy
that gives access to s3's
bucket and then launch an ec2 instance
with the role attached to it we said
rules are assumed by any entity right it
could be user it could be an application
it could be a service it could be
another resource in aws account so here
it's another resource in aws account
right so we create a role and we attach
it to an
ec2 instance so now the ec2 instance can
assume the role now the same role can be
attached to another ec2 instance
the same rule can be attached to another
user
database service we get the idea right
rules can be assumed by
anyone so when the ec2 instance wants to
communicate
with s3 it contacts the role and then
the role
gives this ec2 instance some temporary
username and password
that expires after one hour let's say so
it's a temporary
username and password now with that
temporary username and password
the ec2 instance can access the
s3 bucket and access the file
with the credential that it already has
and that credential is a temporary one
and the credential will expire after one
hour or how much ever time the admin
sets it to be
and then the next time when is when an
ec2 instance wants to contact
s3 it will have to contact the role and
the role will propose
a new access key and secret access key
in other words a new credential
with that new credential the second time
the ec2 instance will be able to contact
the
s3 bucket and get the information so the
password
is not a permanent or a one-time or a
hard-coded password it keeps rotating
it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the role
gets
to access the resources on the other end
well let's talk about the features
of iam the main feature of im is that i
can create
separate username and password for
individual
users or resources and i can delegate
access
no those days where we had just one
username and password for admin and we
need to call the other person to get the
username and password over the phone
if it gets compromised you know the
whole account gets compromised stuff
like that those issues are gone
i can create separate username and
password for all thousand users in my
account no more username and password
sharing
i can manage access to all those
thousand accounts in a very simple
and an easy way so im provides
shared access for all the thousand users
in my account
it provides share access to the aws
environment and the permissions that can
be given through im are very
granular now we saw how restrictions can
be
put on get requests you know we can
allow the user to
download information and not update an
information so that's possible through
the iem policies that we looked at
sometime back
and with the use of roles you know we're
authenticating an ec2 instance
instead of the application running on
top of it so if
there are like 10 or 20 applications
running on top of an ec2 instance
instead of creating a separate username
and password for all those 20 instances
i can
create a role and assign that role to
the
ec2 instance and all the applications
running on the ec2 instance
get a secure access to the other
resources use the role credential
that's provided to that ec2 instance now
besides username and password
im also supports multi-factor
authentication
where we provide our credential the
username and password
plus an otp from our phone
or an randomly generated number
that gets displayed in our phone before
amazon console
or before amazon cli would authenticate
and
uh lets us access some of the servers in
the account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's
username and password plus something
else from what you have
im also provides identity federation if
a user is already authenticated with
a corporate ad or facebook or
google you know im can be made to trust
that authentication method and then
allow access
based on that authentication now without
federation what would happen is
the users will have to remember two
passwords you know one for on-premises
and one for cloud anytime they work on
on-premises they'll have to use
one set of password and anytime they
switch to the cloud which is going to be
very frequent in a
every day so anytime they switch to the
cloud they will have to again
type in the cloud username and password
now with identity federation we can sort
of federate or we can
connect both the authentication systems
both on premises and im
so users can just use one username and
password
for both on-premises and cloud
environments and all that
we saw so far it's free to use there is
no additional charge for im
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies its a free service comes along
with any account
imsn pci dss compliant product now im
comes with password policy where
we can reset the password remotely or
rotate the passwords
remotely and we can set rules like
how a user should pick an password it
should not be the one that was used in
the past
any of the past three times stuff like
that so uh you get the idea right how
the features of iam
help us to build and a secure
authentication and authorization
system in or for our aws account
all right it's time to do a quick lab
let's let's put all the
knowledge that we have earned so far
together
and apply it and try a lab and solve the
problem
so here's a problem statement we need to
create an s3 bucket
for a company where users can
read or write the data only if they are
multi-factor
authenticated so there could be like 20
users in an account
but a user is allowed to read or write
a data in an sd bucket only if the user
is
multi-factor authenticated you know this
is a very good use case if we have
sensitive data in an s3 bucket and you
only want
privileged or mfa authenticated users to
do changes to those buckets and for
those privileged users you would
enable multi-factor authentication so
let's see how that's done
before that let me talk to you a bit
more about multi-factor authentication a
multi-factor authentication is that
additional
level of security process it's provided
by
aws here the user's identity is
confirmed only after
the user proposes or the user passes
to level of verification now one being
the username and password and
another being an otp that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an
rsa token key that generates the
one-time password that's possible as
well but in this case it's the mobile
phone now that's going to be very
similar to how we log in to our gmail
account sometimes when we log into a
gmail account
and i mean if you have the proper
setting enabled
it's going to send an one-time password
to mobile phone and only after we put
that information it's going to let us
log in
let's see how all this is done in an aws
account so
the first thing is to log in to the aws
account
create a user and attach the user to the
virtual
mfa device now we're going to use google
authenticator here and we're going to
attach the user
to google authenticator and make the
user use
the google authenticator one time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition
to the username and password that he or
she already has
right so the first thing is to log into
the account connect
or sync the virtual appliance with the
aws
username and password now when we sync
there will be an
one-time password that gets shown in the
phone type in the password in the aws
console
and then the phone and the username
comes to sync
and from that point onwards the user
anytime they log in
they will have to propose their username
and password which is the first
step of security and then once they
typed in the username and password
type in the mfa code that gets generated
on the phone
that would be the second step or
security or the last step of security
once that is done
the account is going to let them log in
and access the aws resources
alright so in order to test im mfa
s3 together this is what we are going to
do so we are going to
create a bucket and we're gonna have two
users
and we're gonna allow or deny access to
the s3 bucket
to those two users based on whether they
are mfa authenticated or not
and on purpose uh we're gonna assign mfa
to one user and no mfa to the other user
like
you might have guessed by now the user
with mfa will have access to the bucket
and the user
with no mfa attached will not have
access to the bucket
both of them are going to have full s3
services but mfa like i said
is one layer above the other permissions
mfa stands at all time so irrespective
of whether the underlying policy says
but they have full access to the s3
bucket they're not going to because
mfa stands on top of it let's see how
that's done to begin with firstly
we need a bucket so let's create a
bucket
so i'm in my aws console
so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as
simply learn mfa bucket and let me put
it in
north virginia and create
all right so that's done now i'm going
to put a separate folder
in here
i'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is
tax documents now this is where i'm
planning to keep my
tax files
and i only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document
so on the bucket side it's partially
done or on the sd side it's partially
done so let's go back to iam
and here we're going to create two users
one a junior
employee and another one and a senior
employee
the senior employee is the one who is
going to have mfa access
and more access to the s3 bucket
and the junior employee is the one who's
not going to have
access to that particular bucket so
let's get started
let's create an user under iam
click on users and let's create a user
called as user
junior
right so he's a junior user
and for the password set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in
because it's a test environment and the
user who creates
the username and the user are the same
person so let's
keep it simple username password
management console access
and this user is going to have full s3
bucket access all right this is really
the policy
and we should be familiar with this json
document
by now it says effect is allowed and
what action any action in s3
and what resource anybody who is
attached to it
review and create a user
so this user is having s3
full access now let's create another
user call them as
senior employee
all right attach a policy
to the user you know from the surface
level both of them have the same
permissions both of them have
s3 full access
all right so both of them have s3
full access as we see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this senior
employee now we're going to attach mfa
to this employee so
the way we would do it is under the
summary section
of that particular user click on
security credential
and see here is a place we can attach an
mfa to this user
so let's attach mfa to this user for mfa
i can use both virtual mfa or hardware
mfa
this being in lab environment we're
going to use virtual mfa
now that is an application there are a
lot of applications available but there
is one application
that i'm using at the moment called
google authenticator
so once we have installed the
application
now once it is running
so i can go to virtual mfa device and
once it is running
i can scan the code using the google
authenticator in my mobile phone
once you turn on the application and
once you do scan the barcode that
is showing right here now that's going
to give us
codes that we can use and we will have
to put in
those codes here twice we'll have to
wait for some time
and it would generate a second set of
key that we can put
so my first set of key is four zero two
three five one right i'll have to wait
for some time and then it would throw me
a second set of key
it's like validating twice right here so
let me put in my second set of key
so this user is now mfa authenticated
user so
anytime this user logs in it's going to
ask for mfa anytime this user proposes
something
it's going to attach the mfa key along
with it
all right so we're done with iam what
have we done with im we have created two
users
both of them have actually full access
but
one of them have mfa access
and the other one does not have mfa
access and based on whether the user is
having mfa or not
you know we're identifying privileged
users by this mfa all right so based on
whether the
user has mfa or not are we going to
allow deny access
in the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged
folder part here i would like to
restrict access based on whether the
user is having
mfa or not so let me create a bucket
policy here
now here's a policy that i have written
the policy says that you know under tax
document
folder give access only if
the user is mfa authenticated right if
the user is not mfa authenticated simply
deny
the access to that user so as you might
guess right now
the user one will not have access or the
junior employee will not have access
because it's a privilege then
you know junior employee might tend to
delete them unknowingly
and only privileged users get access to
the
tax document because it's confidential
because it's privileged
because if it gets deleted we won't be
able to get it back
for those reasons right so apply the
bucket policy
now try logging in as the different
users
and see how the permissions are applied
on both the users
all right so let's make a note of the im
url
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me login as the privileged user
sure enough i'm being asked for an mfa
code let me put my mfa code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough i'm able to upload content
into it
will i be able to delete
yes i'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation
for the other user
so let's login as the other user
navigate to the sd bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for mfa
so navigate to the folder which we want
to test
now try adding some files
as you see it's failing to add content
to this bucket it shows error because
the bucket policy is requiring
mfa and this user is not mfa and we did
that in iam or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view
the content in the bucket they can do
all that we have specifically restricted
access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user
is now denied with welcome to this new
video lesson
where we're going to learn about plot
formation in this section we're going to
learn about
why we need a solution called cloud
formation or why we need a product
called cloud formation
and we're going to talk in detail about
what is cloud formation
and then how cloud formation works and
the concepts
involved in cloud formation like you
know templates and
stacks there are some concepts involved
in cloud formation we're going to talk
about that
and how do we maintain access control
over the cloud formation we're going to
talk about that as well
in this video and then we're going to go
through a demo or a lab
where we create an lamp stack
environment from a template
through cloud formation and then we're
going to talk about some
use cases one of which include being
able to create
an redeployable template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about
why cloud formation so when the number
of products and services
grow more and managing them and
maintaining them becomes and tedious
work and cloud formation it sort of
eases
that environment now cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a code
and it sort of solves all the problem
that
we discussed some time back and with
cloud formation
we can actually create a perfect clone
of the server configuration
at any point in time and we can also
manage the configuration changes and
configuration changes with cloud
formation we can manage the
configuration changes
across the environment and not only that
we can easily
embed in the ad hoc changes to our
existing environment
so one might ask why use cloud formation
let's look at the current problem that
we have
creating and managing multiple aws
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace
some services it becomes a bigger task
now cloud formation eases that work let
me explain it in detail
now at the moment without the cloud
formation or environments that don't use
cloud formation
have this problem that is a lot of time
is being spent on building the
infrastructure
and less focus and less time at the
moment is being given on
developing that application that runs on
that environment that's because
majority of the time is consumed by
building the environment
and if we need to redeploy the same
environment again and again the same
happens in a cycle again in a new
environment we start from the scratch
build environment and then put
application on top of it now that can be
avoided
using cloud formation now without cloud
formation still is a problem because the
the resource or the bandwidth that is
needed for the application development
is not provided because that's taken
by developing the infrastructure and to
solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about
what is cloud formation so let's talk
about or let's try understanding what
cloud formation is
cloud formation is a service that
provides users a simple
way to create and manage collection of
aws resources by provisioning and
updating them in a
very orderly and in a predictable way if
i need to expand
explanation of cloud formation cloud
formation is an
service that really helps us to model
and set up our
amazon web services or resources so we
can spend less time on managing the
resources
and show more focus on the application
that runs on top of it we can simply
create a template for
an ec2 instance or for an rds instance
and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation
will provision and configure those
resources
based on the template that we define we
really don't have to
sort out the complexities in dependency
between those applications once the
template is vetted and validated cloud
formation
takes the responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application
in an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services
and makes it available for us once the
template is fully run
so in short at the cloud formation it
allows us to create and model our
infrastructure
and applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called expedia is
able to easily manage
and run its entire front and back end
resources they run on aws in cloudfront
what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
the infrastructure and more time
on the core business and the application
that runs on top of it
and we're still talking about what cloud
formation is
with cloud formation it enables us to
manage our complete infrastructure or
aws resource in a text file
now we're going to see that in a moment
you know it's either a json or an
yml file and that file is called as the
template to begin with the resources
the template provision is called the
stack
all right so the abstract of the code is
called the template and the resource
that it provisions is called the stack
and this stack can be i mean it's going
to run resources
obviously and those resources can be
updated as well it's not like once you
create a stack gets done if you need a
change you need to go create another
resource that's not needed
this stack is an updatable stack let's
say if i'm including two more servers
if i'm sort of extending my environment
it's branching out to another
application
now i'm including another functionality
in my environment all those
can be embedded in the update and can be
updated
so like i said the stack is an updatable
one now let's talk about
what the template can do or some
features and functionality
of the template now using a template we
can almost
include all the application and
resources that a user
might require let's say you know after
the easy to instance is provision
running an application on top of it and
you want to templatize
that and include that in the template
that's possible as well
and these templates are portable ones
meaning i can use the template in one
region
and i can use the same template in
another region
and that's going to build a very similar
environment in another region i can also
share that with the customer and when
they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care i'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource
if you need to build an architecture if
you need to build an environment which
looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible
and and these templates are usable by
the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about
parameters mapping and conditions down
the line we're still talking about
aws how aws cloud formation works and
we're going to talk about how a template
becomes an infrastructure right so to
begin with one requires a template and
the template
would be in json or yml format so one
would
develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of
ec2 instances based on whether they want
a load balancer
based on what they want and a windows
server
based on whether they want an database
server in that environment
and then based on the applications that
will be running on top of it that can be
templatized
in the code itself so one creates a code
and then
the code is saved locally or they can be
put in an s3 bucket from which the cloud
formation will call the template
and provision the resource right so we
use cloud formation
uh to create a stack or create the
resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes
the template first validates template
and then it identifies
the uh dependencies between them and
then it starts provisioning the resource
one after the other for example
if you need a five servers in a new vpc
obviously it's going to create the vpc
first and servers
second and stack all right let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation
by now you might have guessed it the two
major components are
the template and the stack together the
aid or the complement cloud formation
and that's how the resource of provision
that's how the resource are managed
and that eases the job of the
administrator who's managing the
environment so let's talk about template
first
a template in cloud formation is an text
file or a formatted text file
in json or yml language and
that the code or the template or the
text file that actually describes
how your infrastructure looks like or
will look like
once provision and for us to create the
template
or for us to modify an existing template
we can use
a tool available called cloud formation
designer
from the console or any text editing
tool that's available but i would
recommend the cloud formation designer
though that has
rich graphics in it and these templates
are built
off or they consist of nine main
objects the first of which is the format
version
and this really identifies the
capabilities
of the template based on the version
number and then the second
object in a template would be
description and this helps us to include
any arbitrary comments about the
template for
what reason are we building this
template what's the purpose of it stuff
like that
and then we have the object called
metadata in a template
and that includes a details about the
template details of the resources in the
template
and then we have the optional parameter
section this really helps us to
customize
our template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time
we create or update and stack and the
mapping
object it helps us to match a key to a
corresponding
set of named values for example if you
want to set
a value based on region then
we get to create a mapping that uses
region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify
for each specific regions and then we
have
conditions object this is again an
optional
object with this we can include
statements that define
when a resource is created or when a
property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition
we can conditionally create additional
resources and then the object called
transform
it's it's an optional object as well and
this transform section specifies one or
more transforms
that we can use in our cloud formation
template for example
uh aws cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the aws
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables
reuse of template components for example
we can
condense multiple line resources
declaring
it into a single line in our template
now we will talk about
all these examples in the upcoming
slides
and then we have the required section
called
resource that declares the aws resource
that you want to include in the stack
for example
if you want to include an ec2 instance
if you want to include a nested bucket
we would be using the resource object in
our stack and then we have
object called output this output object
it's an optional object in the template
and it helps us to
sort of declare the outputs that we can
import into other stacks or we can
actually show it on the cloud formation
console for example
if you want the output of the or the
name of the s3 bucket that got created
in response to a cloud formation
template now we can have that
outputted into an output section in the
cloud formation
console itself so it's sort of easy for
us to identify the resources
that the template provisioned so with
all of those objects put together
this is how a full-blown clot formation
template
with all the objects included is going
to look like now this
includes optional and mandatory object
let's talk about those objects in detail
in the upcoming section
all right let's now discuss each and
every object of this
template structure and let's begin our
discussion
with the format version the format
version it really defines the
capabilities of the template
the latest version format version as of
now is the one that was updated on
2010. now the value of the template
format version it has to be and string
and if we really don't uh specify the
format version
cloudformation automatically assumes the
latest version
talking about description descriptions
are really any comments that
help ourselves that we want to ember in
the template itself
that can be a description and this
description in a template it has to be
an string length of the string can be
between
0 to 124 bytes in length the metadatas
are really used in the template to
provide
any additional information using the
json and
yaml objects and metadata holds some
implementation
details of a specific resource
and parameters are really a way to
customize the template each time we
create or update
our stack these parameters are the ones
that helps us to give some custom value
to the template during
runtime in the example shown below the
parameter named
instance type parameter it lets us to
specify the ec2 instance type
for the stacks to use when creating or
updating the stack by default as we see
it's picking t2 micro and this is the
value that will get picked if we don't
provision another value to it and
mapping mapping really enables us to map
a key to a corresponding named value
that
we specify in a conditional parameter
and also we can detrive the map or to
try the values in the map
using the function find in map instrict
function
let's take this example let's say based
on a region
if you want to set values in a template
we can create a mapping that
uses a key and holds the value that you
want to specify for each
region and the object conditions can be
used when we want to
reuse the templates by creating
resources in a totally different context
for example in a template
during stack creation all the conditions
that we mentioned in the template
are evaluated and any resources that are
associated
and that come up to be true are created
and any condition that fails or invalid
are
kind of ignored automatically and the
check moves forward to the next
condition
and conditional is an optional object
and it includes statement that define
when a resource is created or when a
property is actually defined for example
you can create whether for example you
can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition
we can conditionally create resources if
you have multiple conditions then they
are generally separated with
commands sometimes conditions are very
helpful when we want to
create templates and we want to reuse
those templates
which was created for one environment to
another environment for example if you
want to
use a template that was created in a
test environment
in a dev environment conditions would be
helpful for example in a production
environment we might want to include
instances with certain uh capabilities
and
in a test environment we might want to
include instances with
some reduced capability in them for
saving money and condition
helps us to sort of create resources
based on the environment
it will be used in we can also use
intrinsic functions to define conditions
like
equals we can also use r conditions we
can
use not functions intrinsic functions in
a condition
and when put together the syntax is
going to look like the one that you see
on the screen
now the optional object called transform
it specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple declarative
language
of aws cloud formation with a powerful
macro system
that helps us to reuse the templates or
the template components
and they really help us to condense or
simplify
our codes by enabling reuse of the
template components for example
condense a multiple line resource
declaration into a single line
in our template the resource section it
really declares the aws resource that
you want to include
in the stack such as ec2 instance such
as
s3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are the logical id
the resource type and the properties
let's talk about
them in brief the logical id is unique
within
the template and the logical id name it
actually
reference the resource in other parts of
the template
in this case it's my bucket for example
i know if we want to map an
elastic block store volume or if you
want to map and
uh name of the bucket uh in another
place in
the uh template now then we would use
the logical id and again in this case it
is my bucket
a logical name has the physical id uh
with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case my s3 bucket was named as my bucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies that the type
of the resource
is an s3 bucket and the properties are
the additional
optional information that we can specify
to our resource for example if it is an
ec2 instance let's say
we would like to know which ami it used
then property section
really defines the ami that was used or
ami
as the property of the instance so this
section describes the
output value that needs to be imported
to other stacks
or the output value that needs to be
shown in the console
for the user to easily navigate to the
resource that are being created
for example for a s3 bucket name
we can declare an output and once the
bucket is created
we can actually declare the output and
sort of
uh import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console
so it's it's easy to view instead of you
know the user getting confused and
going to s3 and searching for the bucket
name this can be made available in the
cloud formation console itself and the
output fields it can include some of
these followings like the logical id
uh it's actually the identifier of the
current
output and it's very unique within the
template and it can also include
a description description is really a
string type that describes the output
value
and it can also include value and value
is the
property that was returned by the aws
cloud formation describe
stacks command all right let's talk
about template
resource attribute in this section we're
going to
talk about attributes that you can add
to a resource to control additional
behavior and relationships so let's talk
there are
many resource attributes available out
of which we have
i mean if we need to name them we have a
creation policy
and then we have deletion policy it
depends on
metadata attribute update policy
attribute let's talk about each of them
separately when we associate the create
policy attribute with the resource it
actually delays the resource
configuration actions
before proceeding with the stack
creation
i mean the attribute stack creation is
delayed till the time
the cloud formation receives some number
of success signals
back i mean this is a very good use case
when we do auto scaling
and this creation policy can be used
only with a
limited number of services like auto
scaling and ec2 instances
some of the use cases would be if you
want to install and software application
on an ec2 instance you might
want the applications to be running
before it proceeds further so in this
case we would use the creation policy
attribute
to the instance and then send the
success signal
after the applications are installed and
configured then cloud formation
goes to the next step here in the syntax
that we're looking at
the auto scaling creation policy and the
minimum successful instance percentage
it's actually a number of signals that
it will have to reply back
before it can move forward using
deletion policy
it preserves backing up of resources
when the stack is getting
deleted and by default if you don't have
a delete policy
the data gets deleted just like that but
if we use
an deletion policy we would be able to
preserve
the data by taking a snapshot of it or
just letting the resource and moving on
with deleting the other resources in the
stack
and we specify the delete policy
attribute for each resource specifically
that we want to control and if there are
no deletion policy
mentioned for a particular resource the
cloud formation simply deletes
their resources as that's its default
behavior
and if you want to keep the resource
when the stack is deleted we use
we mention retain in the delete policy
and that simply retains
the resource from getting deleted so in
this example we're actually retaining
a dynamodb table rest of the resources
in the stack
will get deleted and using that depends
on attribute
we actually create a an order
in which the resource gets deleted for
example if i map one resource to another
resource and say that
this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first
then followed by this instance or this
resource
so with the depends on attribute we can
specify that the creation of specific
resource is actually followed by an
another when we add the depends on
attribute to a resource the resource is
created
only after the creation of the resource
specified
by the depends on attribute let's take
this example
in this example we're saying that the
resource x
depends on why we've said that x depends
on y
so in this case when cloud formation is
executing it's going to deploy
y first because it has some resources
that depends on it so it's going to
create y first
and then it's going to create the
resource called x on the same context
let's say in the template we say that an
ec2
is going to depend on s3 and when the
cloud formation is executing it's going
to create an s3 bucket first
and then the ec2 instant that's probably
because
the codes needed for the ec2 instance
are stored in the s3 bucket
and and what we're looking at is the
syntax
of how the depends on template resource
attribute
will look like this is how it actually
will look like
when we put it in the cloud formation
the instance depends on
the bucket the other template resource
attribute is
metadata metadatas are the one that
really helps us to associate
our resources with the the structured
data and by including this attribute in
our template
or by including this attribute to a
resource we can specify
the data in json or in yaml language for
example
in this section of the template we're
creating a vpc and
the metadata explains our metadata
defines that the vpc is part of the
region
us east one and the update policy
template resource attribute and cloud
formation
we can manage and replace the updates of
the instance
in an auto scaling group for example
you're looking at
this sample where it says that the
update policy
will it replace the instance in an auto
scaling
group or not so depending on what the
value is for the will replace section
whether it's true or false
depending on that the update policy will
replace the instance or will replace
the auto scaling group itself when it's
doing and rolling deployment
now that we've discussed about templates
let's talk about
aws stacks as well now we know that aws
stacks
are the actual resources that yes
generated
or that gets created because we ran a
template right so stack is a collection
of aws resource
that we can manage in a single unit in
other words
you know we can create a stack update a
stack or delete
a stack and that would actually create
update delete the collection of
resources within the stack and all the
resources in the stack
are really defined by the cloud
formation template and a stack for
instance can include all the resources
required
to run a web application such as a web
server
a database server and some networking
rules that come along with it all that
gets embedded in a stack and let's say
if we want to delete all the resources
that were created by template that is in
a separate stack we can simply delete
the stack and that would sort of delete
all the resources that
is in the stack so it sort of helps us
to manage all the resources
in a single unit or as a single unit so
to summarize stack is a collection of
aws resource
and it can be managed as a single unit
and the cloud formations template
defines a stack
in which the resource can be created
deleted or updated in a very predictable
way and a stack can have all the
resources like web server
database server vpc the network and the
security
configurations in a vpc all that is
required to run a web or a database
application
now stack could be nested as well with
cloud formation
we can actually nest a stack with
another stack
and that's going to create an hierarchy
of the stacks for example
i mean this is a very good picture that
explains how the stacks are
nested in a hierarchical way let's say
stack p
is the root stack and that could be
a parent stack for the stack called
r and the stack call q and the same way
the stack call r is a parent stack for
the stack s
and the stack s is the parent stack for
d and q
you get that right so stacks can always
be nested it's possible cloudformation
allows
us to create a microsoft windows stack
based on
amazon ec2 windows amis and provide
us with the ability to install software
and use
remote desktop to access our stack and
update the configuration of our stack
and these stacks can be run on windows
server instances
there are a number of pre-configured
templates available
and it's directly available to use from
the aws website itself to name a few we
have templates available for
sharepoint running on an uh windows
server 2008 r2 we also have templates
that create a single server installation
of active directory
running on a windows server and in fact
we have templates available for
elastic bean start and some sample
applications that runs from an windows
server 2008 r2
let's talk about stack sets stacks sets
actually has taken the stack level
implementation to the next level
using the aws cloud formation template
we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack
in aws account across the globe by using
just a single template and after we
create the stack or
after the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack
in the target account and the regions
can also be
specified by us so the stack said it
really extends the functionality
of the stacks by allowing us to create
update and delete stack across multiple
accounts
regions in just a single operation and
using
an administrator account we can define
and manage an aws cloud formation
template and use the template as the
basis for provisioning stacks into
you know some selected target accounts
across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control
with im i can specify the list of users
or list of privileged users who would
have access to the cloud formation
template who can create
update and delete stack so that's how im
helps me with
having or putting a layer of control
over
the cloud formation service and we can
also use service roles
service roles are the one that allows
aws cloud formation to make a call to a
resource
in a stack on the user's behalf and i
can also have stack policies
and these stack policies are applied to
the users who already have
access to the cloud formation service
and these policies
are the ones that help the users who
attempt to update
the stack all right let's do a quick lab
on creating and lamp
stack on an ec2 instance with a local
mysql
database for storage now we can do the
other way as well
i can pick an ec2 instance and install
the servers
one top of the other that can be done as
well but that's going to take a lot of
time now we're talking about automating
it
we're talking about you know
provisioning and infrastructure
using a code and cloud formation helps
us to do that
so this is what we're going to do we're
going to create or we have an
cloudformation template already
and we're going to use that template the
provision web instance
and that is going to have look at that
that's going to have
my sql installed in it that's going to
have php that's going to have
httpd servers installed in it and
running
and it's also going to have an a php
website
running from it so that's going to
receive information from the website
and that's going to store that
information in the database
that's very local to it this is the
template
that defines that environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision
this environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and which region is it this is in
california is it all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the mumbai region
or let me switch to north virginia
region
not virginian from here actually let me
switch to mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same template that we
are provisioning
all right let's give this a name so it
can be great
this could be simply learn simply learn
lamp stack
and what could be the db password
and db root password and what could be
the db user
i'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and i'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
[Music]
password should only have alpha numeric
characters get that so let's go back
and create a new password
it also needs to have eight characters
so what can be your password
look at that the template is actually
creating the resources
and here in the screen we can see the
template that we used to deploy
the environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about instant
types in parameters right the default
instance type is t2 small
but these are also allowed to run
all right parameter section is the one
that was
used to receive information from us like
the db name
the db password the db root password the
user instance type
key name and ssh locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually
created right looks like it's rolling
back
why would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any
if there is an interruption that it
could not proceed
it would simply roll back and delete all
the resources that it had provisioned
and that's what it did
now let me fix this
all right as a fix i have switched
the regen because i had some issue with
the vpc
that's going to take time for me to
analyze and fix it so here we're going
to understand
about cloud formation so i thought i'll
run the cloud formation from
another vpc that i know is working fine
that's in not virginia all right let's
provision this
lamp server which is running out of
linux which has apache installed in it
which has php
and mysql already installed in it so one
server gonna act as web
and db server
all right so i'm going to create a stack
and
from here i'm going to pick a sample
stack
if we look at if we look at it in the
designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security
attack security group attached to it
there you go
right so let's go ahead and create a
stack
all right parameters are used to
receive input from us
what could be the db password
and the db user
and let's select the key name
right i'm going to keep the rest as
defaults
and i'm going to create a stack
all right so our stack
that we run from the template at the
moment
it's getting created it's in progress
from here i can watch the events as to
what is getting created
at the moment like i said in a lot of
these
would have already sorted out their
dependencies
you know which one needs to get created
first which one needs to
get created second all that is sorted
out by
cloud formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted and a resource
tab is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment
so to begin with it created a security
group at the moment it's creating an
instance
and output it's empty as of now
we're going to come back and see it now
output is where
we can get outputs of a finished job
let's say
here i wanted an url
of the server that got created so
instead of me
you know going to a couple of other
places within the console
and find the output of
the url or the
the output of the resource that was
created i can simply get it from here
well this needs to be defined in the
templates first
once we define it in the template it's
going to be made available
like here right so i can
open it up and
there you go so it has it already has
a database locally installed and it's
connected to where if i launch an
application on top of
it that will get connected to the
database which is very local
and my single
server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
uh creating an environment like this
which has elastic load balancer
a vpc a server running in an auto
scaling group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ec2
instance directly but
they should be able to access the ec2
instance or the data
only through the elastic load balance so
this is a bit complicated
than the environment that we've already
created let's see how this is done
all right in this lab we're going to
create elastic load balanced
auto scaling group which is going to
create a load balancer and an auto
scaling group and that auto scaling
group receives
traffic only from the load balancer
so here's the template and here's the
architecture that we're going to
provision
let me call it right and the key pair
it's going to use is
simply learn key pair now this is where
the problem was
now we were selecting few subnets
so now if i provision it
now this is going to take its short time
to provision
the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good no rollback
no no deletes and the resource section
shows the resource that
it is creating so previously created a
target group now it's creating
the application load balancer itself
all right so it created an um load
balancer and then it created a security
group
it created a launch configuration it at
the moment it's creating a web
server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow
green ones are completed yellow ones are
in progress
we don't have any red delete or roll
back
errors so it looks good all right it
took a while
and the resources have
been created some of them show that they
are in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output
to access the url
there you go and remember there was
another feature of the cloud formation
that was
it should restrict access i mean direct
access to ec2 instance
let's see if that has been done if i try
to access using the load balancer
it lets me access but if i try to access
it
using the ec2 instance ip
or the dns name my connection won't go
through
because it's blocked through the
security group but direct access
through the load balancer is allowed and
that's what we wanted to achieve
through that template here we're going
to talk about amazon
ecs a service that's used to manage
docker
containers so without any further ado
let's get
started in this session we would like to
talk about some basics about aws
and then we're going to immediately dive
into why
amazon ecs and what is
amazon ecs in general and then
it uses a service called docker so we're
going to understand what
docker is and there are competitive
services available
for ecs i mean you could ecs is not the
on and only service to manage docker
containers
but why ecs advantage of ecs we will
talk about that
and the architecture of ezs so how it
functions what are the components
present
in it and what are the functions that it
does
i mean each and every component what are
all the functions
that it does all those things will be
discussed in the architecture
of amazon acs and how it works how it
all
connects together that's something we
will discuss and what are the companies
that are using ecs what were the
challenge
and how ecs helped to fix the challenge
that's something we will discuss and
finally we have a wonderful lab
that talks about how to deploy docker
containers on
an amazon ecs so let's talk about what
is
uh aws amazon web service
in short called as aws is an
web service in the cloud that provides a
variety of services
such as compute power database storage
content delivery and a lot of other
resources
so you can scale your business
and grow not focus more on your it needs
and
the rest of the id demands rather you
can focus on your business
and let amazon scale your it or let
amazon
take care of your it so what is that you
can do with aws
with aws we can create deploy
any application in the cloud so it's not
just deploying you can also
create your application in the cloud it
has all the tools and services required
the tools and services that you would
have installed in your laptop or you
would have installed in your
on-premises desktop machine for your
development environment
you know the same thing can be installed
and used from the cloud so
you can use cloud for creating and not
only that
you can use the same cloud for deploying
and making your application available
for your end user the end user could be
internal internal users the end user
could be the could be in the internet
the end user could be kind of spread all
around the world
it doesn't matter so it can be used uh
to create and deploy
your applications in the cloud and like
you might have guessed now it provides
service over the
internet that's how your users worldwide
would be able to use the service that
you create and deploy right so it
provides
service over the internet so that's for
the
end customer and how will you access
those services that's again
through the internet it's like the
extension of your data center
in the internet so it provides all the
services in the internet it provides
compute service through the internet so
in other words you access them through
the internet
it provides database service through the
internet over the internet in other
words you can
securely access your database through
the internet
and lot more and the best part is this
is
a pay as you go or pay only for what you
use there is no long term
or you know beforehand commitment
here most of the services does not have
any
commitment so there is no long-term and
beforehand
commitment you only pay exactly for what
you use there's no overage there's no
overpaying
right there's no buying in advance right
you only pay for
what you use let's talk about what ecs
is
so before ecs before containers right
ecs is a service that manages docker
containers
right it's not a product or it's not a
feature all by itself
it's a service that's dependent on
docker container
so before docker containers all the
applications were running on
vm or on a host or on a physical machine
right
and that's memory bound that's latency
bound
the server might have issues on and on
right so let's say this is alice and
she's trying to access her application
which is running somewhere
in her on premises and the application
isn't working
what could be the reason some of the
reasons could be memory full
the server is currently down at the
moment we don't have another physical
server to launch the application a lot
of other reasons
so a lot of reasons why the application
wouldn't be working in
on premises some of them are memory full
issue and
server down issue very less a high
availability or in fact single point of
failure and no
high availability if i if i need to tell
it correctly with easiest the services
can kind of breed free right the
services can
run seamlessly now how how is that
possible
those thing we will discuss in the
upcoming sessions
so because of containers and ecs
managing containers
the applications can run in a high
available mode they can run in a high
available mode meaning
if something goes wrong right there's
another container that gets spun up
and your application runs in that
particular container
very less chances of your application
going down that's what i mean this is
not possible with
a physical host this is very less
possible with an vm or at least it's
going to take some time for another vm
to get spun up so why ec is or what is
ecs
amazon ecs maintains the availability of
the
application and allows every user to
scale
containers when necessary so it not only
meets the availability of the
application meaning
one container running your application
or one container hosting your
application should be running all the
time
so to meet that high availability
availability is
making sure your service is running 24
7. so
container makes sure that your services
run 24 bar 7
not only that not only that suddenly
there is an increase in demand
how how do you meet that demand right
let's say you have like thousand users
suddenly the next week there are like
2000 users
all right so how do you meet that demand
container makes it very easy for you to
meet that demand in case of vm
or in case of physical host you
literally will have to go buy another
physical host
or add more ram add more memory add more
cpu power to it
all right or kind of club two three
hosts together
clustering you would be doing a lot of
other things to meet that
high availability and also to meet that
demand
but in case of uh ecs it automatically
scales the number of containers
it automatically scales the number of
containers needed
and it meets your demand for that
particular r
so what is amazon ecs the full form
of ecs is elastic container
service right so it's basically a
container management service
which can quickly launch and exit
and manage docker containers on a
cluster
so it's the function of ecs it helps us
to quickly launch
and quickly exit and manage
docker container so it's kind of a
management service
for the docker containers you will be
running in
amazon or running in the aws environment
so in addition to that it helps to
schedule the placement of container
across your cluster so it's like this
you have two
physical hosts you know joined together
as a cluster
and ecs helps us to place your
containers now where should
your container be placed should it be
placed in host 1 should be placed in
host 2. so that logic
is defined in ecs we can define it you
can also let
ecs take control and define that logic
most cases
you will be defining it so schedule the
placement of containers across your
cluster let's say two containers want to
interact
heavily you really don't want to place
them in two different hosts
right you would want to place them in
one single host so they can interact
with
each other so that logic is defined by
us and these container services you can
launch containers
using aws management console and also
you can launch containers
using sdk kits available from
amazon you can launch through a java
program you can launch container using
and.net program you can launch container
using an node.js program as in
when the situation demands so there are
multiple ways you can
launch containers through management
console and also
programmatically and ecs also helps to
migrate
application to the cloud without
changing the code
so anytime you think of migration the
first thing that comes to your mind is
that how will that environment be based
on that i'll have to alter my code
what's what's the ip what is the storage
that's being used
what what are the different parameters
i'll have to include the environment
parameters of
the new environment with containers
now that worry is already taken away
because we can create and
pretty exact environment that the one
that you had an on-premises the same
environment gets created in the cloud so
no worries about changing the
application parameter
no worries about changing the code in
the application right you can be like if
it ran
in my laptop a container that i was
running in my laptop
it's definitely going to run in the
cloud as well because i'm going to use
the same
container in the laptop and also
in the cloud in fact you're going to
ship it you're going to move
the container from your laptop to amazon
ecs and make it
run there so it's like the same the very
same
image the very same container that was
running in your laptop will be running
in the cloud or production
environment so what is docker we know
that it
ecs helps to quickly launch exit and
manage
docker containers what is docker let's
let's answer that question what is
docker
now docker is a tool that helps to
automate
the development of an application as a
lightweight
container so that the application can
work efficiently in
different environments this is pretty
much what we discussed
right before the slide i can build an
application
in my laptop or in on premises in a
container environment
docker container environment and anytime
i want to migrate
right i don't have to kind of rewrite
the code and then rerun the code in that
new environment i can
simply create an image docker image
and move that image to that production
or the new
cloud environment and simply launch it
there
right so no compiling again no
relaunching the application simply pack
all your code
in a docker container image and ship it
to the new environment and launch the
container there that's all
so docker container is a light weight
package
of software that contains all the
dependencies
so because you know when packing you'll
be packing all the dependencies
you'll be packing the code you'll be
packing the framework you'll be packing
the libraries
that are required to run the application
so in the new environment you can be
pretty sure you can be guaranteed that
it's going to run because it's the very
same code
it's the very same framework it's the
very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing
that's going to run in that container so
you can be rest assured that
they are going to run in that new
environment and these docker containers
are highly scalable and
they are very efficient suddenly you
wanted like
20 more docker containers to run the
application
think of adding 20 more hosts 20 more
vms
right how much time would it take and
compared to that time
the amount of time that docker
containers would require to kind of
scale to that amount like
20 more containers it's very less or
it's minimal or negligible so it's an
highly scalable
and it's a very efficient service you
can suddenly scale
number of docker containers to meet any
additional demand
very short boot up time because it takes
a
it's not going to load the whole
operating system
and these docker containers you know
they use
the uh linux kernel and features of the
kernel like c groups and
name spaces to kind of segregate the
processors so they can
run independently any environment and it
takes very less time
to boot up and the datas that are stored
in the containers are kind of reusable
so you can have an external data volume
and i can
map it to the container and whatever the
space that's occupied by the container
and the data that
the container puts in that volume they
are kind of reusable you can simply
remap
it to another application you can kind
of remap it to the next
successive container you can kind of
remap it to the next version of the
container
next version of the application you'll
be launching and you don't have to go
through building the data again from the
scratch whatever data the container was
using previously
or the previous container was using that
data is available for the next container
as well so
the volumes that the containers users
are very reusable
volumes and like i said it's isolated
application so it kind of isolates by
its nature
it kind of by the way it's designed by
the way it is created
it isolates one container from another
container meaning
anytime you run applications on
different containers
you can be rest assured that they are
very much isolated
though they are running on the same host
though they are running on the same
laptop let's say
physical machine let's say running
10 containers 10 different applications
you can be sure that they are
well disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of
ecs the advantage of ecs is improved
security its security is inbuilt
in ecs with ecs we have something called
as
a container registry you know that's
where
all your images are stored and those
images
are accessed only through https
not only that those images are actually
encrypted
and access to those images are allowed
and denied
through identity and access management
policies iam
and in other words let's say two
container running on the same instance
now one container can have access to s3
and the others
or the rest of the others are denied
access to s3 so that kind of granular
security can be achieved through
containers
when we mix and match the other security
products available
in amazon like iam encryption accessing
it
using https these containers are very
cost efficient like i've already said
these are lightweight processes right we
can schedule multiple containers on the
same
node and this actually allows us to
achieve high density
on an ec2 instance imagine an ec2
instance that that's very less utilized
that's not possible with a container
because you can actually
dense or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container
in it so to best use those resources in
ec2
straightforward you can just launch one
application but with when we use
containers you can launch like 10
different applications on the same ec2
server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available
and can benefit the application and ecs
not only deploys the container it also
maintains the state of the containers
and it makes sure that the minimum a set
of containers are always running
based on the requirement that's another
cost
efficient way of using it right and
anytime an application fails and
that has a direct impact on the revenue
of the company and is just make sure
that
you're not losing any revenue because
your application has failed
and easies and pretty extensible
services
it's like this in many organization
there are majority of
unplanned work because of environment
variation a lot of firefighting happens
when we
kind of deploy the code from one or kind
of move the core or
redeploy the code in a new environment a
lot of firefighting happens there
right this docker containers are pretty
extensible like we discussed already
environment is not a concern for
containers because
it's going to kind of shut itself inside
a docker container and anywhere the
docker container can run
the application will run exactly the way
it performed
in the past so environment is not a
concern
for the docker containers in addition to
that
ecs is easily scalable we have discussed
this already
and it improves it has improved
compatibility
we have discussed this already let's
talk about the architecture of ecs
like you know now the architecture of
ecs is the ecs
cluster itself that's group of servers
running the ecs service and it
integrates with docker right so we have
a docker registry docker registry is a
repository where
we store all the docker images or
the container images so it's like three
components ecs is of three components
one is the ecs cluster itself
right when i say easy as itself i'm
referring to easiest cluster
cluster of servers that will run the
containers and then
the repository where the images will be
stored
right the repository where the images
will be stored and
the image itself so container image is
the template of instructions which is
used
to create a container right so it's like
what's the os
what is the version of node that should
be running
and any additional software do we need
so those question
gets answered here so it's the template
template of instructions
which is used to create the containers
and then the registry is the service
where the docker images are stored
and shared so many people can store
there and
many people can access or if there's
another group that wants to access
they can access the image from there or
one person can store the image and rest
of the team can access and
the rest of the team can store image and
this one person can pick the image from
there and
kind of ship it to the customer or ship
it to the
production environment all that's
possible in this container registry
and amazon's version of the container
registry is ecr
and there's a third party docker itself
has a container registry that's
docker hub ecs itself which is the the
group of servers that runs those
containers
so these two the container image and the
container registry they kind of handle
docker in an image format just an image
format and in ecs is where the container
gets
live and then it becomes and compute
resource and
starts to handle requests and starts to
serve the page and
starts to do the batch job you know
whatever your plan is with that
container
so the cluster of servers ecs integrates
well with the familiar services like vpc
vpc is known for securing vpc is known
for
isolating the whole environment from
rest of the customers or isolating the
whole
environment or the whole infrastructure
from the rest of the clients
in your account or from the rest of the
applications
in your account on and on so vpc is a
service that
provides or gives you the network
isolation ecs
integrates well with vpc and this vpc
enables us to launch aws resources such
as amazon ec2 instance
in a virtual private network that we
specify this is basically what
we just discussed now let's take a
closer look at
the ecs how does ecs work
let's find answer for this question how
does ecs work
ecs has got a couple of components
within
itself so these ecs servers can run
across availability zone as you can see
there are two availability zones here
they can actually run across
availability zones
and ecs has got two modes far gate mode
and the ec2
mode right here we're seeing forget mode
and then here we see
nothing that means it's an ec2 mode and
then it has got
different network interfaces attached
to it because they need to be running in
an isolated fashion
right so anytime you want network
isolation you need separate ip
and if you want separate ip you need
separate network interface card
and that's what you have elastic network
interface card
separate elastic network interface card
for all those
tasks and services and this runs within
an
vpc let's talk about the far gate
service tasks are launched
using the far gate service so
we will discuss about uh task what is
forget
now fargate is a compute engine in ecs
that allows
users to launch containers without
having to monitor the cluster
ecs is a service that manages
the containers for you right otherwise
managing containers will be and
full-time job so easy is manages it for
you and if you
and you get to manage ecs that's the
basic service but
if you want amazon to manage ecs and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so farget is a compute engine
in ecs that allows users to launch
containers without having to monitor
the ecs cluster and the tasks
the tasks that we discussed the tasks
has
two components you see task right here
so they have two components
we have ecs container instance
and then the container agent so
like you might have guessed right now
ecs container instance is actually an
ec2 instance right capable of running
containers not all
ec2 instances can run containers so
these are like
specific ec2 instances that can run
containers
they are ecs container instances and
then we have container
agent which is the agent that actually
binds those clusters together and it
does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters
makes sure that the version
needed is present so it's all part of
that
agent or it's all job of that agent
container instances
container instances is part of amazon
ec2
instance which run amazon ecs container
agent
pretty straightforward definition and
then a container agent
is responsible for communication between
ecs
and the instance and it also provides
the status of
the running containers kind of monitors
the container
monitors the state of the container make
sure that the content is up and running
and if there's
anything wrong it kind of reports it to
the appropriate service
to fix the container on and on it's a
container agent
when we don't manage container agent it
runs by itself
and you really don't have to do anything
to make the container agent better
it's already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent
and then elastic network interface card
is a virtual
interface network that can be connected
uh to an instance in
vpc so in other words elastic network
interface is
how the container interacts with another
container
and that's how the container interacts
with the ec2
host and that's how the container
interacts with
the internet external world and a
cluster
a cluster is a set of ecs container
instances it's not something that's very
difficult to understand
it's simply a group of ec2 instances
that runs that ecs agent
and this cluster in cluster handles the
process of
scheduling monitoring and scaling the
request we know that ecs
can scale the containers can scale how
does it scale
that's all monitored and managed by this
ecs cluster
let's talk about the companies that are
using amazon
ecs there are variety of companies that
use
ecs clusters to name a few octa
users easiest cluster and octa
is a product that use identity
information to grant
people access to applications on
multiple devices
at any given point of time they make
sure that they have
a very strong security protection
so octa uses amazon ecs
to run their octa application and serve
their customers
and abima abhima is an uh tv channel
and they chose to use microservices and
docker containers they already had
microservices and
docker containers and when they thought
about a service that they can use
in aws ecs was the only service that
they can
immediately adapt to and because
in abima tv the engineers have already
been using docker and
docker containers it was kind of easy
for them to adapt themselves to ecs
and start using it along with the
benefits that
ecs provides previously they had to do a
lot of work
but now ecs does it for them all right
similarly
remind and ubisoft gopro
are some of the famous companies that
use amazon ecs
and get benefited from its scalability
get benefited from its cost
gets benefited from its amazon managed
services get benefited from the
portability that
ecs and the migration option that ecs
provides
let's talk about how to deploy a docker
container on amazon acs
the way to deploy docker container on
ecs is first we need to have an
aws account and then set up and run our
first
ecs cluster so in our lab we're going to
use
the launch wizard to run an ecs
cluster and run containers in them and
then
task definition task definition tells
the size of the container
the number of the container and when we
talk about size
it tells how much your cpu do you need
how much of memory do you need
and talking about numbers
you know it requires how many numbers of
container you're going to launch
you know is it 5 is it 10 or is it just
one
running all the time now those kind of
information goes in the task
definition file and then we can do some
advanced configuration on ecs
like load balancers and you know what
port number you want to allow
and you don't want to allow you know who
gets access who shouldn't get access
and what's the ip that you want to allow
and deny requests from
on and on and this is where we would
also mention the name of the container
so to differentiate one container from
the other
and the name of the servers you know is
it an a backup
job is it a web application is it an uh
data container
is it going to take care of your data
data backend
and the desired number of tasks that you
want to be running
all the time those details go in when we
try to configure
the ecs service right and then you
configure cluster
you put in all the security in the
configure your cluster
step or configure cluster stage and
finally we will have an instance
and bunch of containers running in that
instance
all right let's do a demo so here i have
logged in to my
amazon portal and let me switch to the
appropriate region
i'm going to pick not virginia north
virginia look for ecs
and it tells ecs as a service that helps
to run and manage
docker containers well and good click on
it i'm in north virginia
just want to make sure that i'm in the
right region and go to clusters
and here we can create cluster this is
our
far gate and this is our ec2 type
launching for linux and windows
environment but i'm going to launch
through this
walkthrough portal right this gives a
lot of information here
so the different steps involved here is
creating
a container definition which is what
we're going to do right now
and then a task definition and then
service and finally
the cluster it's a four step process so
in container definition
we define the image the base
image we are going to use now here i'm
going to launch
an uh httpd or a simple http webpage
right so a simple httpd 2.4 image is
fair enough for me and it's not a heavy
application so
0.5 gigabit of memory is
enough and again it's not a heavy
application so 0.25
virtual cpu is enough in our case
right you can edit it based on the
requirement you can always
edit it and because i'm using hdpd the
port mapping is already
port 80 that's how the container is
going to receive
the request and there's no health check
as if now
when we want to design critical and
complicated environments
we can include health check right and
this is the cpu
that we have chose we can edit it and
i'm going to use some
bash commands to create an html page
right this page says that you know
amazon ecs
sample app right and then it says amazon
ecs sample app
your application is running on a
container in amazon ecs so that's
the page the html page that i'm going to
create
or index.html so i'm going to create and
put it in an appropriate location so
those pages can be served from the
container
right if you replace this with any of
your own content then it's going to be
your own content
ecs comes with some basic logs and
these are the places where they get
stored that's not the focus
as of now all right so i was just saying
that you can edit it
and customize it to your needs we're not
gonna do any customization
now we're just getting familiar with ecs
now
and the task definition name of the task
definition
is first one task definition and then
we are running it in a vpc and then this
is
and for gate mode meaning the servers
are completely handled by
amazon and the task memory is 0.5
gigabit
and the tar cpu is 0.25 virtual cpu
name of the service is it a batch job is
it an
you know front end is it a back end or
is it a simple copy job
what's the service name of the service
goes here again this you can
edit it and here's a security group as
of now i'm allowing 480
to the whole world if i want to restrict
to a certain ip i can
do that the default option for load
balancing is
a no load balancer but i can also choose
to have a load balancer and use port 80
to map that 480 to the container
put 80 right i can do that the default
is
no load balancer all right let's do one
thing let's use load balancer let's use
load balancer and port 80
as it receives information on port 80
http
uh what's going to be the cluster name
we're in the last step what is the
cluster name
cluster name can be simply learn
ecs demo next we're done and we can
create
so it's launching a cluster as you can
see and it's
picking the task definition file that
we've created and it's
using that to launch and service and
then these are the log groups
that we discussed and it's creating your
vpc
remember ecs clubs well with the vpc
it's creating a vpc and it's creating
two subnets here
for high availability it's creating that
security group port 80
allowed to the whole world and then it's
putting it behind
and load balancer it generally would
take like five
to 10 minutes so we just need to be
patient
and let it complete its creation and
once this is complete we can simply
access
these servers using the load balancer
url and when this is running
let me actually take you to the other
products
or the other services that are
integrated with the ecs
it's getting created our service is
getting created as of now
ecr repository this is where all our
images are stored now as of now i'm not
pulling my image from ecr i'm pulling it
directly
from the internet docker docker hub
but all custom images all custom images
they are stored in this repository so
you can
create a repository call it app one
create a repository so here's my
repository so any image that i create
locally or any docker image that i
create locally i can actually
push them push those images using these
commands right here
and they get stored here and i can make
my ecs
connect with ecr and pull images
from here so they would be my custom
images
and as of now because i'm using a
default image it's
directly pulling it from the internet
let's go to
ec2 and look for a load balancer because
we wanted to access the application
from behind a load balancer right so
here is a load balancer created for us
and anytime i put the url
so cluster is now created you see
there's one service running
all right let's click on that cluster
here is the
name of our application and here is the
tasks the different containers that
we are running and if you click on it we
have an
ip right ip of that container and it
says
it's running it was created at such and
such time and
started at such and such time and this
is the task definition file
that it this container uses meaning the
template the details to all the version
details
they all come from here and it belongs
to the cluster
called simply learn ecs demo
right and you can also get some logs
container logs from here
so let's go back and there are no ecs
instances here because remember this is
forget you're not managing any ecs
instance all right so that's why you're
not seeing any ecs instance here
so let's go back to tasks and go back to
the same page where we found the ip pick
that ip
put it in the browser and you have this
sample
html page running from an container so
let me go back to
load balancer ec2 and then under ec2
i'll be able to find a load balancer
find that load balancer pick that dns
name put it in the browser
and now it's accessible to the load
balancer url
right now this url can be mapped to
other services like
dns this url can be embedded
in any of your application if you want
to make that application connect with
this container
now using ip is not all that advisable
because
these containers can die and then a new
container gets created and when a new
container gets created it gets a new ip
right so a hard coding ip is not
hardcoding dynamic ips are not advisable
so you would be using load balancer and
putting that url
in that application that you want to
make it interact with
this container instance it was a
wonderful experience in walking you
through
this ecs topic and in here we learned
about what aws
is and why we're using ecs and
what is easiest in general what is
docker
in specific and we also learn about the
advantages of
ecs the architecture the different
components of ecs
and how ecs works when they're all
connected together
and we also looked at the companies that
use ecs and their use cases and finally
a
lab how we can launch ecs fargate
through the portal i'm very glad to walk
you through this lesson about
route 53. so in this section we are
going to talk about
basics of aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into
why why we need amazon route 53
and then we're going to expand and talk
about the details of
amazon route 53 the benefits it
provides over its competitors and the
different types of routing policy
it has and some of amazon ralph 53's
key features and we're going to talk
about how to access
route 53 i mean the different ways the
different methods you can
access route 53 and finally we're going
to end with an
a wonderful demo in drought 53. so let's
talk about
what is aws amazon web services or aws
in short is a cloud provider
that offers a variety of services such
as a
variety of id services or infrastructure
services
such as a compute power database
content delivery and other resources
that
helps us to scale and grow our business
and aws is hot aws is picking up
aws is being adapted by a lot of
customers
that's because aws is easy to use
even for a beginner and talking about
safety
the the aws infrastructure is designed
to keep the data safe irrespective of
the size of the data with small data
be it very minimal data be it all the
data that you have
in terabytes and in petabytes amazon
can keep it safe in their environment
and the wonderful thing and the most
important reason why
a lot of customers move into the cloud
is that
the pay as you go pricing there is no
long term commitment
and it's very cost effective what this
means is that you're not paying for
resource that you're not using in
on-premises you do
pay for resources you're not using a lot
meaning
you go and buy a server you do the
estimate for the next five years
and only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the
peak capacity but still you would be
buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be
you know utilizing it from you know 40
days 60
days 70 80 and then 100. so what you
have done is that
even though you're not using the full
capacity you still have bought it and
are and are paying for it from day one
but in the cloud it's not like that you
only pay for
the resources that you use anytime you
want more you scale up the resource and
you you pay for the scaled up resource
and anytime you want less you scale down
the resource and you pay less
for that scaled down resource let's talk
about why amazon
route 53 let's take this scenario where
rachel is trying to open
her web browser and the url that she hit
isn't working a lot of reasons behind
why the url isn't working it could be
the server utilization that went high it
could be
it could be the memory usage that went
high a lot of reasons
and she starts to think is there an
efficient way to scale
resources according to the user
requirements
or is there an efficient way to kind of
mask
all those failures and kind of divert
the traffic to the appropriate
active you know active resource or
active
service that's running our application
you always want to hide the failures
right in
it kind of mask the failure and direct
the customer to
another healthy service that's running
right
none of your customers would want to see
a server not available or
you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see
your service not working not impressive
to them and this is
tom tom is an i.t guy and
he comes with an idea and he's answering
rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using amazon
rod53 in a sense he's saying that yes we
can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running
meaning we can provide more high
availability to our customers
with the use of route 53 and then he
goes on and explains
amazon rough 53 is a dns service that
gives developers an efficient way to
connect
users to internet applications without
any downtime now downtime is the key
amazon route 53 helps us to avoid
any downtime that customers will
experience you still
will have downtime in your server and
your application but
your customers will not be made aware of
it
and then rachel is kind of interested
and she's like yeah that sounds
interesting
i want to learn more about it and tom
goes on and explains the important
concepts of amazon
route 53 that's everything that i'm
going to explain it to you as well
all right so what is amazon rat53
amazon drop 53 is a highly scalable
dns or domain name system web
service this service this amazon raw 53
it functions three main things or it has
three main functions
so the first thing is if a website needs
a name
route 53 registers the name for the
website domain let's say
you want to buy google.com you want to
buy the domain name
let's say you want to buy that domain
name you buy that through
rot 53 secondly a route 53 is the
service that actually connects
your server which is running your
application
or which is holding which is serving
your web page
so that's the service that actually
route 53 is the service that connects
the user to your server when they hit
google.com in the browser or whatever
domain name that you have purchased so
you bought a domain name and the user
types in
yourdomainname.com and then roth53 is a
service that helps
the user to connect their browser to the
application that's running in an ec2
instance or
any other server that you are using to
serve that content
and not only that 53 checks health
of the resource by sending automated
requests over the internet to a resource
so that's how
it identifies if there is any resource
that has failed can i say resource
i'm referring to any infrastructure
failure any application
level failure so it kind of keeps
checking so it understands it first
before
the customer notices it and then it does
the magic kind of shifts the connection
from a one server to the other server we
call it routing we will talk about that
as we progress
so the benefits of using route53 it's
highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests
the number of people trying to access
your website through that
domain name that you have bought let's
say it has increased ralph 53 is highly
scalable
right it can handle even millions and
millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by amazon
the same thing it's reliable it's a
highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
without you interacting without the user
who bought it
interact with it you don't have to scale
up you know when you're expecting more
requests it automatically
scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that
it's very consistent it has the ability
to route
the users to the appropriate application
through the logic
that it has it's very easy to use when
we do the lab
you're going to see that it's very easy
easy to use you buy the domain name and
then you simply map it to the
application you simply map it to the
server
by putting in the ip or if you you can
simply map it to another load balancer
by putting in the load balancer url
you can simply map it to another s3
bucket by simply putting
the s3 bucket name or the s3 bucket url
it's
pretty straightforward easy to set up
and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only
pay for the service that we have used so
no wastage of money here
so the billing is set up in such a way
that you are paying only for
the amount of requests that you have
received
right the amount of traffic the amount
of requests that you have received
and couple of other things the the
number of uh
hosted zones that you have created right
and couple of other things
it it's very cost effective in such a
way that you
only pay for the service that you are
using
and it's secure in a way that access to
route 53
is integrated with identity and access
management iam
so you only have authorized users
gain access to route 53 the trainee who
just
joined yesterday won't get access and
the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is
using your environment you can block
access to that
particular person because he's not the
admin or he's not a privileged user in
your account so only privileged users
and admin gain access to
route 53 through iam now let's talk
about the routing policies
so when you create a record in
in route 53 recorder is nothing but an
entry so when you do that
you choose a routing policy right
routing policy is nothing but
it determines how route 53 responds
to your queries how the dns queries are
being responded
right that's that's a record or that's a
routing policy
so the first one is a simple routing
policy
so we use simple routing policy for a
single resource in other words simple
routing allows to configure dns with
no special route 53 routing it's kind of
one to one
you use an single resource that performs
a given
function to your domain for example if
you want to simply map an url to a web
server that's pretty straightforward
simple
routing so it routes traffic to a single
resource
example web server to a website and with
simple routing
multiple records with the same name
cannot
be created but multiple values can be
created
in the same record the second type of
routing policy
is failover routing so we would be using
failover routing when we want to
configure
active passive failover if something
failed
right you want to fail over to the next
resource which was previously the backup
resource now the active resource
or which was previously the backup
server now it's an active server so you
would be failing over
to that particular resource or that
particular ip
if you want to do that we use failover
routing so failover routing routes
traffic to a resource when the resource
is healthy
or to a different resource when the
previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy
i mean it does all that's needed to
shift the traffic from the
primary resource to the secondary
resource in other words
from the unhealthy resource to the
healthy resource
and this records can draw traffic to
anything
from an amazon s3 bucket
or you can also configure a complex tree
of
records now when we configure the
records it will be
more clear to you so as of now just
understand that
route 53 can route or this routing
policy the failover
routing policy can route traffic to
amazon s3 bucket
or to a website that has complex tree of
uh
records geolocation routing policy now
geolocation
routing just like the name says it takes
that routing decision
based on the geographic location of
the user in other words you know when
you want to roll traffic based on the
location of the user
that's your primary criteria for you
know sending that request to the
appropriate server
we will be using geo location
routing so it localizes the content and
presents
a part or the entire website in the
language
of the user for example a user from us
you would want to direct them to an
english website and a user from german
if you want to send them to the
german website and a user from france
you know
you want to send those requests or you
want to show content
specific to a customer who lives in
france a french website
so this is if that's your condition this
is the routing policy
we would be using and the geographic
locations are specified by
either continent or by country or by
state
in the united states so only in the
united states you can actually split it
to
state level and for the rest of the
countries you can do it on a country
level
on a high level you can also do it on a
continent level
the next type of routing policy would be
job proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to route traffic based on the
location
of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location
to resource in another location we would
be using
geoproximity routing so geoproximity
routing routes traffic to the resources
based on the geographic location of the
user
and the resources they want to access
and it also has an option to route more
traffic
or less to a given resource by
specifying a value known as
a bias kind of weight but we also have
weighted routing that's different
so we've chosen different name bias you
can send more traffic to a particular
resource
by having a bias on that
particular routing condition and a bias
expands or shrinks the size of the
geographic
region from which traffic is routed to a
resource
and then we have latency based routing
just like the name says
we use latency based routing if we have
resources in
multiple aws regions and if you want to
route traffic
to the region that provides the best
latency at any given point of time
so let's say if one single website
needs to be installed and hosted on
multiple aws regions
then latency routing policy is what is
being used
it improves the performance of the users
by serving the request
from the aws region that provides the
lowest
latency so at any given point if
performance is your
criteria and at any given point of time
irrespective
of what happens in amazon infrastructure
irrespective of what happens in the
internet
if you want to route your users to the
best performing
website best performing region then we
would be using
latency based routing and for using
latency-based routing we should create
latency records for the resources in
multiple
aws regions and then the other type of
a routing policy is a multi-value
routing policy where we can make route
53 to respond to dns queries with up to
eight healthy records selected at
random so you're not kind of loading
one particular server we can define
eight records and on a
random basis route 53 will respond to
queries from
these eight records so it's not one
server
that gets all the requests but eight
servers
gets the request in a random fashion so
it's multi-value routing policy and what
we get
by this is that we are distributing the
traffic to many servers instead of just
one server so multi-value routing
configures
route 53 to return multiple values in
response to a single
or multiple dns queries it also checks
the health
of order sources and returns the
multiple values only for the healthy
resources let's say out of the eight
servers we have
define one server is not doing healthy
it will not respond to the query with
the details
of the unhealthy server right so now
it's gonna treat it as only seven
servers in the list
because one server is unhealthy and it
has the ability to return
multiple health checkable ip addresses
to improve
availability and load balancing the
other type of
routing policy is weighted routing
policy
and in here we use to route traffic or
this is used to route traffic to
multiple resources in a proportion that
we
specify so this is an weighted routing
and weighted routing routes multiple
resources
to a single domain name or a sub domain
and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources
so this is very useful when you're doing
load balancing and testing new versions
of the
software so when you have a new version
of the software you really don't want to
send 100 of the traffic to it
so you want to get customers feedback
about the new software that you've
launched
new version or new application that
you've launched so you would kind of
send only 20 of the traffic to that
application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that
new application so any software launches
application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the
key benefits or key features of route 53
some of the key features of route 53 are
traffic flow
it routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide
the best user experience that's what we
discussed
in the routing policies right it uses a
routing policy
a latency based routing policy and jio
based routing policy and then failover
routing policy so
it kind of improves the user experience
and the key feature the other key
feature of route 53 is
we can buy domain names using
roth 53 using route 53 console we can
buy it from here
and use it in a rough 53. previously it
was not the case
but now we can buy it directly from
amazon through route 53 and we can
assign it to any resources that we want
so anybody
browsing that url the connection will be
directed
to the server in aws that runs our
website a health checks
it monitors health and performance of
the application so it comes with an
health check attached to it health check
are useful to make sure that the
unhealthy resources are
retired right the unhealthy resources
are taken away
or your customers are not kind of
hitting the unhealthy resources and
they see an service down page or
something like that uh we can have
weighted round robin load balancing
that's helpful in spreading traffic
between
several services or servers we are round
robin
algorithm so no one server is fully
hit or no one server kind of fully
absorbs all the traffic
you know you can shift you can split and
shift
the traffic to different servers based
on the weight
that you would be configuring and also
weighted routing also helps with
a soft launch soft launch of your
new application or the new version of
your website there are different ways we
can
access amazon route 53 so you can access
amazon rot 53
through aws console you can also access
amazon route 53 using aws sdks
and we can access it using we can
configure it
using the apis and we can also do it
through the command
line interface that's linux type linux
flavor
aws command line interface we can also
do that using windows command line
windows powershell
flavored command line interface as well
now let's look at some of the companies
that are using ros 53
so some of the famous companies that use
ralph 53 are
medium medium is an online publishing
platform and it's more like a social
journalism it's kind of having hybrid
collection of
professionals people and publications or
exclusive
blogs or publishers on medium it's kind
of
an blog website and that uses
roth53 for the dns service reddit is an
uh social news aggregation or web
content rating and discussion website
that uses route 53 so these are some
websites that
that are accessed throughout the world
and they are using
roth 53 and it's highly scalable
suddenly there is a
new news right their website will be
accessed a lot
and they need to keep their service up
and running
all the time more availability otherwise
customers will end up in a broken page
and
the number of customers who will be
using the website will come down
so it's very critical these sites these
companies are very critical
you know they're being highly available
their page their site being highly
available and the internet is very
critical and crucial for them
and they rely and use route 53 to meet
that particular
demand and airbnb is another company
uh instacart cozara is another company
stripe is another company
that uses route53 to as their dns
uh provider for their dns service they
use
route 53 so their customers get best
performance they use raw 53 so their
website is highly available they use rot
53 to kind of shift to the traffic
between the resources so their resources
are properly
used with all the weighted routing the
resources are properly
used now let's quickly look at a demo
i'm in my aws console
and i'm in route 53 so let me click on
rot53
so in this lab we're actually going to
simulate
buying a domain name and then we're
going to create an
s3 static website and we're going to map
that website
to this dns name right so the procedure
is the same for mapping load balancer
the procedure is the same for mapping
cloudfront the procedure is the same for
mapping ec2 instances as well
we're picking s3 for simplicity right
but our focus is actually on
route53 so let's go in here and we'll
see if we can
we'll buy a domain name here so let's
first check
the availability of a domain name called
simply learn hyphen demo hyphen route 53
let's check its availability
it is available for 12 dollars so let me
add it to cart
and then come back here and then once
you continue to ask for personal
information once you give the personal
information
you finally check out and then it gets
added to your shopping list
once you pay for it amazon takes like 24
to 40 hours
to make that a dns name available so the
next stage would be contact details and
then the third stage would be
verify and purchase so once
we have bought the domain name it will
become available
in our dns portal and i do have a domain
name which i bought
some time back and it's now available
for me to use
so i can go to hosted zone and simply
start
creating i can go to hosted zone and
then here it's going to list all the
domain names
for me right click on the domain name
and then click on
the record set and here i can actually
map
elastic load balancer s3 website vpc
endpoint
api gateway and cloudfront elastic bean
stock
domain names right all that gets mapped
through this portal
quite simple like four or five step
button clicks and then it'll be done so
i have an
domain name bot and then i'm gonna go to
s3
and i'll show you what i've done in s3
so i've created a bucket
name called as a dns name let me clear
the content in them so i've created a
bucket and then
permissions i've turned off public
access blocking and then i've created
and a bucket policy
so this bucket is now publicly
accessible and then i went on
to properties and created the static
website hosting
right and i've pointed that this is the
file that's my index file
that i'm going to put or name of the
file that's going to be my index file
that i'm going to put in this s3 bucket
so put the index file.html
saved it and we're going to create a
file now we're going to create an index
file
so this is a sample code it says
amazon.53 getting started
routing internet traffic to s3 bucket
for your website and then a couple of
other information
so save it as an index.html file
in my desktop so let me upload that from
my desktop
into this bucket so that's index.html
and it's in capital i
so let me go to properties and go to
static website hosting and
make sure that i spell it properly right
it's case sensitive
and then save it so now this means that
my website
should be running through this url and
it does
it's running to the static website url
we're halfway through so now let me go
back to
route53 go back to route53 go back to
hosted zones
go into the domain name and then create
a record set
and it's going to be an alias record and
i i see my
s3 static website endpoint there right
so click on it
and create it has now created an
record that's pointing my domain name to
the s3 endpoint
that i have created and my static
website is running from it
so let me test it right so let me go to
the browser put the domain name in there
and sure enough
the domain name when my browser queried
for the domain name
a route53 returned a response saying
this domain name is actually mapped to
the s3 bucket
static website hosting enable s3 bucket
and this is the url for that static
website hosting and then
my browser was able to connect to that
s3 bucket and
download the details and show it in my
browser
right so it's that simple and pretty
straight forward today's session is on
aws elastic beanstalk
so what's in it for you today we'll be
discussing about what is aws
why we require aws elastic bean stock
what is aws elastic bean stock the
advantages
disadvantages the components of mean
stock along with that
the architecture and the companies that
are primarily using the aws be installed
so let's get started
and first understand what is aws aws
stands for amazon web services it's a
cloud provider and that offers a variety
of services such as compute power
database storage content delivery and
many other resources
so we know that aws is the largest cloud
provider in the market
and so many services are available in
the aws where you can apply the business
logics
and create the solutions using the cloud
platforms
now why aws elastic means stock now what
happened earlier
and that whenever the developer used to
create
the software or the modules related to
the softwares
has to be joined together to create a
big application now one developer
creates a module
that has to be shared with another
developer and if the developers are
geographically separated then it has to
be shared over
a medium probably an internet so that is
going to take some time
uh it would be a difficult process and
in return
it uh makes the application or a
software development
a lender process the building of the
software development lender process
so there were challenges which the
developers were facing earlier
and to overcome that uh we have the bean
stock as a service
available in the aws so why aws elastic
bean stock is
required uh aws elastic being stock has
made the life of
the developers quite easy in terms of
that they can share the applications
across different devices
at a shorter time duration now let's
understand
what is aws elastic bean stock aws
elastic bean stock is a service
which is used to deploy and scale web
applications by developers not only web
application any application that is
being developed by the developers
this is a simple representation of the
aws elastic bean stock
now along with that the aws elastic bean
supports the programming language the
runtime environments
that are java.net php node.js
python rubygo and docker and in case if
you're looking for
any other programming language or a
runtime environment then you can make a
request with aws
to arrange that for you now what are the
advantages associated with the elastic
bean stock
first advantage is that it's a highly
scalable service
now when we talk about the scalability
it means that
whenever we require the resources in
demand we can scale up the resources
or we can scale down the resources so
that is kind of a flexibility we get
in terms of changing the type of
resources whenever we need it
and in that case the elastic bean stock
is a highly scalable
service now that is something which is
very difficult to achieve
in case of an on-prem environments
because you have to plan
for the infrastructure and in case if
you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second advantage
associated with the bean stock is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple
that means that you just have to focus
on the development of an application
building an application and then you can
just deploy the application directly
using the bean stock but the bean stock
is going to do that every networking
aspect
is being taken care by the bean stock it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the url
or through the ip address the third
advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we
discussed in the fast and simple to
begin as well so why it offers a quick
deployment you don't have to bother
about the networking concepts you just
have to focus
on the application development and then
you can just upload your application
deploy that
and then you're good to go the other
advantage is that it supports
multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenants that means
we can have a virtual environments for
separate organizations or
the divisions within the organizations
that will be virtually isolated
so likewise you can have a virtually
isolated environments created on the
bean stock
and they can be separated used as a
separate entities
or a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then it is a flexible also
now coming to the simplifies operations
as an advantage now once the application
is deployed
using the bean stock then it becomes
very easy to maintain
and support that application using the
bean stock services itself
and the last advantage that we can have
from the bean stock is that it's a cost
efficient service the cost efficient as
we know that many of the aws services
are cost effective
the cost optimization can be better
managed using the aws main stock as
compared to if you are developing or if
you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution
on the on-prem servers now there are
some components that are
associated with the aws bean stock and
it has to be created in the form of a
sequence manner
so aws elastic bean stock consists of
few important components
which are required while developing an
application now what are these
components
these are four components one is
application the second is application
version
the third is environment and the fourth
one is the environment tier and we have
to
progress while deploying our
applications or the
softwares using the same sequence now
let's understand
what are the different components of the
beanstalk r the application
it refers to a unique label which is
used as a deployable code for a web
application
so generally you deploy your web
application or you create your
application
and that is something which is basically
uh used as a unique label
then the second component is application
versions
so it resembles a folder which stores a
collection of components
such as environments versions and
environment configurations so all these
components are being stored using the
application
version the third most important
component is the environment
in the environment only the current
versions of the applications runs
now remember that elastic means stock
supports multiple versions as well
and using the environment you can only
run the current version of the
application for
if you wanted to have another version of
an application to be
running then you have to create another
environment for that then comes the
environment here
and in the environment here it is
basically it designates the type of
application
that the environment runs on now
generally there are two types of
environment here one is the web
and the other one is the worker node and
that's something which we'll be
discussing later as well
now let's understand how does elastic
beam stock in aws works
so first we have to create an
application and this is a task that
would be done by the developers
and for that you can actually select any
runtime environment or a programming
language like
java docker ruby gopal or python as well
and once you select that environment you
can
develop your application using that
runtime environments
now after that once the application is
created
then you have to upload the version of
an application on the aws
and after that once the version is
uploaded
and then you have to launch your
environment so just have to click
on the buttons that's it nothing more
you have to do once the environment is
launched then you can actually view that
environment
using a web url or using the ip address
now what happens in that case is when
you launch an environment
in the back end the elastic bean stock
runs automatically runs an ec2 instance
and using a metadata the mean stock
deploys your application within that ec2
instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well
so you don't have to take care of the
security groups you don't have to take
care
of the ip addressing and even you don't
have to login into the instance
and deploy your application it would be
done automatically by the bean stock
it's just that you just have to monitor
the environment
and the statistics will be available
there itself in the bin stock dashboard
otherwise
you can view those statistics in the
cloudwatch logs as well now in case
if you wanted to update any kind of a
version then you just upload
a new version and then just deploy that
and then monitor your environment
so these are the essentials to create a
local applications for
any platform whether it's a node.js
python etc
these are the things that you have to
actually take care and this is the
sequence you have to
follow while creating an environment so
you can say that it's a four steps
creation offer or deployment of your
application that's it now
after users upload their versions the
configuration is automatically deployed
with a load balancer yes
and with the load balancer that means
you can
access the applications using the load
balancer dns also
and apart from load balancer if you
wanted to put any other
feature that includes the auto scaling
for example if you wanted to create
your ec2 instances where the application
will be deployed
within the virtual private cloud or in a
particular subnet within the vpc
all those features that are available
and you can select them
using the mean stock itself you don't
have to move out to the vpc
you don't have to actually go to the ec2
dashboard and select all those
separately
everything would be available within the
beanstalk dashboard so that's what it
says in the presentation that after
creating an application the deploy
service can be
specifically accessed using the url so
once the
environment is created there will be a
url defined now you can
put a url name also that is something
which
you wanted to put for your application
you can define that you can check for
the availability of that url and then
you have to use that url to access your
application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and multi
features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
aws elastic bean stock
now there are two types of environments
that you have to select you can select
one is the web server environment and
the other one is the worker environment
so based on the client requirement bean
stock gives you two different types of
environment that you have to select
generally the web server environment is
the front end facing
that means the client should be
accessing this environment directly
using a url so mostly web applications
are
deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the back end
applications
or on the micro apps which are basically
required to support
the running of the web applications now
it depends on the client requirement
what kind of an environment you wanted
to select
now in the web server environment it
only handles the http request from the
client so that's why we use
the web server environment mostly for
the web applications or any application
which works on the http https requests
so it's not only the http you can use
the https as well
the worker environment it process
background task and minimizes the
consumption of
resources so again it is just like a
kind of a micro service or an
application services that are running
in the back end to support the web
server environment now
coming to the understanding of the aws
main stock
so this is how the architecture of the
aws bean stock is designed
and you can refer to that image also now
in the web server environment let's say
if we
select a web server environment and it
says that if the application receives
client request the amazon route 53
sends this request to the elastic load
balancer now obviously we discussed here
that the web server environment
is primarily an environment which
receives the http request
it's a kind of a client-facing
environment now
if the application receives a client
request amazon from the amazon route 53
this route 53 is a service which is
primarily used for
dns mapping it's a global service and it
may route you can
route the traffic from the route 53
matching your domains towards the load
balancer and from the load balancer you
can point that traffic to the web server
environment
obviously the web server environment is
nothing it's just the ec2 instances that
would be running in the back end
now here in the diagram you can see that
there are two web server environments
and they are created in the auto scaling
group that means
there is some kind of scaling options
that are defined as well
and these instances are created in an
availability zone or they can be created
in a different availability zone also
for the redundancy as well
and these web application servers are
further connected to your databases
which primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
rds database also
so all these functionalities all these
features
are basically available on the elastic
mean stock dashboard itself now what
happens in that case is if the
application receives client requests
amazon
route 53 send these requests to the load
balancer later the load balancer shares
those requests among the ec2 instances
how does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances
or n number of ac2 instances running in
the
availability zone now in the
availability zones
every ec2 instance would have its own
security group
they can have a common security group
also they can have their own security
group as well
now after the security group the load
balancer is then connected to the amazon
ec2 instance which are part of the auto
scaling group so that's something which
we have discussed already now this auto
scaling group
is would be defined from the beanstalk
itself and
there will be some scaling options that
will be created it could be a
possibility that
it might be the minimum number of
instances
that would be running as of now and
based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on distributing the
load
to as many instances that will be
created inside
the availability resource obviously
there will be an internal health check
that the load balancer will be first
doing
before distributing the real time
traffic to this instances
created by the mean stock now what does
auto scaling group
does it automatically starts the
additional ec2 instance to accommodate
increasing load on your application
that's something which we know that
and also it monitors and scales
instances based on the
workload as well so depends on what kind
of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups
and when the load of an application
decreases the ec2 instance will also be
decreased so whenever we talk about the
auto scaling generally it comes in our
mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances
in the auto scaling you might have the
scale down option also scaled down
policy also created in which if the load
minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well
so that is something which will be
automatically managed all these features
can be achievable using the elastic bean
stock and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization
in terms of managing your resources now
it says that elastic bean stock has a
default security group and the security
group acts as a
firefall for the instances now here in
this diagram it says about the security
group auto scaling also you might
create it in a default vpc also you
might create it in your custom vpc also
where you can have
the additional level of security is also
created you can have the nacl's knuckles
also
defined here before the security groups
so that would give you the additional
filtering option
or the firewall option now it says that
with these groups with these security
groups
it allows establishing security groups
to the database server as well so every
database
would also have its own security group
and the connection can be
created between the web servers
environment that is created by the
beanstalk to the database security
groups as well
now let's discuss about the worker
environment now
understanding the worker environment
what happens is that
the client the web server environment is
the client facing the client sends a
request
for an access to the web server and in
this diagram the web server further
sends it to
the sqs which is a simple queue service
and the queue service
sends it to the worker environment and
then whatever the worker environment is
created for
doing some kind of a processing or some
kind of an application that is running
in the back end
that environment initiates and then send
back uh
the results to this sqs and vice versa
so let's understand the architecture of
a
aws elastic bean stock with the worker
environment so when a worker environment
here is launched aws elastic main stock
installed the server on every ec2
instance
so that is in the case of a web server
environment also and later
the server passes the request to the
simple queue service
now this service is an asynchronous
service instead of a simple queue
service you can have
other services also it is not necessary
that you need to have the sqs also this
is an example that we are
discussing about and the sqs shares
those message
via a post request to the http path over
the
broker environment and there are many
case studies also with respect to this
kind of an environment that is being
created that has been done on many
customers
and you can search for these kind of a
case studies
available on the internet now the worker
environment
executes the task given by the sqs with
the http response
after the operation is completed now
here what happens is
a quick recap the client request for an
access of
an application to a web server using an
http request
the web server passes that request to
the queue service
the q service shares the message with
the worker probably a worker
might be the manual worker and generally
it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
by the worker environment only
and the worker sends back the response
with the http response back to the
queue that response can be viewed
directly from the queue service
by the client using the web server so
this is one of the example likewise
as i said that there can be many other
examples also where you can have the
worker environments
defined now what are the companies that
are using the elastic bean stock
these are few of the companies that are
primarily using on a zillow
jelly button games then you have league
of women waters
ebery these are some of the few listed
companies
and obviously you search on the aws site
and you will find many
more organizations that are using the
elastic bean stock
primarily for deploying their
applications
now the next thing is to go with the
practicals that how actually we use the
elastic bean stock so let's look into
the demo
using the aws elastic bean stock now
first you have to
login into the aws console and i'm sure
that you might be having
the accounts created or you can use the
im credentials as well and then you have
to
select the region also now i am in the
north virginia region likewise you can
select any of the regions that are
listed here now click on the services
and you have to search for the elastic
bean stock you can find the elastic bean
stock under the compute section
so here itself you'll find the elastic
bean stock as a service
now open this service and there it will
give you an option
to create an environment you have to
specifically
select an environment probably a worker
environment
or a web service environment so let's
wait for
the service to open so we have the
dashboard now available with us this is
how the elastic bean stock looks and
this is the symbol representation
of a bean stock now what you have to do
is we have to click on get
started and that will load and you have
to create a
web app so instead of creating a web app
what we'll do we'll create a new
application so just click on create a
new application put an application name
let's say we put something like
x y z you can put any description to
your
application let's say it's a demo app
and click on
create now it says you have to select an
environment
now the environment the application name
xyz is created you just have to
select the nav environment so click on
create one now and it is going to ask
you
that what kind of an environment here
you wanted to select
so as we discussed that there are two
types of environments one is the web
server and the other one is the
current one let's look into it what is
defined by the aws
aw says that it has two types of
environment
tiers to support different types of web
applications web servers are standard
applications
that listen for and then process http
request
typically over port number 80. workers
are specialized application that have a
background
processing task that listens for message
on an amazon sqs
queue workers application post those
messages to your application
by using the http response so that's
what we
saw in the case of the beanstalk slides
also now
the usability of a worker environment
can be anything
now we'll do a demo for creating a web
server environment
so just click on select and you we have
the environment name created
now we can define our own domain it ends
with
the region dot elastic beanstalk.com
let's say
i look for a domain which is xyz only
that's the environment name
now i'll check for the availability
whether that domain name is
available with us or not and it says we
don't have that
domain name so probably i'll try to make
it with some other name and let's look
for
the availability xyz abc and it says yes
it is available now once i deploy my
application
i would be able to access the
application using this complete
dns so you can put a description it's a
demo
app that we are creating and then you
have to define
a platform as well now these are the
platforms
that are supported by the aws let's say
i wanted to run a node.js environment
so i'll just click on the node.js
platform the application codes
is something which is basically
developed by the developers
and you can upload the app application
right now or you can do that
later as well once the environment is
ready now
either you can select to create an
environment if you wanted to go with all
the default
settings otherwise if you wanted to
customize it more
you can click on configure more options
so let's click on configure more options
and here you would be able to define
various different features
like the type of an instance for example
what kind of
an ec2 instance or a server that should
be running
so that the bin stock can deploy our
applications over it
if you wanted to modify just click on a
modify button and
here you can modify your instances with
respect to the
storage as well now apart from that if
you wanted to
do some modification in the case of
monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security
or in the case of a capacity let's look
into the capacity
so here you can actually do the
modification so in the capacity you can
select
the instance type also by default it is
t2.micro but
in case if your application requires a
larger type of an instance
then you can actually go for the
instance type as well
similarly you can define your emi ids
also because
obviously for the application to run you
would require the operating system also
so you can select
that particular ami id for your
operating system as well
let's cancel that likewise you have many
other features
that you can actually define here from
the dashboard and you don't have to go
to the ec2 dashboard to do the
modifications
now let's go and create an environment
let's assume that we are going with the
default
configuration so this is going to create
our environment the
environment is being created and you can
get the environment and the logs
defined in the dashboard itself so you
see that the beanstalk environment is
being initiated
the environment is being started and in
case if there would be any errors or
if it is deployed correctly you will get
all the logs here itself
now the environments are basically color
coded so there are different color
codings that are
defined if you get the environment in a
green color that means
everything is good to go so here you can
see that
it has created an elastic ip it has
checked the health of the environment
now it has created the security groups
and that would be an auto security
groups created by the bean stock
and the environment creation has been
started you can see that
elastic bean stock has amazon s3 storage
bucket for your environment data as well
this is the url through which you will
be accessing the environment but right
now we cannot do that
since the environment is being created
let's click on the application name and
here you can see that it is in a gray
color that means
right now the build is being done it is
being
created once it will be successfully
created it should change to the green
color and then
we will be able to access our
environment using the
url now if i move to the ec2
instances and see in the ec2 dashboard
if i see whether
the instance is being created by the
bean stock or not so let's see
and let's see what are the differences
in terms of creating an instance
manually and getting it created
from the bean stock so click on the easy
to let's go to the old ec2 experience
that's what we are familiar with and
let's see what's there in the
dashboard so here you can see one
running instance
let's open that and the xyz environment
which was created from the beanstalk is
being initiated the instance is being
initiated
and that is something which is being
done by the mean stock itself we have
not gone to the dashboard and created it
manually
now in the security groups if you see
that here the
aws mean stock security groups are
defined it has the elastic ips also
defined
so everything is being created by the
beanstalk itself
right now let's go back to the beanstalk
and let's look into the
status of our environment whether the
color coding has been changed from gray
to
green or not and here you can see the
environment is successfully created
and we have that environment colored in
green
we will access the environment and it
says it's a web server environment
its platform is node.js running on
64-bit amazon linux ami and it says
samples app sample application health
status is okay now the other thing is
that if
you do not want to use the web console
the management console to
access the main stock then the beanstalk
offers you the
elastic beanstalk cli as well so you can
install the
command line interface and then you have
the command references cli command
references that you can actually play
with
and get your applications deployed using
the bean stock itself
so this is one of the sample cli
commands that you can actually
look into now let's look into the
environment let's click on the
environment and we'll be
represented with the url it says health
is okay
these are the logs that you have to
follow in case if there are any issues
the platform is nodejs that is what we
selected now the next thing is you just
have to upload and deploy your
applications
so just click on upload and deploy
select the version
label or the name select file and
wherever your application
is hosted at just select that upload it
and
deploy your application you'll see that
the like your environment is created
similarly your application will be
deployed automatically on the instance
and from this url you will be able to
view the output it is as simple as just
like you have to follow these four steps
now let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application
so we'll just click on this url since
the beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or
http port 80 for all we can actually
view that output directly from the url
so we have the node.js running that's
visible here
and after that you just have to upload
and deploy your application and then
from that url
you can get the output now this url you
can
map it with the root 53 service so using
the root 53 dns services
the domain names can be pointed to the
elastic bean stock url
and from there it can be pointed to the
applications that are running on the ec2
instance
whether you wanted to point it to the
url directly using the mean stock you
can do that otherwise
as we saw in the slides you can use the
root 53 pointer to the load balancer and
then point it
to the instances directly also once it
is created by the mean stock
so that was the demo guys uh with
respect to
the bean stock and how we can actually
run the environments
apart from that the operational task
like
system operations you can manage all
these things from
the environment dashboard itself so you
have the configurations you have the
logs you can actually check the health
status of your environment you can do
the monitoring and you can actually
get the alarms and the events here so
let's say if i wanted to
if i wanted to see the logs i can
request for the logs
here itself and i will be represented
with the full log report and i can now
download that log file and i can view
the locks
so it's in the so we have this bundle
locks in the zip file
all right so if you want to see some
kind of uh
logs with respect to elastic bean stock
activity it's in the form of a notepad
and here
you can see what all configurations the
beanstalk has done
on your environment on your instance
similarly you can go for the health
monitoring
alarms events and all those things if
getting your learning started is half
the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simplylearn
click on the link in the description to
know more
hi this is the fourth lesson of the aws
solutions architect course migrating to
the cloud doesn't mean that resources
become completely separated
from the local infrastructure in fact
running applications in the cloud
will be completely transparent to your
end users
aws offers a number of services to fully
and seamlessly integrate your local
resources
with the cloud one such service is the
amazon virtual private cloud
this lesson talks about creating virtual
networks that closely resemble the ones
that operate in your own data centers
but with the added benefit of being able
to take full advantage of aws
so let's get started
in this lesson you'll learn all about
virtual private clouds
and understand their concept you'll know
the difference between
public private and elastic ip addresses
you'll learn about what a public and
private sudden there is
and you'll understand what an internet
gateway is and how it's used
you'll learn what route tables are and
when they are used
you'll understand what a nat gateway is
we'll take a look at security groups and
their importance
and we'll take a look at network acls
and how they're used in amazon vpc
we'll also review the amazon vpc best
practices
and also the costs associated with
running a vpc in the amazon cloud
welcome to the amazon virtual private
cloud and subnet section in this section
we're going to have an overview of what
amazon vpc
is and how you use it and we're also
going to have a demonstration
of how to create your own custom virtual
private cloud
we're going to look at ip addresses and
the use of elastic ip addresses in
aws and finally we'll take a look at
subnets
and there'll be a demonstration about
how to create your own subnets in an
amazon vpc
and here are some other terms that are
used in vpcs
there's subnets root tables elastic ip
addresses
internet gateways nat gateways network
acls
and security groups and in the next
sections we're going to take a look at
each of these
and build our own custom vpc that we'll
use throughout this course
amazon defines a vpc as a virtual
private cloud
that enables you to launch aws resources
into a virtual network that you've
defined this virtual network closely
resembles a traditional network that
you'd operate in your own data center
but with the benefits of using the
scalable infrastructure
of aws
a vpc is your own virtual network in the
amazon cloud
which is used as the network layer for
your ec2 resources
and this is a diagram of default vpc
now there's a lot going on here so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default vpc
over the coming lesson but what you need
to know is that a vpc is a critical part
of the exam
and you need to know all the concepts
and how it differs from your own
networks
throughout this lesson we're going to
create our own vpc from scratch
which you'll need to replicate at the
end of this so you can do well in the
exam
each vpc that you create is logically
isolated from other virtual networks in
the aws cloud
it's fully customizable you can select
the ip address range
create subnets configure route tables
set up network gateways
define security settings using security
groups and network access control lists
so each amazon account comes with a
default vpc
that's pre-configured for you to start
using straight away
so you can launch your ec2 instances
without having to think about anything
we mentioned in the opening section
a vpc can span multiple availability
zones in a region
and here's a very basic diagram of a vpc
it isn't this simple in reality
and as we saw in the first section
here's the default amazon vpc
which looks kind of complicated but what
we need to know at this stage is
that cidr block for the default vpc is
always a 16
subnet mask so in this example
it's 172.31.0.0.16.
what that means is this vpc will provide
up to 65536 private ip addresses
so in the coming sections we'll take a
look at all of these different items
that you can see on this default vpc
but why wouldn't you just use the
default vpc
well the default vpc is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing aws
but creating a custom vpc allows you to
make things more secure
and you can customize your virtual
network as you can define your own
ip address range you can create your own
subnets that are both private and public
and you can tighten down your security
settings
by default instances that you launch
into a vpc
can't communicate with your own network
so you can connect your vpcs to your
existing data center
using something called hardware vpn
access
so that you can effectively extend your
data center into the cloud
and create a hybrid environment now to
do this you need a virtual private
gateway and this is the vpn concentrator
on the amazon side of the vpn connection
then on your side in your data center
you need a customer gateway
which is either a physical device or a
software application
that sits on your side of the vpn
connection
so when you create a vpn connection a
vpn tunnel comes up
when traffic is generated from your side
of the connection
vpc peering is an important concept to
understand
a parent connection can be made between
your own bpcs
or with a vpc in another aws account
as long as it's in the same region so
what that means is
if you have instances in vpca they
wouldn't be able to communicate with
instances in vpc b or c unless you set
up appearing connection
peering is a one-to-one relationship a
vpc can have multiple peering
connections to other vpcs
but and this is important transitive
peering is not supported
in other words vpca can connect to b
and c in this diagram but c
wouldn't be able to communicate with b
unless they were directly paired
also vpcs with overlapping cidrs
cannot be paired so in this diagram you
can see they all have different ip
ranges
which is fine but if they had the same
ipo ranges they wouldn't be
able to be paired and finally for this
section
if you delete the default vpc you have
to contact aws support to get it back
again
so be careful with it and only delete it
if you have good reason to do so
and know what you're doing this is a
demonstration of how to create
a custom vpc
so here we are back at the amazon web
services management console
and this time we're going to go down to
the bottom left where the networking
section is
i'm going to click on the pc
and the vpc dashboard will load up now
there's a couple of ways you can create
a custom vpc there's something called
the vpc wizard
which will build vpcs on your behalf
from a selection of
different configurations for example a
vpc with a single public subnet
or a bpc with public and private subnets
now this is great because you click a
button type in a few details and it does
the work for you
however you're not going to learn much
or pass the exam if this is how you do
it so
we'll cancel that and we'll go to your
vpcs
and we'll click on create a vpc
and we're presented with the create the
vpc window
so let's give our vpc a name i'm going
to call that simply learn
underscore vpc and this is the kind of
naming convention i'll be using
throughout this course
next we need to give it the cidr block
or the classless interdomain routing
block
so we're going to give it a very simple
one 10.0.0
and then we need to give it the subnet
mask so you're not allowed to go larger
than 15. so if i try to put 15
in it says no not going to happen
for a reference subnet mask of 15 would
give you
around 131 000 ip addresses
and subnet 16 will give you
65 536 which is probably more than
enough for what we're going to do
next you get to choose the tenancy
there's two options default and
dedicated
if you select dedicated then your ec2
instances will reside on hardware that's
dedicated
to you so your performance is going to
be great but your cost is going to be
significantly higher
so i'm going to stick with default and
we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our vpc dashboard we can see
our simply learn vpc
has been created now if we go down to
the bottom here to see the information
about our new vpc we can see
it has a root table associated with it
which is our default route table
so there it is and we can see that it's
only allowing local traffic at the
moment
we go back to the vpc again we can see
it's been given a default network acl
and we'll click on that and have a look
and you can see this is very similar to
what we looked at in the lesson
so it's allowing all traffic from all
sources inbound and outbound
now if we go to the subnet section
and just widen the vpc area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated
with the vpc we just created
so that means we won't be able to launch
any instances
into our vpc and to prove it
i'll just show you we'll go to the ec2
section
so this is a glimpse into your future
this is what we'll be looking at in the
next lesson
and we'll just quickly try and launch an
instance
we'll select any instance it doesn't
matter
any size not important so here the
network
section if i try and select simply learn
vpc
it's saying no subnets found
this is not going to work
so we basically need to create some
subnets in our vpc
and that is what we're going to look at
in the next lesson
now private ip addresses are ip
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet
and they're used for communication
between instances in the same network
when you launch a new instance is given
a private ip address
and an internal dns host name that
resolves to the private ip address of
the instance
but if you want to connect to this from
the internet it's not going to work
so then you'd need a public ip address
which is reachable from the internet
you can use public ip addresses for
communication between your instances
and the internet each instance that
receives a public ip address
is also given an external dns host name
public ip addresses are associated with
your instances
from the amazon pool of public ip
addresses
when you stop or terminate your instance
the public ip address is released
and a new one is associated when the
instance starts
so if you want your instance to retain
this public ip address
you need to use something called an
elastic ip address
an elastic ip address is a static or
persistent
public ip address that's allocated to
your account
and can be associated to and from your
instances as required
an elastic ip address remains in your
account until you choose to release it
there is a charge associated with an
elastic ip address
if it's in your account but not actually
allocated to an instance
this is a demonstration of how to create
an elastic
ip address
so we're back at the amazon web services
management console
we're going to head back down to the
networking vpc section
and we'll get to the vpc dashboard on
the left hand side
we'll click on elastic ips
now you'll see a list of any elastic ips
that you have associated
in your account and remember any the
elastic ip address that you're using
that isn't
allocated to something you'll be charged
for so i have one available
and that is allocated to an instance
currently so we want to allocate a new
address
and it reminds you that there's a charge
if you're not using it i'm saying yes
allocate
and it takes a couple of seconds and
there's our new
elastic ip address now we'll be using
this ip address
to associate with the nat gateway when
we build that
aws defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses
in your bpc you can launch aws resources
into a subnet that you select
you can use a public subnet for
resources that must be connected to the
internet
and a private subnet for resources that
won't be connected to the internet
the netmask for the default subnet in
your vpc
is always 20 which provides up to 4096
addresses per subnet
and a few of them are reserved for aws
use
a vpc can span multiple availability
zones
but the subnet is always mapped to a
single availability zone
this is important to know so here's our
basic diagram which we're now going to
start adding to
so we can see the virtual private cloud
and you can see the availability zones
and now inside each availability zone
we've rated a subnet
now you won't be able to launch any
instances unless there are subnets in
your vpc
so it's good to spread them across
availability zones for redundancy and
failover purposes
there's two different types of subnet
public and private
you use a public subnet for resources
that must be connected to the internet
for example web servers a public subnet
is made public
because the main route table sends the
subnets traffic
that is destined for the internet to the
internet gateway
and we'll touch on internet gateways
next private subnets
are for resources that don't need an
internet connection or that you want to
protect from the internet
for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets
a public and a private subnet and we're
going to put them in
our custom vpc in different availability
zones
so we'll head to networking and vpc
wait for the vpc dashboard to load up
we'll click on subnets
we'll go to create subnet and i'm going
to give the subnet a name
so it's good to give them meaningful
names so i'm going to call this first
one
for the public subnet 10.0.1.0
and i'm going to put this one in the us
east 1b
availability zone and i'm going to call
that
simplylearn
public so it's quite a long name i
understand but at least it makes it
clear for what's going on in this
example
so we need to choose a vpc so we
obviously want to put it in our simply
learn vpc
and i said i wanted to put it in us east
1b i'm using the north virginia region
by the way
so we click on that then we need to give
it the cidr block
now as i mentioned earlier when i typed
in the name
that's the range i want to use and then
we need to give it
the subnet mask and we're going to go
with 24
which should give us 251 addresses in
this range which obviously is going to
be more than enough
if i try and put a different value in
that's unacceptable to amazon
it's going to say it's going to give me
an error and tell me not to do that
let's go back to 24 and click i'm going
to cut and paste this by the way just
because i need to type something very
similar for the next one
click create
and it takes a few seconds
okay so there's our new subnet and i
just
widen this you can see so that's
the ip range that's the availability
zone
it's for simply learn and it's public so
now we want to create
the private so put the name in i'm going
to give the private
the ip address block of
that i'm going to put this one in us
east 1c and it's going to be the private
subnet obviously i want it to be in the
same vpc
better but it is the zone of us east 1c
and we're going to give it 10.0.2.0
24 and we'll click yes create
again it takes a few seconds
okay so we sort by name
so there we are we can see now we've got
our private subnet and our public subnet
let me just type in simply then there we
are so now you can see them both there
and you can see they're both in the same
vpc
simply learn vpc
now if we go down to the bottom you can
see the root table associated with these
vpcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access so that's
what we need to do next
in the next lesson you're going to learn
about internet gateways and how we can
make these
subnets have internet access
welcome to the networking section in
this section we're going to take a look
at
internet gateways root tables and nat
devices
and we'll have a demonstration on how to
create each of these
aws vpc items
so to allow your vpc the ability to
connect to the internet
you need to attach an internet gateway
and you can only attach one internet
gateway
per vpc so attaching an internet gateway
is the first stage in permitting
internet access to instances
in your vpc now here's our diagram again
and now we've added the internet gateway
which is providing the connection to the
internet
to your vpc but before you can
configure internet correctly there's a
couple more steps
for an ec2 instance to be internet
connected
you have to adhere to the following
rules firstly you have to
attach an internet gateway to your vpc
which we just discussed
then you need to ensure that your
instances have public ip addresses
or elastic ip addresses so they're able
to connect to the internet
then you need to ensure that your
subnets root table points to the
internet gateway
and you need to ensure that your network
access control and security group rules
allow relevant traffic to flow to and
from your instance
so you need to allow the rules to let in
the traffic you want
for example http traffic after the
demonstration for this section
we're going to look at how root tables
access control lists and security groups
are used
in this demonstration we're going to
create an internet gateway and attach it
to our custom vpc
so let's go to networking bpc
bring up the vpc dashboard and on the
left hand side
we click on internet gateways
so here's a couple of internet gateways
i have already
but i need to create a new one so create
internet gateway
i'll give it a name which is going to be
simply learn
internet gateway igw and i'm going to
click
create so this is an internet gateway
which will connect a vpc to the internet
because at the moment our custom vpc has
no internet access
so there it's created
simply then i gw but it's state is
detached because it's not attached to
anything
so let me try and attach it to a vpc
and it gives me an option of all the
vpcs that have no
internet gateway attached to them
currently so i only have one which is
simply then bpc
yes attach now you can see
our vpc has internet attached and you
can see that down here
so let's click on that and it will take
us to our vpc
but before any instances in our vpc can
access the internet
we need to ensure that our subnet root
table points to the internet gateway
and we don't want to change the main
route table we want to create a custom
route table
and that's what you're going to learn
about next
a route table determines where network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table
and a subnet can only be associated with
one
root table however multiple subnets can
be associated
with the same route table
every vpc has a default route table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state
and create a new route table to
customize the network traffic routes
associated with your vpc
so here's our example and we've added
two route tables
the main route table and the custom
route table
the new route table or the custom route
table will tell the internet gateway to
direct internet traffic to the public
subnet
but the private subnet is still
associated to the default route table
the main route table which does not
allow internet traffic to it
all traffic inside the private subnet is
just remaining local
in this demonstration we're going to
create a custom route table
associated with our internet gateway and
associate our public subnet with it
so let's go to networking and vpc
the dashboard will load and we're going
to go to route tables
now our vpc only has its main route
table at the moment the default one it
was given
at the time it was created so we want to
create a new
route table and we want to give it a
name so
we're going to call it simply learn
i'm going to call it root table rtb for
sure
and then we get to pick which vpc we
want to put it in
so obviously we want to use simply learn
vpc
so we click create
which will take a couple of seconds and
here you are here's our new route table
so what we need to do now is change its
route so that it points to the internet
gateway
so if we go down here to roots at a
minute you can see it's just like our
main route table it just has local
access
so we want to click on edit and we want
to add another route
so the destination is the internet
which is all the zeros and our target
and we click on this it gives us the
option of our internet gateway
which we want to do so now we have
internet access
to this subnet sorry to this route table
and we click on save save was successful
so now we can see that
as well as local access we have internet
access
now at the moment if we click on subnet
associations
you do not have any subnet associations
so basically both both our subnets the
public and private subnets are
associated with the main
route table which doesn't have internet
access so we want to change this
we'll click on edit and we want our
public
subnet to be associated with this root
table
so click on save
so it's just saving that so now
we can see that our public subnet is
associated with this route table
and this route table is associated with
the internet gateway so now anything we
launch
into the public subnet will have
internet access
but what if we wanted our instances in
the private subnet to have internet
access
well there's a way of doing that with a
nat device and that's what we're going
to look at in the next lecture
you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet
or other aws services but prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with the instances in the private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from being directly connected to the
internet
for example your web server would sit in
the public subnet
in your database in the private subnet
which has no internet connectivity
however your private subnet database
instance might still need
internet access or the ability to
connect to other aws resources
if so you can use a network address
translation device
or a nat device to do this and that
device
forwards traffic from your private
subnet to the internet
or other aws services and then sends the
response back to the instances
when traffic goes to the internet the
source ip address of your instance is
replaced with the nat device address
and when the internet traffic comes back
again then that device translates the
address to your instance's private ip
address
so here's our diagram which is getting
ever more complicated
and if you look in the public subnet you
can see we've now added and that device
and you have to put that devices in the
public subnet so that they get internet
connectivity
aws provides two kinds of nat devices
and that gateway and a nat instance
aws recommends a nat gateway as it's a
managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances each nat gateway is created in
a specific availability zone
and is implemented with redundancy in
that zone
and that instance is launched from a nat
ami
and amazon machine image and runs as an
instance in your vpc
so it's something else you have to look
after whereas in that gateway being a
fully managed service
means once it's installed you can pretty
much forget about it
and that gateway must be launched into a
public subnet because it needs internet
connectivity
it also needs an elastic ip address
which you can select
at the time of launch once created you
need to update the route table
associated with your private subnet to
point internet bound traffic to the nat
gateway
this way the instances in your private
subnets can communicate with the
internet
so if you remember back to the diagram
when we had the custom route table which
was pointed to the internet gateway
now we're pointing our main route table
to the nat gateway so the private subnet
also gets internet access
but in a more secure manner
welcome to the create a nat gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create a nat gateway
so that the instances in our private
subnet can get internet access
so we'll start by going to networking
and vpc
and the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at our subnets
and you'll see why shortly so here are
our simply learned subnets
so this is the private subnet that we
want to give internet access
but if you remember from the section
that gateways need to be placed in
public subnets
so i'm just going to copy the name of
this subnet id
for the public subnet and you'll see why
in a moment
so then we go to nat gateways on the
left hand side
and we want to create a new nat gateway
so we have to put a subnet in there so
we want to choose our public subnet as
you can see
it truncates a lot of the subnet names
on this option so it's a bit confusing
so we know that we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc
in the public subnet but you can see
it's truncated so it's actually this one
at the bottom but what i'm going to do
is just paste in the subnet id which i
copied earlier
so there's no confusion then we need to
give it an elastic ip address now if you
remember from the earlier demonstration
we created one so let's select that
but if you hadn't allocated one you
could click on the create new
eip button so
we'll do that okay so it's telling me my
nat gateway has been created
and in order to use your netgateway
ensure that you edit your route table to
include a route
with a target of and then on that
gateway id
so it's given us the option to click on
our edit route tables so we'll go
straight
there now here's our here's our route
tables
now
here's the custom route table that we
created earlier
and this is the default the main route
over which was created
when we launched our when we created our
vpc so we should probably give this a
name
so that we know what it is so let me
just call this simplylearn
rtb main
so now we know that's our main route
table
so if you take a look at the main route
table and the subnet associations
you can see that our private subnet is
associated with this table
so what we need to do is put a route in
here that points to the nat gateway
so if we click on routes and edit
and we want to add another route and we
want to say that
all traffic
can either go to the simply then
internet gateway which we don't want to
do we want to point it to our nat
instance which is this nat
id here and we click save
so now any instances launched in our
private subnet will be able to get
internet access
via on that gateway
welcome to the using security groups and
network acl
section in this section we're going to
take a look at security groups
and network acls and we're going to have
a demonstration on how we create both of
these items
in the amazon web services console
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that adow traffic
to or from its associated instances
basically a security group controls the
inbound and outbound traffic
for one or more ec2 instances
security groups can be found on both the
ec2 and vpc dashboards in the aws web
management console
we're going to cover them here in this
section and you'll see them crop up
again
in the ec2 lesson and here is our
diagram
and you can see we've now added security
groups to it
and you can see that ec2 instances are
sitting
inside the security groups and the
security groups will control
what traffic flows in and out
so let's take a look at some examples
and we'll start with a security group
for a web server
now obviously a web server needs http
and https traffic as a minimum
to be able to access it so here is an
example of the security group
table and you can see we're allowing
http and https
the ports that are associated with those
two and
the sources and we're allowing it from
the internet we're basically allowing
all traffic
to those ports and that means any other
traffic that comes in on different ports
would be unable
to reach the security group and the
instances inside it
let's take a look at an example for a
database server security group
now imagine you have a sql server
database then you would need to open up
the sql server port
so that people can access it and which
is port 1433 by default so we've added
that to the table
and we've allowed the source to come
from the internet
now because it's a windows machine you
might want rdp access
so you can log on and do some
administration so we've also added rdp
access
to the security group now you could
leave it open to the internet but that
would mean anyone
could try and hack their way into your
box so in this example we've added a
source ip address
of 10.0.0.0 so only ipa ranges from that
address
can rdp to the instance
now there's a few rules associated with
security groups
by default security groups allow all
outbound traffic
so if you want to tighten that down you
can do so in a similar way to you can
define the inbound traffic
security group rules are always
permissive you can't create rules that
deny access
so you're allowing access rather than
denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance
the response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in
regardless of the inbound security group
rules
and you can modify the rules of a
security group at any time
and the rules are applied immediately
welcome to the create security group
demonstration
where we're going to create two security
groups one the hostdb servers and one
the host web servers
now if you remember from the best
practices section it said it was always
a good idea to tear your applications
into security groups
and that's exactly what we're going to
do so we go to networking and vpc
to bring up the vpc dashboard on the
left hand side under security
we click on security groups now you can
also get to security groups from the ec2
dashboard as well
so here's a list of my existing security
groups but we want to create
a new security group and we're going to
call it
simply learn
web server sg security group
and we'll give the group name as the
same and our description is going to be
simply learn
web servers security groups
okay and then we need to select our vpc
now it defaults to the default vpc but
obviously we want to put it in
our simply learn vpc so we click yes
create
takes a couple of seconds and there it
is there's our new security group
now if we go down to the rules the
inbound rules
you can see there are none so by default
a new security group has no inbound
rules
but what about outbound rules if you
remember from the lesson
a new security group by default allows
all traffic to be outbound
and there you are all traffic has
destination of everywhere so all traffic
is allowed
we're going to add some rules so let's
click on inbound rules click on edit
now this is going to be a web server so
if we click on the drop down
we need to give it http so you can
either choose
custom tcp rule and type in your own
port ranges
or you can just use the ones they have
for you so http
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the source
now if i click on it it's giving me the
option of saying
allow access from different security
groups
so you could create a security group and
say i only accept traffic
from a different security group which is
a nice way of securing things down
you could also put in here just your ip
address so that only you
could do http requests to the instance
but because it's a web server we want
people to be able to see our website
otherwise it's not going to be much use
so we're going to say all traffic so all
source
traffic can access our instance on port
http
80. i want to add another rule because
we also want to do https
which is hiding from me
there we are and again we want to do
the same and also because this is going
to be a linux
instance we want to be able to connect
to the linux instance to do some work
and configuration so we need to give it
ssh
access and again it would be good
practice to tie it down to your specific
ip or an ip range
but we're just going to do all for now
and then we click on save
and there we are there we have our
ranges
so now we want to create our security
group for our db servers
so let's click create security group and
then we'll go through and give it a
similar name
simply learn
db servers sg
and the description is going to be
simply learn
db servers security group
and our vpc is obviously going to be
simply learn vpc
so let's click yes create wait a few
seconds
and here's our new security group as you
can see it has no inbound rules by
default
and outbound rules allow all traffic
so this is going to be a sql server
database server
and so we need to allow sql server
traffic into the instance
so we need to give it microsoft sql port
access now the default port for
microsoft sql server is 1433.
now in reality i'd probably change the
port the sql server was running on to
make it more secure but we'll go with
this for now
and then the source so we could choose
the ip ranges again
but what we want to do is place the db
server in the private subnet
and allow the traffic to come from the
web server
so the web server will accept traffic
and the web server will then go to the
database to get the information it needs
to display
on its web on the website or if people
are entering information into the
website we want the
information to be stored in our db
server so basically we want to say that
this
the db servers can only accept sql
server traffic
from the web server security group
so we can select the simply then web
server security group
as the source traffic for microsoft sql
server
data so we'll select that now our sql
server is obviously going to be a
windows instance
so from time to time we might not we
might need to log in
and configure it so we want to give rdp
access
now again you would probably put a
specific ip range in there
we're just going to do all traffic for
now then we click save
and there we are so now we have two
security groups
db servers and web servers
a network acl is a network access
control list
and it's an optional layer of security
for your vpc
that acts as a firewall for controlling
traffic in and out
of one or more of your subnets you might
set up network acls with rules similar
to your security groups
in order to add an additional layer of
security to your vpc
here is our network diagram and we've
added network acls
to the mix now you can see they sit
somewhere between the root tables
and the subnets this diagram makes it a
little bit clearer
and you can see that a network acl sits
in between a root table
and a subnet and also you can see an
example
of the default network acl which is
configured to allow all traffic to flow
in and out of the subnets to which is
associated
each network acl includes a whose rule
number is an asterisk
this rule ensures that if a packet
doesn't match any of the other numbered
rules
it's denied you can't modify or remove
this rule
so if you take a look at this table you
can see on the inbound
some traffic would come in and it would
look for the first rule which is 100
and that's saying i'm allowing all
traffic from all sources
so that's fine the traffic comes in if
that
rule 100 wasn't there it would go to the
asterix rule
and the aztecs rule is saying traffic
from all sources
is denied
let's take a look at the network acl
rules
each subnet in your vpc must be
associated with an acl
if you don't assign it to a custom acl
it will automatically be associated to
your default acl
a subnet can only be associated with one
acl
however an acl can be associated with
multiple subnets
an acl contains a list of numbered rules
which are evaluated in order
starting with the lowest as soon as a
rule matches traffic
it's applied regardless of any higher
numbered rules that may contradict it
aws recommends incrementing your rules
by a factor of 100
so there's plenty of room to implement
new rules at a later date
unlike security groups acls are
stateless
responses to allowed inbound traffic are
subject to the rules for outbound
traffic
welcome to the network acl demonstration
where we're just going to have an
overview of ocls where they are in the
dashboard
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam you just need to
know how they work and where they are
so let's go to networking and vpc
and on when the dashboard loads on the
left hand side under security there's
network acls
so let's click on that now you can see
some acls that are in my
my aws account so we want the one that's
associated with our simply learn vpc
so if we extend this vpc
column that's our network acl simply
then vpc
now let's give it a name because it's
not very clear to see otherwise
also i'm kind of an obsessive tagger so
let's call it
simply learn acl and click on the tick
so there we are so now it's much easier
to see so we click on inbound rules
so this is exactly what we showed you in
the lesson
the rule is 100 so that's the first rule
that's going to get evaluated and it's
saying
allow all traffic from all sources
and the outbound rules are the same so
if you wanted to
tighten down the new rule you could
click edit we would give it a new rule
number say which would be 200
so you should always increment them in
100 so that means if you had 99 more
rules you needed to
put in place you'd have space to put
them in in between these two
and then you could do whatever you
wanted you could say you know we are
allowing http access from
all traffic and we're allowing or you
could say actually you know what we're
going to deny it
so this is the way of blacklisting
traffic into your vpc
now i'm not going to save that because
we don't need it but this is where
network acls sit and this is where you
would make any changes
it's also worth having a look at the
subnet associations with your acl
so we have two subnets in our simply
learn vpc so we would expect to see both
of them associated with this
network acl because it's the default
and there they are this both are public
and our private subnets are associated
and you can also see up here on the on
the dashboard
it says default so this is telling us
this is our default acl
if you did want to create a new network
acl you would click create
network acl you'd give it a name
just say new acl and then you would
associate it with your vpc
so we would say simply learn vpc
takes a few seconds and there we are
there we have our new one
now you can see this one says default no
because it obviously isn't the default
acl for
our simply learn vpc and it has no
subnets associated with it
so let's just delete that because we
don't need it but there you are there's
a very brief overview of network
pcls
welcome to the amazon vpc best practices
and costs
where we're going to take a look at the
best practices and the costs associated
with the amazon virtual private cloud
always use public and private subnets
you should use private subnets to secure
resources that don't need to be
available
to the internet such as database
services
to provide secure internet access to the
instances that reside in your private
subnets
you should provide a nat device
when using that devices you should use a
nat gateway
over nat instances because they're a
managed service
and require less administration effort
you should choose your cidr blocks
carefully
amazon vpc can contain from 16 to 65
536 ip addresses so you should choose
your cidr block
according to how many instances you
think you'll need
you should also create separate amazon
vpcs for development
staging test and production or create
one amazon vpc
with separate subnets with a subnet each
for production development staging
and test you should understand the
amazon vpc limits
there are various limitations on the vpc
components
for example you're allowed 5 vpcs per
region
200 subnets per vpc
200 route tables per vpc
500 security groups per vpc
50 in and outbound rules per vpc
however some of these rules can be
increased by raising a ticket with aws
support
you should use security groups and
network acls to secure the traffic
coming in and out of your vpc
amazon advises to use security groups
for white listing traffic
and network acls for blacklisting
traffic
amazon recommends tiering your security
groups
you should create different security
groups for different tiers of your
infrastructure architecture
inside vpc if you have web tiers and db
tiers
you should create different security
groups for each of them
creating tier wise security groups will
increase the infrastructure security
inside the amazon vpc
so if you launch all your web servers in
the web server security group
that means they'll automatically all
have http and https
open conversely the database security
group will have sql server
ports already open you should also
standardize your security group naming
conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows amazon vpc
operation and management for large-scale
deployments to become much easier
always span your amazon vpc across
multiple subnets
in multiple availability zones inside a
region
this helps in architecting high
availability inside your vpc
if you choose to create a hardware vpn
connection to your vpc
using virtual private gateway you are
charged for each vpn connection hour
that your vpn connection is provisioned
and available
each partial vpn connection hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
you'll also incur standard aws data
transfer charges
for all data transferred via the vpn
connection
if you choose to create a nat gateway in
your vpc
you are charged for each nat gateway
hour that your nat gateway is
provisioned and available
data processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through the net
gateway
each partial nat gateway hour consumed
is billed as a full hour
this is the practice assignment for
designing a custom vpc
where you'll create a custom bpc using
the concepts learnt
in this lesson
using the concepts learnt in this lesson
recreate the custom vpc
as shown in the demonstrations the vpc
name should be simply learn vpc
the cidr block should be 10.0.0.0.16
there should be two subnets one public
with a range of 10.0.1.0
and one private with a range of 10.0.2.0
and they should be placed in separate
availability zones
there should be one internet gateway and
one that gateway
and also one custom route table for the
public subnet
also create two security groups simply
learn web server
security group and simply learn db
server security group
so let's review the key takeaways from
this lesson
amazon virtual private cloud or vpc
enables you to launch aws resources into
a virtual network that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network
that you'd operate in your own data
center but with the benefits of using
scalable infrastructure of aws
there are three types of ip address in
aws
a private ip address this is an ip
address that's not reachable over the
internet
and it's used for communication between
instances in the same network
a public ip address is reachable from
the internet
which you can use for communication
between your instances
and the internet and there's an elastic
i p address
this is a static public persistent ip
address
that persists after an instance restarts
whereas a public ip address
is raised associated after each restart
amazon defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your vpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select
and a subnet is always mapped to a
single availability zone
use a public subnet for resources that
must be connected to the internet
and a private subnet for resources that
won't be connected to the internet
to allow your vpc the ability to connect
to the internet
you need to attach an internet gateway
to it and you can only attach one
internet gateway per vpc
a root table determines where network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table
and a subnet can only have an
association with one root table
however multiple subnets can be
associated
to the same root table and you can use a
nat device
to enable instances in a private subnet
to connect to the internet
or other aws services but and that
device will prevent the internet from
initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that allow traffic
to or from its associated instances
a network access control list or network
acl
is an optional layer of security for
your vpc
that acts as a firewall for controlling
traffic in and
out of one or more of your subnets
today's session is on aws sagemaker
let's look into what we have in our
today's session so what's in it for you
we would be covering what is aws why do
we need
aws sage maker what is aws
sage maker services what are the
benefits of using the aws sagemaker
machine learning with aws sagemaker how
to train a model
with aws stage how to validate a model
with aws
and the companies that are using aws
shmaker along with that we will be
covering up
one live demo on the aws platform
now let's understand what is aws so
what is aws it's an amazon web services
it's a largest
or most widely used public cloud
platform
offered by amazon it provides services
over the internet
aws services can be used to build
monitor
and deploy any type of application in
the cloud aws also uses the subscription
pricing model
that means you only pay for whatever the
services you
use for now why do we need aws sagemaker
let's look into it
so let's consider an example of one of
the company that is
proquest now before aws age maker
the proquest is a global information
content and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers etc to the users
before awschmaker the proquest
requirement was
to have a better user experience maximum
relevant search results
now after aws shmaker they were able to
achieve those
results so they achieved more appealing
video user experience
they achieved more relevant search
results for the users now
what do we mean by aws sagemaker why
this service is primarily used
so amazon sage maker is a cloud machine
learning platform
that helps users in building training
tuning and deploying
machine learning models in a production
ready hosted environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
aws platform
now what are the benefits of using aws
sagemaker
uh the key benefits of using aw
sagemaker are
it reduces machine learning data cost so
you can do the cost optimization
while running this particular service on
the aws
all ml components are stored in a
particular
place in a dashboard so they can be
managed together
highly scalable so it can be scalable
on you can scale this particular service
on the fly
it trains the models quite faster
maintains
the uptime so you can be assured that
your workloads will be running all the
time it will be available all the time
high data security so security becomes a
major concern on the cloud platforms
and it ensures that you have the high
data
security along with that you can do a
data transfer to different aws services
like s3 bucket and all
with these simple data transfer
techniques
now machine learning with aws sagemaker
let us look into it
so machine learning with aws sagemaker
is a
three-step function so one is to build
second is to test and tune the model and
third is to deploy the model now with
the build it provides more than
15 widely used ml algorithms for
training purpose
now to build a model you can collect and
prepare training data
or you can select from the amazon s3
bucket also
choose and optimize the required
algorithm so some of the algorithms that
you can select
are k-means linear regressions logistic
regression
sage maker helps developers to customize
ml instances
with the jupiter notebook interface
in the test and tune you have to set up
and manage the environment
for training so you would need some
sample data to train the model
so train and tune a model with the
amazon
sage maker sage maker implements hyper
parameter tuning
by adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters
also it divides the training data and
stores that in the
amazon s3 s3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data
hence it is used for storing and
recovering data over the internet
and below you can see that aws sagemaker
uses amazon s3 to store data as it's
safe and
secure also it divides the training data
and stores in amazon s3
where the training algorithm code is
stored in the
ecr ecr stands for elastic container
registry which is primarily used for
containers and dockers
ecr helps users to save monitor and
deploy docker and the containers
later sage maker sets up a cluster for
the input data
trains it and stores it in the amazon s3
itself so this is done by the sagemaker
itself
after that you need to deploy it so
suppose you want to predict limited data
at a time
you use amazon sage maker hosting
services for that okay
but if you want to get prediction for an
entire data set
prefer using amazon sage maker batch
transform
now the last step that is to deploy
the model so once tuning is done models
can be deployed
to sagemaker endpoints and in the end
point
real time prediction is performed so you
would have some data
which you would reserve and validate
your model whether it is working
correctly or not now evaluate your model
and determine whether you have achieved
your business goals
now the other aspect is how we can train
a model with aws stage maker
so this is basically a flow diagram
which shows you how to train a model
with the aws sagemaker
and here we have used couple of services
of an aws
to get that done so model training in
age maker is done on machine learning
compute instances
and here we can see there are two
machine learning compute instances
used as helper code and the training
code
along with that we are using 2s3 buckets
and the ecr for the container registry
now let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
so below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements
to train a model the url of an amazon s3
bucket
where the training data is stored that
is mentioned
the compute resources on machine
learning compute instances
so these are all your machine learning
compute instances
then the url of an amazon s3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of aws elastic container
registry
where the code data is safe the
inference code image lies in the
elastic container registry now what are
these calls
these are called as the training jobs
now when a user trains a model in amazon
sage maker he she creates a training job
so we need to first create a training
job
and then the input data is fetched from
the specified amazon s3 bucket
once the training job is built amazon
sage maker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the
training job is built then it trains the
model with the training code and the
data set
and it shows the output and model rt
graphs in the aws s3 bucket so this is
done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task
when the training code fails the
interference code
which is in the elastic container
registry consists of
multiple linear sequence containers that
process the request for
inference on data the ec2 container
registry
is a container registry that helps users
to save monitor and deploy container
images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified
amazon s3 bucket so here you can see the
output will be stored here
to prevent your algorithm being deleted
save the data
in amazon's sagemaker critical system
which can process you on
your ml compute instances now how to
validate a model
let's look into it so you can evaluate
your model
using offline or using the historical
data
so first thing is that you can do the
offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or
real time streams coming you can
validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a holdout set
and also you can validate using the k
fold
validation now use historical data to
send requests to the model
through the jupiter notebook in amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation
online testing with livedata deploys
multiple models
into the endpoints of amazon sagemaker
and directs live traffic
to the model for validation validating
using a holdout set
is part of the data is set aside where
which is called holdout set so the part
of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training so later when the model is
trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learnt initially so whatever the data
which is left out
will be used for validating a model
because we have not used the data
while training a model the k-fold
validation
is the input data is split into two
parts
one part is called k which is the
validation data
for testing the model and the other part
is k minus 1
which is used as a training data now
based on the input data the machine
learning model evaluates
the final output now
the companies that are using aws
sagemaker one is the adp
so you must be knowing about adb zlando
dow jones which is the stock market
proquest
and the intuit now let's look into the
demo
that how we can actually run the aws
sagemaker
so we'll use the r algorithm and then
package the algorithm as a container for
building training and deploying a model
we are going to use the jupyter notebook
for that
for model building for model training
for model deployment
and the code for the demo is in the
below link so you can see here
that from this link you can get the code
for the demo
let's try to do a demo on the aws
now i would be using a link which is
provided by amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sagemaker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where
you can put those steps and the code
python codes into your
aws sagemaker jupiter lab so in this
tutorial you will learn how to use
amazon sagemaker to build train and
deploy a machine learning model
and for that we will use the popular xt
boost ml algorithm for this exercise
so first of all what you need to do is
you have to go to the aws console and
there you have to create a notebook
instance
so in this tutorial you will be creating
a notebook instance
you will prepare the data train the
model to learn from the data
deploy the model evaluate your ml
model's performance and once all those
activities are done then we will see how
we can actually remove all the resources
in order to prevent the extra costing
now the first step is we have to enter
to the amazon stage maker console
so here you can see i'm already logged
in into the sagemaker console
you can click on the services search for
the sagemaker here
and here you get the amazon sagemaker
service
now the next step is that we have to
create a notebook instance
so we will select the notebook instance
from the sagemaker service
and then after the notebook instance is
selected we'll put a name to our
instance
and we'll create a new im role for that
so let's wait for the sage maker studio
to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and you just have to click on
the notebook instances and here you have
to create a notebook instance so here
you can see couple of notebook instances
have already been created
one of them is in service so this is the
notebook instance that we are going to
use for
creating the demo model i'll show you
how you can create a notebook instance
you just have to click on create
notebook instance button
and put your notebook instance name so
you can put something like demo
dash sage maker 987 or we can put it as
model we'll go with notebook instance
type as default which is mlt2.medium
and in the permission and encryptions
under the i am role
we'll click on create a new i am role
now why we are creating a new im rule so
that we can allow the sage maker
to access any s3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see
that the new im role will be created
with the set of permissions
the rest of the things will keep it as
default and then you just have to click
on
create a notebook instance the notebook
instance creation takes some time so you
just have to wait for a couple of
minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created
so we will be using that to create
a demo now going back to the steps
so these are the steps that we have
already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so in this step we will be
using the sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data
that would require to train the machine
learning model
and for that we would be opening up the
jupiter notebook
and then we have to select an
environment a kernel environment in the
jupiter notebook that would be
conda underscore python 3.
so let's follow these steps go back to
the sage maker
click on the notebook instances
select the running notebook instance and
here
you would select the open jupiter lab
now here you would see that the
sagemaker would try to open up
the jupiter notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that
jupiter notebook and executing the
results there itself so just wait for
the notebook to open
now here you can see the jupyter lab
notebook has been open
so i would be selecting one of the
notebook that has been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also
how you can do that first of all let me
select the kernel environment so i would
be selecting
underscore python 3 and just click on
select
so how you can create your own notebook
just have to click on file
click on new and here you can select the
notebook
just name your notebook select the
environment
conda underscore python 3 to run this
demo
so i have my notebook open so in the
tabs i would be putting up the python
codes
and i would be executing those codes to
get the output directly
so the next step is to prepare the data
train the ml model and deploy it we will
need to import some libraries
and define a few environment variables
in the jupyter notebook environment
so i would be copying this code which
you can see that would try to import
numpy pandas these are all required to
run the
python syntax so
just copy this code
and paste it into your notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see that you get the
output
which is that it has imported
all the necessary libraries that have
been defined in the code
now the next step is we would create an
s3 bucket
into the s3 service and for that you
have to copy this python code
just that you have to edit it so you
have to specify
this bucket name that you want to get
created so here i would
provide the bucket name which should be
unique
should not overlap so something like
sage maker dash
demo
is the name that i have selected for the
bucket and now you have to
execute that code it says that the s3
bucket has been created successfully
with the name sage maker dash demo 9876
so this is something which you can
verify so you can go to the s3
service and there you can verify whether
the bucket has been created or not
now the next task is that we need to
download the data
to the aws sagemaker instance and load
it into the data frame
and for that we have to follow this url
so from this url which is build train
deploy machine learning model
would have a data in the form of bank
underscore clean.csv
and this will be deployed onto our
sagemaker instance
we'll copy this code and
paste it here and execute the code
so it says that it has successfully
downloaded
bank underscore clean.csv which is which
has the data inside it
and that has been loaded into the sage
maker
data frame successfully now we have a
data to
build and train our machine learning
model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it
one into the training data set and the
other one into
test data set so for the training data
set we are going to use 70
of the customers that are listed in the
csv file
and 30 of the customers in the csv file
data we will be using it as a test data
to train the model
so we will copy the following code into
a new code cell
and then we are going to run that code
cell
so i'll just copy it for training the
data so that we can segregate
the data model 70 for building the model
and 30 for testing the
data so click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output
successfully
now we have to train the model from that
data so how we are going to train that
model
and for that we will use sagemaker
prebuilt xgboost model which is an
algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and first column of the training data
and load the data from the
s3 bucket so what i'll do is i'll copy
this syntax
paste it in the note cell
so it has the trained data it would
train
the model click on run execution
now it is changing the s3 input class
which will be
renamed to training input because now we
are training the model
with the training data so we just have
to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sage maker session
to create an instance of the xgboost
model
so here we are going to create this
sagemaker session say
we are going to create an instance of
the xt boost model
which is an estimator so just copy that
copy that code
and paste it here
execute it and here you can see that
it will start it has basically changed
the parameter image name to the image
underscore uri in this sage maker python
sdk v2
now we'll follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the xt boost
estimator
we'll set up train the model using
gradient optimization
and we'll copy the following code and
that would
actually start the training of the model
so copy this code
and this would actually start
training the model using our input data
that we have reserved 70
of that data that we have reserved for
training the model
so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job now we'll deploy
the model
and for that i would copy the deploy
code
put that in the cell
and execute it so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image uri and using already existing
model so xd boost was
deployed already uh if you have not done
that
if you're doing it first time so it will
initiate another xd boost instance
so where you can find your xt boost
endpoints created you just have to
scroll down
and here under the interference
click on the endpoints and you should
find
the xt boost endpoints defined here so
here you can see
that today i have created one xt boost
endpoint and that is uh now in process
of
creating so just refresh it
so it is still created it is going to
take some time
to get that in service now our endpoint
is
in service state so now we can use it so
going forward with the next steps we'll
try to predict whether the customer in
the test data enroll for the bank
product or not
for that we are going to copy this code
put that in the jupiter
cell function and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has
actually evaluated and the same output
we got
in the screenshot of the demo as well
now we are going to evaluate the model
performance
so what we are going to do we are going
to get the prediction done
so based on the prediction we can
conclude that you predicted a customer
that will enroll for a certificate of
deposit accurately for
90 of the customers in the test data
with the
precision of 65 percent for enrolled and
which are which haven't enrolled for it
so for that we are going to copy
this code
and executed here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is
working absolutely fine so here you can
say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate prediction that
has
been made by the model and that's what
the output we can see
here in the screenshot of a model
so that means our model is absolutely
working fine it has been
built deployed and trained correctly
now the next thing is that once you are
done with that you terminate your
resources
and for that you just have to copy
this code and put that in the cell
function so that
the additional resources and the
endpoints and the buckets that have been
created
by the jupiter notepad should be
terminated so that you would not be
incurred with the
extra costing so just execute it
and here you would see that it has tried
to it would
try to terminate all the additional
resources that we have created from the
jupyter notebook
today's tutorial is on aws cloudfront
let's look into what we have today
in the cloud front so what's in it for
you
we would be covering up the concept of
what is aws
what was earlier uh before aws
cloudfront
after aws cloudfront what were the
services that were introduced how it
benefited
what do we mean by aws cloudfront
benefits of
the using aws cloudfront and how aws
cloudfront actually
is known as a content delivery service
the name of the companies that are using
aws
cloud front and we would be covering up
on live demo
now aws is the amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider
that basically offers a multiple
services variety of services
such as compute power database storage
networking and other resources so that
you can
create your solutions on the cloud and
help the business grow
now with aws you only pay for whatever
the services you use so for example
if you are using a service for a couple
of hours then you pay for only that many
hours
that you have used that service
before aws cloud front so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is
you must be aware of an application
called spotify
so when you used to access spotify and
when you click on it it kept on loading
and
at the end you used to get the error and
the error was that the connection failed
and
why you received that error because of a
latency issue
probably a network error right so how
you can solve these kind of a latency
issues
and that is also going to these kind of
an issues are also going to impact the
performance of an application so with
the introduction of aws cloud from this
problem of
loading the application got resolved so
after aws cloud front with the help of
idle play slot front spotify gives
the facility of updating new features
access to million
songs that you can access instantly
so with the use of aws cloudfront or the
latency issues were
solved and successfully you can
basically
access your application now what
we mean by aws cloudfront so aws
cloudfront is a
globally distributed network that is
offered by
aws amazon web services which securely
delivers content
to the end users across any geography
with a higher transfer speed and an
improve
or a low latency now what are the
benefits of aws cloudfront there are
multiple benefits
one is the cost effective so it helps
you to do the cost optimization when you
use the
cloud front it is time saving
so it is implemented easily
and also a lot of issues with respect to
accessing the application
with respect to latency and all can be
resolved
content privacy so the content is
placed to the end users and also to
the cloudfront servers in a secured
manner in a secured way it is highly
programmable
and you can make the changes amend the
changes on the fly
and you can target any location any
geography across the globe
along with that it helps you to get the
content
deliver quickly now how aws cloudfront
delivers the content
let's look into the architecture so
this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content
from the cloud front now the client
first access a website by typing a url
on the browser
and in the step one it takes tries to
access the application
then the client requests when the
website is open the client request
for an object to download such as for
example a particular file
now at that time the dns
routes user request to download that
file to aws cloudfront
the aws cloud front connects to the
nearest
edge locations edge locations are
basically the servers
where it caches the files documents and
the web codes
aws cloud front connects to its nearest
edge location
in order to serve the user the request
at edge location aws cloud front looks
for its requested cache file
once the file is found let's say if the
file is available in the cache of an
edge location
aws cloudfront then sends the file to
the
user otherwise if the file is not found
in the cache
memory of an edge location ews cloud
front
compares the requirement with the
specification and share it with a
respected server that means a web server
or a server where the file is actually
available
the server the web server responds to
the edge location by
sending the file back to the cloudfront
edge location
and then as soon as the aws cloud front
receives the file
it shares with the client also adds the
file to the
cache of an edge location for a future
reference
this is how the flow of a cloud front is
now
the name of the companies that are using
the aws cloud front
so one of them is jio7 app which is
which is a very popular app
so it uses amazon cloudfront to deliver
15 petabytes of audio and video to its
subscribers globally which is a huge
data
sky news it uses the service in order to
unify the content for faster
distribution to scrub subscribers or the
discovery communications
also uses the cloud front it uses the
service for delivering api
static asset and also the dynamic
content
and then the tv one eu streaming europe
is basically also uses the cloudfront
service
that helps in improving latency and
performance that results in fastest
delivery of content now let's look into
the demo how to use cloudfront to serve
private s3 bucket
as a website now i'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the aws console
and we'll basically try to deliver the
content from a
private s3 bucket and then map that
with the domain name using the root 53
service
so what we need for this demo we would
need
a domain url we would need a route 53
service
we would need cloud front uh we have to
create a cloud front distribution
and that will be linked with our s3
bucket the private s3 bucket
right and in the s3 bucket we would have
one html file the index.html file
so let's move into aws console
so right now i have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see that couple of
distributions have already been created
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content
one is the web distribution and the
other one is
rtmp rtmp stands for real time
audio or video distribution it's
basically
used for distribution of a media content
or a media file which are available in
the s3 bucket
here we are going to select a web
distribution
because primarily we will be using files
which uses
protocols http or the https
so you have to click on get started and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify
the bucket where your code is available
so i have a bucket already created
here you can see and what you need to do
is you have to create a bucket
with the url name or the domain name
which you would be mapping with the
route 53 service so this is a bucket
that has already been created
let me show you in a new tab so
here you have to go to the storage under
the storage
you have to select the s3 bucket let's
open the link in the new tab
and let's look into how we can create
the s3 buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created i have created one bucket with
the domain name that i'm
going to use and map it with the root 53
service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an html web page the
index.html has been
already added right so similarly you
have to
create a bucket with a domain and an
index.html page
needs to be uploaded there now again
we'll go to the cloud front we will try
to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method select an
origin domain
which is sunshinelearning.n
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin id
is this one so basically when you define
an origin domain name
automatically the origin id appears you
can customize this origin id as per your
requirement also so rest of the things
primarily we keep it as a default
settings only until and unless if we
require some customized settings to be
done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either select use all edge locations for
the best performance
so what does aws basically do here
it uses all the age locations which are
associated
with aws across the globe otherwise you
can specify based on the regions also
right apart from that if you want to
enable
firewalls or the access control list you
can specify here
and then what you need to do is
in the default root object here you have
to specify
your index.html page which is
in the s3 bucket the distribution state
has to be enabled
and if you want to use ipv6 as well you
need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you can see here a distribution has
been created
it's in progress and it is enabled
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution
completed the reason is that the web
codes the web pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time
to get that done right well let's move
on to
route 53 service and let's create the
hosted zones
so we'll type route 53 here scalable dns
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is we
are going to map
our url the domains
pointed to the name servers that will be
provided by the root 53 so we have to
create a hosted zone
let's wait for it so
now the root 53 dashboard is open and
you can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click
on the hosted zones and in order to
point
the traffic from the external domains
towards
the aws you have to first point the
domains traffic
to the hosted zone in the route 53
so i'll click on create hosted zone but
before that i will
first delete the existing one
and then i'll create another record
another hosted zone
right put your domain name
let's say i put as sunshine learning dot
in
and it is acting as a public hosted zone
rest of the things will be default
click on create hosted zone
now it gives you four name servers and
these four name servers has to be
updated
in the domain so you have to update
these name servers in a platform from
where you have purchased the
domain right so this is half of the work
done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create
records now in the records you can
select a routing policy so right now
what we are targeting
we are targeting basically that the
traffic
from the domain should be pointed
directly towards the cloudfront
distribution
hence we are going with a simple routing
right now
click on next here you have to
specify the record sets so we are going
to create the records
uh just click on default simple record
put here as world wide web
and you have to select an end point so
end point we are selecting for the
cloudfront distribution so we have to
specify
alias for the cloudfront distribution
now here we are going to put the
cloudfront distribution url
and then we are going to define the
simple report set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution url
which you can find it uh from the
cloudfront service itself
and you can find the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that and then
paste it here in the distribution
and then just click on define simple
records
again click on create records and here
you can see
the record set has been updated now this
domain
is basically pointed towards these name
servers
which are further pointed towards the
cloud front distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain
you should update these phone name
servers and
then you can see the live traffic coming
on this domain
will have an output from the cloud front
distribution
today's topic is on aws auto scaling so
this is akil i would be taking up a
tutorial on the auto scaling
let's begin with our tutorial and let's
look into what we have in
today's session so i would be covering
up
why we require aws auto scaling what is
aws auto scaling what are the benefits
of using the scaling service
how this auto scaling works the
different
scaling plans we have what is the
difference between the snapshot
and the ami what is the load balancer
and how many types of load balancers we
have and along with that i would be
covering up a real life demo on the aws
let's begin with why we require aws auto
scaling
now before aws cloud scaling there was a
question in the mind of enterprises
that they were spending a lot of money
on the purchase of the infrastructure if
they have to set up some kind of a
solution so they have to purchase an
infrastructure and one time cost was
required
so that was a burden for them in terms
of procuring a server hardware software
and then
having a team of experts to manage all
those infrastructure
so they used to think that no longer
they require these resources
if there was a cost efficient solution
for their project that was the project
manager used to think
now after the aws cloud scaling that was
introduced
automatically the auto scaling maintains
the application performance
based on the user requirements at the
lowest possible price
so what does the auto scaling does is
that whenever there is a scalability
required it manages it automatically
and hence the cost optimization became
possible
now what is aws auto scaling let's look
into deep
so aws auto scaling is a service that
helps users
to monitor their applications and the
servers
and automatically adjust the capacity of
their infrastructure
to maintain the steadiness so they can
increase the capacity they can even
decrease the capacity also for the cost
optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible
cost now what are the benefits of
auto scaling it gave the better fault
tolerance
applications you can get the servers
created and you can have a clone copy of
the servers
so that you don't have to deploy the
applications again and again
better cost management because the
scalability is decided by
the aws automatically based on some
threshold parameters
it was a reliable service and
whenever the scaling is created or
initiated
you can get the notifications onto your
mail ids or to your cell phones
scalability as i mentioned is always
there in the auto scaling it can scale
up it can scale down
as well and it has the flexibility
the flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it
if you want to stop it if you want to
keep size of the
servers at a fixed number uh you can
always
make the changes on the fly and the
better availability
now with the use of the auto scaling
we come around with the terminology
called snapshot and the ami
let's look into the difference between
the snapshots and the ami
snapshots versus ami so in a company
there was one of the employee that was
facing an issue with launching the
virtual machines
so he asked his colleague a question is
it possible to launch multiple virtual
machines with a minimum amount of time
because it takes a lot of time in terms
of creating the virtual machines
the other colleagues said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration
and this can be done either you use a
snapshot or the ami on the aws
then the colleague said that what are
the differences between the snapshot and
ami
let's look into the difference now the
snapshots basically kind of a backup
of a single ebs volume which is just
like a
virtual hard drive that is attached to
the ec2 instance
whereas the ami it is basically used as
a backup of an
ec2 instance only the snapshots
opts for this when the instance contain
multiple static ebs
when you opt for the snapshot whenever
the instance contains multiple statics
evs volumes ami this is widely used to
replace
the failed ec2 instance
in the snapshots here you pay only for
the storage of the modified data
whereas with the ami you pay only for
the storage
that you use the snapshots are
non-bootable images on ebs volume
whereas ami are bootable images on the
ec2 instance
however creating an ami image will also
create the evs snapshots
now how does aws auto scaling work let's
look into it
so for the aws auto scaling to work you
have to configure single unified scaling
policy for application resource
and this scaling policy with that you
can explore the applications also
and then select the service you want to
scale
also for the optimization select do you
want to optimize
cost or do you want to optimize the
performance
and then keep track of scaling by
monitoring or getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have
so in the auto scaling a scaling plan
basically helps a user to configure a
set of instructions
for scaling based on the particular
software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of aws auto scaling on how
to optimize resources
in a particular application so it's
basically a kind of
the parameters that you set it up so
that how the
resource optimization can be achieved in
the auto scaling
with the scaling strategies users can
create their own strategy based on their
required metrics and thresholds and this
can be changed on the fly as well
what are the two types of scaling
policies we have so there are basically
dynamic scaling and the predictive
scaling
now what is dynamic scaling it basically
guides the service of aws auto scaling
on how to optimize the resources
and it is helpful in optimizing
resources for availability and
particular price now with scaling
strategies
users can create their plan based on the
required metrics and
thresholds so a metric can be like let's
say a network in network out or it can
be a cpu utilization
memory utilization likewise
now in the predictive scaling its
objective is to predict
future workload based on daily and
weekly trends and
regular forecast future network traffic
so it is kind of
a forecast that happens based on the
previous past
experiences it uses a machine learning
technique for analyzing that network
graphic
and this scaling is like how weather
forecast
works right it provides schedule
scaling actions to ensure the resource
capacity is available
for application requirement
now with the auto scaling you would need
the load balancers also because if there
are multiple instances that are created
then you would need a load balancer to
distribute
the load to those instances so let's
understand what do we mean by
a load balancer a load balancer
basically acts as a reverse proxy
and it is responsible for distributing
the network or the application traffic
across multiple
servers with the help of a load balancer
you can achieve a reliability you can
achieve a fault tolerance of an
application
that is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability
so for example when there is a high
network traffic that is coming
to your application and if that much
traffic comes to your application to the
instances
your instances may crash so how you can
avoid that situation
so you need to manage the network
traffic that is coming to your instances
and that can be done with the load
balancer so thanks to the aws load
balancers which helps in distributing
network traffic across backend servers
in a way that it increases performance
of an application
here in the image you can see the
traffic coming from a different
resources
landing on to the ec2 instance and the
load balancer is actually distributing
that traffic to all the three instances
hence managing the network traffic
quite properly now what are the types of
load balancers we have
there are three types of load balancers
on the aws one is the classic load
balancer second is the application load
balancer
and the third one is the network load
balancer let's
look into what we have in the classic
load manager
so the classic load balancer is the most
basic form of load balancing
and we call it as a primitive load
balancer also
and it is widely used for the ec2
instances
it is based on the ip address and the
tcp port and it routes
network traffic between end users as
well as in between the backend servers
and it does not support host-based
routing and it results in low efficiency
of resources
let's look into what we have in the
application load balancer
this is one of the advanced forms of
load balancing it performs a task
on the application level in the osi
model
it is used when there are http and https
traffic routing is required
and also it supports the host based and
pathways routing and performs well with
the
microservices or the backend
applications
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer 4
of the connection level in the osi model
the prime role of the network load
balancer is to route the tcp
traffic and it can manage a massive
amount of traffic and is also suitable
to manage the low latencies
let's look into the demo and see how
practically we can
create the auto scale guys
let's look into the demo for how we can
create an auto scaling on the aws
console
so right now i'm logged into the aws
console and i am in the mumbai region
what you need to do is you have to go to
the compute section and under that
click on the ec2 service let's wait for
the ec2 servers to come
now just scroll down and
under the load balancing there is an
option called auto scaling
so there first you have to create a
launch configuration and then after that
you have to create the auto scaling
groups
so click on launch configuration
and then you have to click on create
launch configurations
so click on create launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define
while launching an auto scaling so that
this uniformity is maintained
with all the instances so that includes
let's say if you select a windows os or
linux os
that particular type of an operating
system will be implemented in all the
instances that will be part of an auto
scaling
so there are certain set of parameters
that we have to specify during the
launch configuration
so that we can have a uniformity in
terms of launching the servers
so here i would select an amazon linux
ami
and then i would select the type of
server which will be t2.micro
click on configure details put
the name to the launch configuration
let's say we put it as a demo
and the rest of the things we'll keep it
default
click on add storage since it's a linux
ami we can go with the 8gb storage that
should be fine
click on configure security group
let's create a new security group which
has the ssh port opened
and that is open for anywhere which is
basically source ipv4 and ipv6 ips any
ip will be able to access that
click on review just review your launch
configuration if you want to make
changes you can do that otherwise
click on create a launch configuration
you would need
the key pair and this key pair will be a
unique key pair
which will be used with all the
instances that are part of the auto
scaling group
so we can select an existing keypair if
you have that otherwise you can create a
new keypair
so i have an existing keypair i'll go
with that acknowledge it
and click on create launch confusion
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling
the next thing is to create an auto
scaling group so
click on create an auto scaling group
using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test
and the group size to start with uh it
says one instance so that means
at least a single instance will always
be running
and it will be initiated and running 24
cross 7 till the auto scaling is
available
you can increase the size of the minimum
base instances also let's say you can
change it to two also
so you would get at least two servers
running all the time
so we'll go with the one instance the
network would be the vpc default and
uh in the vpc particular region we can
select the availability zones so let's
say if i select availability zone 1a
and then availability is on one b so how
the instances will be launched
so one instance will be launched in one
a the other one in the one b
the third one in the one a fourth one
and the one b likewise
it will be equally spreaded among the
availability zones
next part is to configure the scaling
policies so click on it
if you want to keep this group at its
initial size let's say if you want to go
with only a single instance or two
instances and you don't want the scaling
to progress you can put it
keep this group at its initial size so
this is basically a way to hold the
scaling
but we'll use the scaling policies to
adjust the capacity of this group
so click on it and we would scale
between let's say minimum one instance
that we have
and we'll scale it between one two four
instances
and what condition on what basis these
instances will be scaled
up or scaled down would be defined in
the scale group size
so the scaling policies you can
implement
based on a scale group size or
using the simple scaling policies using
the steps
so in the scale group size you have a
certain metrics
you can use average cpu utilization you
can define a metric related to average
networking
average network out or the load balancer
request counts per target
and if you create the simple scaling
policies using steps then
you need to create the alarms and there
you can get some more metrics that you
can add up
as a parameter for the auto scaling
let's go with the scaling group size
let's go with the metric type as average
cpu utilization
and the target value here you have to
specify what would be the
threshold that when the instance cpu
utilization is crossed
then a new instance should be initiated
so you can
put a reasonable threshold for that
let's say we put something like 85
percent
and whenever the instance cpu
utilization is crossed 85
threshold you will see that there will
be a new instance created
let's go to the next configure
notifications
and here you can add notifications so
let's say if there is a new instance
that is initiated and you want to
basically be notified so you can get
notifications over your email ids or you
can get it on the cell phones
so for that for adding the notification
you would need the sns service
that is called as a simple notification
service and
you have to create a topic there you
have to subscribe for the topic
using your email id and then you should
get the notifications
click on configure tags the tags are not
mandatory you can basically
put a tag let's say if you want to
identify the instance for the purpose it
was created
otherwise you can leave it blank also
click on review
and review your scaling policies
notification
tags as well as the scaling group
details
click on create auto scaling group and
here you go
your scaling has been launched click on
close
and you should get at least a single
instance
initiated automatically by the auto
scaling
so let's wait for the details to appear
so here you can see
our launch configuration name demo auto
scaling group name
test minimum instance we want
one the maximum instances we want four
we have selected two availability zones
ap south one ap south 1b
and the instance one has been initiated
and if
you want to verify where exactly this
instance has been initiated
just click on the instances here and
here you will see
that our single instance has been
initiated that is in service
and that has been initiated in ap south
1b
now once the threshold of this instance
crosses 85 percent that is what we have
defined in the scaling policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated
so likewise this is basically i have
created
steps to initiate a scaling policy that
means to increase the
number of servers whenever the threshold
crosses likewise here itself you can add
another policy
to scale down the resources in case
if the cpu utilization goes to a
normal value today we are going to
discuss about amazon redshift
which is one of the data warehouse
service on the aws
so let's begin with amazon redshift and
let's see what we have
for today's session so what's in it for
you today we'll
see what is aws uh why we require amazon
redshift
what do we mean by amazon redshift the
advantages of
amazon redshift the architecture of
amazon redshift
some of the additional concepts
associated with the redshift and the
companies that are using the
amazon redshift and finally we'll cover
up one demo
which will show you the practical
example that how you can actually use
the redshift service
now what is aws as we know that aws
stands for amazon web service
it's one of the largest cloud providers
in the market and it's basically a
secure cloud service platform provided
from the amazon
also on the aws you can create and
deploy
the applications using the aws service
along with that you can access the
services
provided by the aws over the public
network
that is over the internet they are
accessible plus
you pay only whatever the service you
use for
now let's understand why we require
amazon redshift
so earlier before amazon readchef what
used to happen
that the people used to or the
developers used to fetch the data
from the data warehouse so data
warehouse is basically a terminology
which is basically represents the
collection of the data so
a repository where the data is stored is
generally called as a data warehouse now
fetching data from the data warehouse
was a complicated task because
might be a possibility that the
developer is located at a different
geography
and the data data warehouse is at a
different location and probably there is
not that much network connectivity or
some
networking challenges internet
connectivity challenges security
challenges might be
and a lot of maintenance was required uh
to manage uh the data warehouses
so what are the cons of the traditional
data warehouse services
it was time consuming to download or get
the data from the data warehouse
maintenance cost was high and there was
the possibility of loss of information
in between the
downloading of the data and the data
rigidity was
an issue now how these problems could
overcome and this was uh basically
solved
with the introduction of amazon redshift
over the cloud platform now
we say that amazon redshift has solved
traditional data warehouse
problems that the developers were facing
but how what is amazon
redshift actually is so what is amazon
redshift it is one of the services
over the aws amazon web services which
is called as a data warehouse service
so amazon redshift is a cloud-based
service or a data warehouse service that
is primarily used for collecting and
storing the large chunk of data
so it also helps you to get or extract
the data
analyze the data using some of the bi
tools
so business intelligence tools you can
use and get the data from the redshift
and process that
and hence it simplifies the process of
handling the large scale data sets
so this is the symbol for the amazon
redshift
over the aws now let's discuss about one
of the use case
so dna is basically a telecommunication
company and
they were facing an issue with managing
their website and also the amazon s3
data which led down to slow process
of their applications now how could they
overcome this problem let's say that
so they overcome this issue by using the
amazon redshift and all the company
noticed
that there was a 52 increase in the
application
performance now did you know that amazon
redshift is
basically cost less to operate than any
other cloud data warehouse service
available on the cloud computing
platforms and also
the performance of an amazon redshift is
the fastest data warehouse we can say
that that is available as of now so in
both cases
one is that it saves the cost as
compared to the traditional data
warehouses
and also the performance of this
redshift service or a data warehouse
service
the fastest available on the cloud
platforms and more than 15 000 customers
primarily presently they are using the
amazon redshift service
now let's understand some of the
advantages of amazon redshift
first of all as we saw that it is one of
the fastest available data warehouse
service so it has the high performance
second is it is a low cost service so
you can have
a large scale of data warehouse or the
databases combined in a data warehouse
at a
very low cost so whatever you use you
pay for that only scalability
now in case if you wanted to increase
the nodes of the databases in your
redshift
you can actually increase that based on
your requirement and
that is on the fly so you don't have to
wait for the procurement of any kind of
hardware or the infrastructure it is
whenever you require you can scale up or
scale down the
resources so this scalability is again
one of the advantage of the amazon
redshift
availability since it's available across
multiple availability zones so it makes
this service as a highly available
service
security so whenever you create whenever
you access redshift
you create a clusters in the redshift
and the clusters are created in the
you can define a specific virtual
private cloud for your cluster
and you can create your own security
groups and attach it to your cluster
so you can design the security
parameters based on your requirement
and you can get your data warehouse or
the data items in a secure place
flexibility and you can remove the
clusters you can create under clusters
if you are deleting a cluster you can
take a snapshot of it and you can move
those snapshots to different regions so
that much flexibility is available on
the aws for the service
and the other advantage is that it is
basically a very simple
way to do a database migration so if
you're planning that you wanted to
migrate
your databases from the traditional data
center over the cloud
on the redshift it is basically uh very
simple
to do a database migration you can have
some of the inbuilt tools available on
the aws
access you can connect them with your
traditional data center and get that
data migrated directly to the redshift
now let's understand the architecture of
the amazon redshift so
architecture of an amazon redshift is
basically it combines of a cluster and
that we call it as a data warehouse
cluster
in this picture you can see that this is
a data warehouse cluster
and this is a representation of amazon
redshift so
it has some of the compute nodes which
does the data processing
and a leader node which gives the
instructions to these compute nodes
and also the leader node basically
manages
the client applications that require the
data
from the redshift so let's understand
about
the components of the redshift the
client application
of amazon redshift basically interact
with the leader node
using jdbc or the odbc now what is jdbc
it's a java database connectivity and
the odbc
stands for open database connectivity
the amazon redshift service
using a jdbc connector can monitor the
connections from the
other client applications so the leader
node can actually have a check
on the client applications using the
jdbc connections
whereas the odbc allows a leader node to
have
a direct interaction or to have a live
interaction
with the amazon redshift so odbc allows
a user
to interact with live data of amazon
redshift so it has a direct connectivity
direct
access of the applications as well as
the leader node can
get the information from the compute
nodes now what are these compute nodes
these are basically kind of a databases
which does the
processing so amazon redshift has a set
of computing resources which we call it
as a nodes
and the nodes when they are combined
together they are called it as a
clusters
now a cluster a set of computing
resources which are called as nodes
and this gathers into a group which we
call it as a data warehouse cluster so
you can have a compute node starting
from 1 to n number of
nodes and that's why we call that the
redshift is a scalable service because
we can
scale up the compute nodes whenever we
require now
the data warehouse cluster or the each
cluster
has one or more databases in the form of
a nodes
now what is a leader node this node
basically manages
the interaction between the client
application and the compute node so it
acts as a bridge between the client
application and the compute nodes
also it analyzes and develop designs in
order to carry out
any kind of a database operations so
leader node basically sends out
the instructions to the compute nodes
basically perform or
execute that instruction and give that
output to the leader node
so that is what we are going to see in
the next slide
that the leader node runs the program
and assign the code to individual
compute nodes
and the compute nodes execute the
program and share the result
back to the leader node for the final
aggregation and then it is delivered to
the client
application for analytics or whatever
the client application is created for so
compute nodes are basically categorized
into slices
and each node slice is alerted with
specific memory space
or you can say a storage space where the
data is processed
these node slices works in parallel in
order to finish their work and hence
when we talk about a redshift as a fast
faster
processing capability as compared to
other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these node slices work in a
parallel operation that makes it more
faster now
the additional concept associated with
amazon redshift is
there are two additional concepts
associated with the redshift one is
called as the column storage
and the other one is called as the
compression let's see what is the column
storage as the name suggests
column storage is basically kind of a
data storage in the form of a column so
that whenever
we run a query it becomes easier to pull
out the data from the columns
so column storage is an essential factor
in optimizing query performance and
resulting in
quicker output so one of the examples
are mentioned here
so below example show how database
tables store record into
disk block by row so here you can see
that if we wanted to pull out
some kind of an information based on the
city address age we can basically create
a filter
and from there we can put out the
details that we require
and that is going to fetch out the
details based on the column storage
so that makes data more structured more
streamlined and it becomes very easier
to run a query and get that output now
the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the
query performance and this is one of the
syntax for the column compression
now the companies that are using amazon
redshirt one is
lya the other one is equinox the third
one is the pfizer which is one of the
famous
pharmaceuticals company mcdonald's one
of the burger chains across the globe
and
philips it's an electronic company so
these are one of the biggest companies
that are basically
relying and they are putting their data
on the red shift data warehouse service
now in another video we'll see the demo
for using the amazon redshift
let's look into the amazon redshift demo
so these are the steps that we need to
follow for
creating the amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we will be doing is
that we'll be creating an im role for
the redshift so that the redshift can
call the services and specifically we'll
be using the s3 service
so the role that we'll be creating will
be giving the permission
to redshift to have an access of an s3
in the read-only format
so in the step one what we require we'll
check the prerequisites and
what you need to have is the aws
credentials uh if you don't have that
you
need to create your own credentials and
you can use
your credit and the debit card and then
in the step two we'll proceed with the
im role for the amazon redshift once the
role is created
we will launch a sample amazon redshift
cluster mentioned in the step 3 and then
we will assign a vpc security groups to
our cluster now you can create it in the
default vpc also you can create a
default security groups also otherwise
you can
customize the security groups based on
your requirement now to
connect to the sample cluster you need
to run the queries
and you can connect to your cluster and
run queries on the aws management
console
query editor which you will find it in
the redshift only or if you use the
query editor you don't have to download
and set up a sql client application
separately and
in the step six what you can do is you
can copy the data from the
s3 and upload that in the redshift
because the redshift would have an
access
a read-only access for the s3 as that
will be created in the
im role so let's see how we can actually
use the redshift
on the aws so i am already logged into
my account i am in north virginia region
i'll search for red shift service
and here i find amazon redshift so just
click on it
let's wait for the redshift to come now
this is a redshift dashboard
and from here itself you have to run the
cluster so to launch a cluster you just
have to click on this launch cluster
and once the cluster is created and if
you wanted to run queries
you can open query editor or you can
basically create
queries and access the data from the red
shift so that's what it was mentioned in
the steps also that you don't require a
separate
sql client application to get the
queries run on the data warehouse
now before creating a cluster we need to
create the role so what we'll do is
we'll click on the services
and we'll move to im role section so i
am role i can find here under the
security identity and compliance so just
click on the identity access management
and then click on create roles so let's
wait for i am page to open
so here in the im dashboard you just
have to click on the rules
i already have the role created so what
i'll do is i'll delete this role and
i'll create it
separately so just click on create role
and under the aws services you have to
select for the redshift because now the
redshift will be calling the other
services
and that's why we are creating the role
now which other services
that the redshift will be having an
access of s3 why
because we'll be putting up the data on
the s3 and that is something which needs
to be uploaded on the redshift
so we'll just search for the redshift
service and
we can find it here so just click on it
and then
click on red shift customizable in the
use case
now click on next permissions and here
in the permissions
give the access to this role assign the
permissions to this role in the form of
an s3
read-only access so you can search here
for the s3 also
let's wait for the policies to come in
here it is let's type s3 and here we can
find amazon s3 read-only access so just
click on it and
assign the permissions to this role tags
you can leave them blank
click on next review put a name to your
role
let's put my redshift role and click on
a create role
now you can see that your role has been
created now the next step is that we'll
move to redchat service and we'll create
one cluster so click on the services
click on amazon redshift you can find
that in the history section
since we browsed it uh just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of
gb how much db memory you want you can
define it here itself this also gives
you the information about
the costing on demand is basically pay
as you use
so they are going to charge you 0.5
dollars per r
for using the two node slices so let's
click on launch this cluster
and this will be a dc2 dot large kind of
an instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of a
solid state drive ssds which is one of
the fastest way of
storing the information and the nodes
two
are mentioned by default that means
there will be two node slices and that
will be
created in a cluster you can increase
them also let's say if i put three node
slices
so it is going to give us 3 into 0.16 db
per node storage now here you have to
define the master username password
for your redshift cluster and you have
to follow
the password instructions so i would put
a password
to this cluster and if it accepts that
means it does not give you any kind of a
warning otherwise it is going to
tell you about you have to use the ascii
characters and all and here you have to
assign
this cluster the role that we created
recently so
in the available im rules you just have
to click on my redshift
role and then you have to launch the
cluster if you wanted to change
something in with respect to the default
settings let's say if you wanted to
change the vpc from default vpc to your
custom vpc and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own security groups so you can
switch to advanced settings and
do that modification now let's launch
the cluster and here you can see the
redshift cluster is being created
now if you wanted to run queries on this
redshift cluster so you don't require a
separate sql client you just have to
follow
the simple steps to run a query editor
and the query editor you will find it
on the dashboard so let's click on the
cluster and
here you would see that the red shift
cluster would be created with the three
nodes
in the us east 1b availability zone so
we have created the redshift cluster
in the ohio region and now what we'll do
is we'll
see how we can create the tables inside
the redshift
and we'll see how we can use the copy
command so that
we can directly move the data uploaded
on the s3 bucket
to the redshift database tables and then
we'll query the results
of a table as well so how we can do that
first of all
after creating the redshift cluster we
have to
install sql workbench slash j
this is not a mysql which is managed by
oracle and you can find this
on the google you can download it from
there and
then you have to connect this client
with the redshift database
how you can do click on file click on
connect window
and after connecting a window you have
to paste the url
which is a jdbc driver this driver link
you can find it
onto the aws console so if you open up
a redshift cluster there you would find
the jdbc
driver link let's wait for it so this is
our cluster
created let's open it and here you can
find this jdbc url
and also make sure that in the security
groups
of a redshift you have the port 5439
open for the traffic incoming traffic
you also need to have the
amazon redshift driver and this is the
link
where you can download the driver and
specify the path
once you are done with that you provide
the username and the password that you
created while creating the redshift
cluster
click on ok so this connects with the
database and now
the database connection is almost
completed
now what we will be doing in the sql
workbench we will be
first creating the sales table and then
in the sales table
we'll be adding up the entries copied
from
the s3 bucket and then move it to the
redshift
database and after that we'll query the
results in the sales table
now whatever the values you are creating
in the table the same values needs to be
in the
data file and i have taken up this
sample data file from this link
which is docs.aws.amazon.com redshift
sample database creation and here you
can find
a download file ticketbb.zip file this
folder has
basically multiple data files sample
data files which you can actually
use it to practice uploading the data on
the redshift
cluster so i have extracted one of the
files from this folder and then i have
uploaded that file in the s3 bucket
now we'll move into the s3 bucket let's
look for the file that has been uploaded
on the s3 bucket
so this is the bucket sample and sales
underscore tab
dot text is the file that i have
uploaded
this has the entries data entries that
will be uploaded using a copy command
onto the redshift cluster
now after executing after putting up
the command for creating up the table
then
we'll use a copy command and copy
command
we have to define the table name the
table name is sales
and we have to define the path from
where the data would be copied
over to the sales table in the red shift
now path is the s3 bucket
and this is the redshift bucket sample
and
it has to look for the data inside the
sales underscore tab.text file
also we have to define the role arn
that was created previously and once it
is done
then the third step is to query the
results inside the sales table
to check whether our data has been
uploaded correctly on the table or not
now what we'll do is we'll execute all
these three syntax
it gives us the error because we have to
connect it again
to the database let's wait for it
execute it
it's again gives us the error let's look
into the name of
the bucket it's redshiftbucketsample so
we have
two t's mentioned here right let's
connect
with the database again and now execute
it so table sales created
and we got the error the specified
bucket does not
exist uh redshift bucket sample
let's view the bucket name redshift
bucket sample let's copy that
put it here connect to the window
connect back to the database
right and now execute it so table sales
created
uh the data in the table has been copied
from the s3 bucket uh to sales
underscore tab.text to the redshift and
then the query of the results
now the results from the table has been
queried hi guys i'm raul from simply
learn and today i'd like to welcome you
all to the greatest debate of the
century
today i'm joined by two giants of the
cloud computing industry
they'll be going head to head with each
other to decide who amongst them is
better
it's going to be one hello fight now
let's meet our candidates
on my left we have aws who's voiced by a
picture
hi guys and on my right we have
microsoft azure who's voiced by anjali
hey there so today we'll be deciding
who's better on the basis of
their origin and the features they
provide their performance on the present
day
and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market sharing options
free tier and instance configuration now
let's listen to their opening statements
let's start with aws launched in 2006
aws is one of the most commonly used
cloud computing platforms across the
world
companies like adobe netflix airbnb
htc pinterest and spotify have put their
faith in aws
for their proper functioning it also
dominates the cloud computing domain
with almost
40 percent of the entire market share so
far
nobody has even gotten close to beating
that number aws
also provides a wide range of services
that covers a great number of domains
domains like compute networking storage
migration and so much more now let's see
what azure has to say about that
azure was launched in 2010 and is
trusted by almost
80 of all fortune 500 companies
the best of the best companies in the
world choose to work only with azure
azure also provides its services to more
regions than any other cloud service
provider in the world
azure covers 42 regions already and 12
more are being planned to be made
azure also provides more than 100
services spanning a variety of domains
now that the opening statements are done
let's have a look at the current market
status of each of our competitors
this is the performance route here we
have the stats for the market share of
aws
azure and other cloud service providers
this is for the early 2018 period
amazon web services takes up a whopping
of the market share closely followed by
hdr at 30
and other cloud services adding 30 this
indicates most organizations clear
interest in using aws
we are number one because of our years
of experience
and trust we've created among our users
sure you're the market leader
but we are not very far behind let me
remind you more than 80 percent of the
fortune 500 companies
trust azure with their cloud computing
needs so it's only a match of time
before azure takes the lead the rest of
the 30 percent that is in aws or azure
accounts to the other cloud service
providers like google cloud platform
backspace ibm softlayer and so on now
for our next round
the comparison round first we'll be
comparing pricing
we'll be looking at the cost of a very
basic instance which is a virtual
machine
of two virtual cpus and 8gbs of ram for
aws
this will cost you approximately 0.0928
us dollars
per hour and for the same instance in
azure it'll cost you approximately 0.096
us dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options
as i mentioned before aws is the
undisputed market leader
when it comes to the cloud computing
domain taking up 40 percent of the
market share
by 2020 aws is also expected to produce
twice its current revenue
which comes close to 44 billion dollars
not to mention aws is constantly
expanding its already strong roaster of
more than 100 services to fulfill the
shifting business requirements of
organizations
all that is great really good for you
but the research company gardner has
released a magic quadrant that you have
to see
you see the competition is now nectar
between
azure and aws it's only a matter of time
before azure can increase from its 30
market share and surpass aws this
becomes more likely considering how
all companies are migrating from aws to
azure to help satisfy their business
needs
azure is not far behind aws when this
comes to services as well
azure service offerings are constantly
updated and improved on to help users
satisfy their cloud computing
requirements now let's compare aws
and azure's free offerings aws provides
a
significant number of services for free
helping users get hands-on experience
with the platform
products and services the free tier
services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only
for one year the always free category
offers
more than 20 services for example amazon
sns
sqs cloudwatch etc and the valid fourier
category
offers approximately 20 services for
example
amazon s3 ec2 elastic cache etc
both types of services have limits on
the usage for example storage
number of requests compute time etc but
users are only charged for using
services
that fall under the valid for a year
category after a year of their usage
a show provides a free tier as well it
also provides services that belong to
the categories of free for a year and
always free there are about 25 plus
always free services provided by azure
these include app service functions
container service
active directory and lots more and as of
the valid for a year there are eight
services offered
there's linux or windows virtual
machines blob storage
sql database and few more azure also
provides the users with credits
of 200 us dollars to access all their
services for 30 days
now this is a unique feature that azure
provides where
users can use their credits to utilize
any service of a choice for the entire
month
now let's compare instance configuration
the largest instance that aws offers
is that of a whopping 256gb of ram
and 16 virtual cpus the largest that
azure offers
isn't very far behind either 224 gbs of
ram
and 16 virtual cpus and now for the
final round
now each of our contestants will be
shown facts and they have to give
explanations
for these facts we call it the rapid
fire round
first we have features in which aws is
good and azure is better
aws does not cut down on the features it
offers its users
however it requires slightly more
management on the user's part
azure goes slightly deeper with the
services that fall
under certain categories like platform
as a service
and infrastructure as a service next we
have hybrid cloud where aws is good
and azure is better okay although aws
did not emphasize on hybrid cloud
earlier they
are focusing more on technology now
azure has
always emphasized on hybrid cloud and
has features supporting it since the
days of its inception for developers aws
is better and azure is good
of course it's better because aws
supports integration with third-party
applications
well azure provides access to data
centers that provide a scalable
architecture
for pricing both aws and azure are at
the same level
it's good for aws because it provides a
competitive and constantly decreasing
pricing model
and in the case of azure it provides
offers that are constantly experimented
upon
to provide its users with the best
experience
and that's it our contestants have
finished giving their statements
now let's see who won surprisingly
nobody
each cloud computing platform has its
own pros and cons
choosing the right one is based entirely
on your organization's requirements
hi guys today we've got something very
special in store for you
we're going to talk about the best cloud
computing platform available
amazon web services uh rahul i think you
said something wrong here
the best cloud computing platform is
obviously google cloud platform
no it isn't aws has more than 100
services that span a variety of domains
all right but google cloud platform has
cheaper instances what do you have to
say about that
well i guess there's only one place we
can actually discuss this a boxing ring
so guys i'm opexia and i will be google
cloud platform and i'm rahul i'll be aws
so
welcome to fight night this is aws
versus gcp
the winner will be chosen on the basis
of their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day
and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market sharing options
the things they give you for free and
instance configuration
now first let's talk about aws aws was
launched in 2004 and is a cloud service
platform that helps businesses grow and
scale by providing them services in a
number of different domains these
domains include compute
database storage migration networking
and so on a very important aspect about
aws is its years of experience now
aws has been in the market a lot longer
than any other cloud service platform
which means they know how businesses
work and how they can contribute to the
business
growing also aws has over 5.1 billion
dollars of revenue in the last quarter
this is a clear indication of how much
faith and trust
people have in aws they occupy more than
40 percent of the market which is a
significant chunk
of the cloud computing market they have
at least 100 services that are available
at the moment which means just about
every issue that you have
can be solved with an aws service now
that was great
but now can we talk about gcp i hope you
know that gcp was launched very recently
in 2011 and it is already helping
businesses
significantly with the suite of
intelligent secure and flexible cloud
computing services
it lets you build deploy and scale
applications websites services
on the same infrastructure as google the
intuitive user experience that gcp
provides with dashboards wizards is
way better in all the aspects tcp has
just stepped in the market
and it is already offering a modest
number of services and the number is
rapidly increasing
and the cost for a cpu instance or
regional storage that gcp provides is a
whole lot cheaper and you also get a
multi-regional cloud storage
now what do you have to say on that i'm
so glad you asked let's look at present
day in fact let's look at the cloud
market share of the fourth quarter of
2017.
this will tell you once and for all that
aws is the leader when it comes to cloud
computing
amazon web services contributes 47 of
the market share
others like rackspace or verizon cloud
contribute 36 percent microsoft azure
contributes 10
the google cloud platform contributes 4
and ibm software contributes 3
47 of the market share is contributed by
aws
you need me to convince you any wait
wait wait
all that is fine but we only started a
few years back and have already grown so
much in such a less span of time
haven't you heard the latest news our
revenue is already a billion dollars per
quarter
wait for a few more years and the world
shall see and aws makes 5.3 billion
dollars
per quarter it's going to take a good
long time before you can even get close
to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things
for starters let's compare pricing for
aws a compute instance of two cpus in
8gb ram
costs approximately 68 us dollars now a
computer instance is a virtual machine
in which you can specify what operating
system ram or storage you want to have
for cloud storage
it costs 2.3 cents per gb per month with
aws
you really want to do that because gcp
wins this
hands down let's take the same compute
instance of
two cpus with 8gb ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp
and as per my calculations that's a 25
annual cost reduction when compared to
aws talking about cloud storage costs it
is only 2 cents per gb
per month with gcp what else do you want
me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now aws is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 percent of the entire market
share
aws also has at least 100 services
available at the moment which is a clear
indication
of how well aws understands businesses
and helps them grow
yeah that's true but you should also
know that gcp is steadily growing
we have over 60 services that are up and
running as you can see here and a lot
more to come it's only a matter of time
when we will have as many services as
you do many companies have
already started adopting gcp as a cloud
service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws
you get access to almost all the
services for an entire year with usage
limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis
for example with amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month
you also have limits on the number of
requests to services for example with
aws lambda
you have 1 million requests per month
now after these limits across
you get charged standard rates with gcp
you get access to all cloud platform
products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products
and interestingly after the free trial
ends you won't be charged unless you
manually upgrade to a paid account now
there is also the always free version
for which you will need an upgraded
billing account here you get to use a
small instance for free and 5gb of cloud
storage
any usage above this always free usage
limits will be automatically billed at
standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws the largest
instance that's offered the 128 cpus and
4 tvs of ram
now other than the on-demand method like
i mentioned before
you can also use spot instances now
these are the situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption now
you pay for the spot price which is
effective at a particular r
now these spot prices do fluctuate but
are adjusted over a period of time
the largest instance offered with google
cloud is
160 cpus and 3.75 tbs ram
like spot instances of aws google cloud
offers short-lived compute instances
suitable for bad jobs and
fault tolerant workloads they are called
as preemptable instances
so these instances are available at 80
percent off on on demand
price hence they reduce your compute
engine costs
significantly and unlike aws these come
at a fixed price google cloud platform
is a lot more flexible when it comes to
instance configuration you simply choose
your cpu and ram
combination of course you can even
create your own instance types this way
before we wrap it up let's compare on
some other things as well
telemetry it's a process of
automatically collecting periodic
measurements from remote devices
for example gps gcp is obviously better
because they have superior telemetry
tools which help in
analyzing services and providing more
opportunities for improvement
when it comes to application support aws
is obviously better
since they have years of experience
under their bed aws provides the best
support that can be given to the
customers
containers are better with gcp a
container is a virtual process running
in user space
as kubernetes was originally developed
by google
gcp has full native support for the
tools other cloud services are just
fine tuning a way to provide humanities
as a service
also the containers help with
abstracting applications from their
environment they originally run it
the applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment
when it comes to geographies aws is
better since they have a head start of a
few years aws in this span of time has
been able to cover a larger market share
and geographical locations
now it's time for the big decision so
who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or aws
i think i'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform
is the decision that's made on the basis
of the user or the organization's
requirement
on that note i believe it's time for us
to wrap this video up aws azure and gcp
are three of the world's largest cloud
service providers but how are they
different from each other
let's find out hey guys i'm rahul and
i'll be representing amazon web services
i'm chinmay and i'll be representing
microsoft azure
and i am shruti and i'll be representing
google cloud platform
so welcome to this video on aws versus
azure vs gcp
talking about market share amazon web
services leads with around 32
of the worldwide public cloud share
azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around nine percent of the world's
market share
let's talk about each of these service
providers in detail aws provides
services
that enable users to create and deploy
applications over the cloud
these services are accessible via the
internet aws being the oldest of the lot
was launched in the year 2006.
azure launched in 2010 is a computing
platform that offers a wide range of
services
to build manage and deploy applications
on the network
using tools and frameworks launched in
the year 2008
gcp offers application development and
integration services for its end users
in addition to cloud management it also
offers services for big data machine
learning and iot
now let's talk about availability zones
these are isolated locations within data
center regions from which public cloud
services originate and operate
talking about aws they have 69
availability zones within 22
geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states
south america europe and asia pacific
they are also predicted to have 12 more
editions in the future
azure available in 140 countries has
over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers
gcp is available in 200 plus countries
across the world
as of today gcp is present in 61 zones
and 20 regions with osaka and zurich
being the newly added regions
now let's talk about pricing these
services follow the pay-as-you-go
approach
you pay only for the individual services
you need for as long as you use them
without requiring long-term contracts or
complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances
like general purpose compute optimized
memory optimized
and gpu now let's talk about the compute
services offered
first off we have virtual servers for
aws we have ec2
it is a web service which eliminates the
need to invest in hardware
so that you can develop and deploy
applications in a faster manner
it provides virtual machines in which
you can run your applications
azure's virtual machines is one of the
several types of computing resources
that azure
offers azure gives the user the
flexibility to deploy
and manage a virtual environment inside
a virtual network gcp's vm service
enables users to build
deploy and manage virtual machines to
run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aw cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines
azure virtual machine service is a part
of the free tier that offers this
service for about 750 hours per month
for a year
the user gets access to windows and
linux virtual machines
gcp's vm service is a part of a free
tier that includes
micro instance per month for up to 12
months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or pass services
for aws elastic bean stock is an easy to
use service
for deploying and scaling web
applications and services developed with
java.net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity
provisioning load balancing auto scaling
and application health monitoring
the pass backbone utilizes
virtualization techniques where the
virtual machine is independent of the
actual hardware that hosts it hence
the user can write application code
without worrying about the underlying
hardware
google app engine is a cloud computing
platform as a service which is used by
developers for hosting and building
apps in google data centers the app
engine requires the apps to be written
in java or python
and store data in google bigtable and
use the google query language for this
next let's talk about virtual private
server services aws provides light sale
it provides everything
you need to build an application or a
website along with the cost-effective
monthly plan
and minimum number of configurations in
simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines
it helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service
next up we have serverless computing
services aws has lambda
it is a serverless compute service that
lets you run your code without
facilitating
and managing servers you only pay for
the compute time you use
it is used to execute backend code and
scales automatically when required
azure functions is a serverless compute
service that lets you run even triggered
code without having to explicitly
provision or manage infrastructure
this allows the users to build
applications using serverless simple
functions with the programming language
of their choice
gcp cloud functions make it easy for
developers to run
and scale code in the cloud and build
image driven
serverless applications it is highly
available and fault tolerant
now let's talk about storage services
offered by each of these service
providers
first off we have object storage aws
provides s3
it is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability
data availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet
blob storage is an azure feature that
lets developers store unstructured data
in microsoft's cloud platform
along with storage it also offers
scalability it stores the data in the
form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed
google cloud storage is an online
storage web service for storing and
accessing data
on google cloud platform infrastructure
unlike the google drive
google cloud storage is more suitable
for enterprises
it also stores objects that are
organized into buckets
amazon provides ebs or elastic block
store it provides high performance block
storage and is used along with ec2
instances
for workloads that are transaction or
throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized
these managed disks allow the users to
create up to 10 000 vm disks
in a single subscription persistent
storage is a data storage device that
retains data after
power to the device is shut off google
persistent disk is durable
and high performance block storage for
gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine
or kubernetes engine next up we have
disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure
and data are recovered while minimizing
the amount of downtime that could be
experienced
site recovery helps ensure business
continuity by keeping business apps and
workloads running during outages
it allows recovery by orchestrating and
automating the replication process
of azure virtual machines between
regions unfortunately gcp has no
disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service
it is a web service that's cost
effective and automates administration
tasks
basically it simplifies the setup
operation and scaling of a relational
database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform
that includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance
reliability and data protection it also
eases the migration of sql server
databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up
maintain and administer relational
postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp
cloud sql provides a database
infrastructure for applications running
anywhere next we have nosql database
services
aws provides dynamodb which is a managed
durable database that provides security
backup and restore and in-memory caching
for applications
it is well known for its low latency and
scalable performance
azure cosmos db is microsoft's globally
distributed multi-model database service
it natively supports nosql it natively
supports nosql
created for low latency and scalable
applications
gcp cloud data store is a nosql database
service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target
now let's talk about the key cloud tools
for each of these service providers
for aws in networking and content
delivery we have aws route 53 and aws
cloud front for management we have aws
cloud watch and aws cloud formation
for development we have aws code start
and aws code build for security we have
iam
and key management service for microsoft
azure networking and content delivery we
have content delivery network and
express route for management tools we
have azure advisor and network watcher
for development tools
for management we have azure advisor and
network watcher
for development we have visual studio
ide and azure blob studio
for security we have azure security
center and azure active directory for
gcp we have the following tools for
networking and content delivery we have
cloud cdn and cloud dns for management
we have stack driver and gcp monitoring
for development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk
and finally for security we have google
cloud im and google
and cloud security scanner now let's
talk about the companies using these
cloud providers for aws we have netflix
unilever
kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe pixar
samsung ebay fujitsu emc and bmw among
others use microsoft azure
so as seen on your screens the companies
that use gcp are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and 20th century fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone
and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly
and securely host your applications
whether an existing application
or a new sas based application speed and
agility aws provides you access to its
services within minutes
all you need to select is what you
require and you can proceed you can
access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable
amazon enables you to innovate and scale
your application in a secure environment
it secures and hardens your
infrastructure more importantly it
provides security at a cheaper cost than
on-premise environments
now talking about some of the advantages
of azure microsoft
azure offers better development
operations it also provides strong
security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect
assess diagnose stabilize and close
azure also provides a cost-effective
solution the cloud environment allows
businesses to launch both customer
applications and internal apps in the
cloud
which saves an it infrastructure costs
hence it's opex friendly
let's now look at the advantages of gcp
google builds in minute level
increments so you only pay for the
compute time you use
they also provide discounted prices for
long running workloads
for example you use the vm for a month
and get a discount
gcp also provides live migration of
virtual machines
live migration is the process of moving
a running vm from one physical server to
another without disrupting its
availability to the users
this is a very important differentiator
for google cloud compared to other cloud
providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a size container scale to as many
cpus as needed
google cloud storage is designed for
99.9 percent durability
it creates server backup and stores them
in an user configured location
let's talk about the disadvantages of
each of these services for aws there's a
limitation of the ec2 service
aws provides limitations on resources
that vary from region to region
there may be a limit to the number of
instances that can be created however
you can request for these limits to be
increased secondly they have a technical
support fee
aws charges you for immediate support
and you can opt for any of these
packages
developer which costs twenty nine
dollars per month business which costs
more than hundred dollars
an enterprise that costs more than
fifteen thousand dollars it has certain
network connectivity issues
it also has general issues when you move
to the cloud like downtime limited
control
backup protection and so on however most
of these are temporary issues
and can be handled over time talking
about some of the disadvantages of
microsoft azure
code base is different when working
offline and it requires modification
when working on the cloud
pass echo system is not as efficient as
iaas
azure management console is frustrating
to work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple
tasks azure backup is intended for
backing up and restoring data located on
your on-premises servers to the cloud
that's a great feature but it's not
really useful for doing bare metal
restores of servers in a remote data
center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp
so when it comes to cloud providers the
support fee is very minimal but in the
case of gcp it is quite costly it is
around 150 dollars per month for the
most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema
also it is not very budget friendly when
it comes to downloading data from google
cloud storage
hey guys this is chidanan from simply
learn and i welcome you to this short
tutorial and demo
on kubernetes kubernetes specific to aws
cloud platform so what's
a part of this tutorial and demo what's
in store for you at
offset i would like to cover the basics
of orchestration tools
as most of you would know kubernetes is
one of the most popular orchestration
tools in recent times
specifically for applications which are
cloud native
and deployed on some or the other types
of containers
but what are these organization tools
why would one need to use orchestration
tools
what are the facilities or features
provided by this orchestration tools
that's the first thing that i'm going to
cover
after that i will pick two orchestration
tools
specific to container management docker
swarm
versus kubernetes i'm going to compare
them with regard to the features that
they provide the use cases that they
cover
what facilities that they provide and
when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kubernetes architecture
what exactly is required for setting up
a kubernetes cluster
what runs in a control plane or a master
node
what runs as a part of the worker node
after that
i will end the tutorial by running you
through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform
i will use something called as cops
which is one of the admin
tools for setting up production grade
kubernetes cluster so i will use this
to set up a three note cluster on aws
all right now that we set the context
right let me get
started so what are orchestration tools
the application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code
to your continuous integration to
testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production
managing your production servers the
dependencies that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware
the features of fault tolerance
self-healing capabilities
auto scaling all this has complicated
over the last few years
as a part of devops one thing that
everyone is interested
in is managing all this application
dependency
or life cycle management using some or
the other kind of a tool so that's where
these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide
is you'll have to just let them know
what are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are
the fault tolerance mechanisms that it
has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required
if at all you can bake in all these
specific parameters into your tool
your orchestration tool becomes a
one-stop shop for
all your deployment and configuration
management needs
that's where this orchestration tools
have become a very very popular and
relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more
interested in adopting devops practices
all right so having said that about
orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
specifically for container management
docker
swarm and kubernetes many of the
applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are
called or kind of fall into a category
of cloud native
where the application need not know much
about the underlying
infrastructure or the platform where
these applications are running
so these two along with apache missions
there are many other container
management systems
but i'm going to pick docker swarm and
kubernetes
for comparing the features that is
provided by
these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm
and kubuntes just because of the reason
that both of them
operate in the space of container
management they
do something very very similar to
containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools
however there's a big difference that
exists when it comes to
the types of containers that both of
them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be
used for docker swamp is a cluster
management solution
that is provided by docker container
docker
is one of the very very popular
containers of recent times
and in case you have your applications
that is totally powered by
only docker containers if you have a
need where you want to run a cluster
of servers which are running only docker
containers docker swarm should be
your choice for your orchestration tool
kubernetes on the other hand
can cater to any other types of
containers other than
docker and including docker as well so
in case you have your applications which
have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container
kubernetes should be your choice of
orchestration too
a docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in docker
containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 60 nodes
docker swarm should be your choice of
orchestration tool
on the other hand kubernetes is
something that was open sourced by
google and the kind of the scale of
operations that kubernetes can cater to
is google scale so if in case your
applications are more than a thousand
nodes
that is where kubernetes comes into play
that's the big difference that exists
between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside
let me compare docker swarm and
kubernetes
based upon other features which are
similar in nature the first and
important feature that kubernetes
provides
is something called as auto scaling if
at all the load on
your cluster is too high and your
application is experiencing
more load so kubernetes can add
new nodes to your cluster of course
you'll have to configure kubernetes in
order to
have those capabilities where it can
spin up new
vms or new nodes if at all you do that
configuration correctly
kubernetes has got the capacity or it
has got the feature
where it can bring up a new node and add
it to the cluster
on the fly based upon the load that
exists
at that moment on similar lines if at
all the load is not too high
it can identify a few of those nodes
which have got less number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also
scale down by deleting few nodes from
your cluster
so that is the powerfulness of auto
scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist
in docker swamp the other feature of
load balancing
specifically application node balancing
so docker swarm gives you
an application level auto load balancing
however
kubernetes gives you the flexibility of
manually configuring any
other type of load balancer of your
choice for
application load balancing installation
as i mentioned earlier docker swarm is a
loose
cluster of containers which are running
on
nodes it is very easy to spin up a new
node
and then connect them to a swarm and
this can be done in a very very
loosely coupled way where you can create
swarms of your choice
nodes are allowed to connect to swarms
and quit or leave the swamps on the fly
so
in and all the installation is pretty
easy and fast
kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node
how many masternodes how many config
planes that you want how many nodes that
you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes
strength is very very strong they are
very tightly coupled
and even they have the capability where
on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon
the requirement on a darkest form the
cluster strength is weak
as compared to copper days worker notes
can be added to a swarm
worker notes can be asked to leave us
form or can be taken out of a swarm
based upon the requirement so this is
kind of a loosely coupled architecture
for docker swarm
while coverage is the cluster is very
tightly coupled
since docker swarm runs only docker
containers containers
find it very easy to share data a lot of
other things with each other because
they all have the same signature
they are all from the same family so
it's very easy for them to share
not just volumes but a lot of other
things however for kubernetes
since it manages containers of different
types
if your application has to share some
data across different containers there's
a little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your
containers to share data also when it
comes to kubernetes kubernetes groups
containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container
that's the preferred choice or multiple
containers and the idea of pod is like
each part can run in any other node it's
not guaranteed that you would want to
have two or three parts to be running
on the same note that makes data sharing
a little bit of a
different thing compared to docker's
form uh gui
so there's not a good enough ui tool
in docker's form at least the ce edition
of it
which will allow you to get to know what
is running on your containers
what is the size of the containers what
is the volume of the containers and all
that stuff
there are some free and open source
tools like proteiner
which gives you a good visibility into
your running docker containers
however there's nothing at a swarm level
that is provided by
docker kubernetes gives you an out of
the box dashboard which is easy to
configure and set up
you can also club it with some metrics
services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this
across your cluster in a very beautiful
dashboard perspective
so that way um this is little bit of a
good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided
out of the box let me spend some time in
explaining a little bit about the
kubernetes architecture
what comprises of the kubernetes cluster
what resides
in a master or a control plane and what
resides in a
worker node this is a very high level uh
depiction
of a kubernetes cluster so this is the
master node which has got
something called as a cluster store a
controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes
that are connected or administered by
the master node the master node can be
one three five typically an odd number
this is as per the typical cluster
management thing
where you would need the masternodes to
be in odd numbers so that whenever
there's any contention
in terms of what needs to be deployed
where or where to give the job to whom
and stuff like that all the masters
would cast their vote
and they would decide on the outcome so
that's the master node
and there are a bunch of nodes which can
be connected
and administered by the master node cuba
ctl
or the command from using which anybody
can
assign some workloads to the cluster can
also be
run either on the same node or on a
separate node so cubectl
is the command line tool that we will be
installing and using
in order to fire up our commands to our
cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to
give out any specific commands to my
cluster
all this is done using cuba ctl there's
a bunch of
rest apis which is used by cuba ctl and
cubectl will talk to the api server
and fire up the commands specific to my
cluster
what runs in the master node master node
without saying
it's the most important component of any
of the cluster if at all you're running
um cluster with only one master node if
your master
node goes down there's no other way that
you know you can or any user can
talk to the different nodes in the
cluster so master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster
there's always one node that should be
running
as a master node that's the bare minimum
requirement for your cluster
so what are the other components in the
master node the most important one
is called etcd so this is nothing but
a data store a value of key value pair
which is stored
which contains all information about
your cluster so all the configuration
details which
node is up which worker node is down all
this information is stored
in the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything
else that has to be done specific to
your cluster
what's in the controller as the name
says controller is something
it's like a daemon server that is
running in a continuous loop
all the time it is responsible for
controlling the set of replicas
the kind of workloads that is running
based upon the configuration that the
user has
set in so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers
endpoint controllers namespace
controllers all these controllers are
managed by
the controller component if any user
asks for some three replicas of a
particular pod or a service to be
running
and if at all any of the nodes goes down
or the part goes on for whatsoever
reason
the controller is the one who wakes up
and assigns this particular job or
the part to some other available node by
looking up for the details using in the
cluster store
that's the importance of the control
manager or the controller the scheduler
the scheduler assigns the tasks based
upon
whoever is asked for any job to be
scheduled based upon a time frame
or based upon some criteria it also
tracks
the working load as to what what exactly
is the load who is running what and in
the cluster
and places the workload on whoever is
the available
resource at that time all right api
server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster
where how would the end user deploy
or give out any sort of a workload onto
your cluster
all the requests come to the api server
so this
is an entry point for all your requests
that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to
bring down a few services anybody wants
to put in a service
all this will have to come in as a part
of
a rest um api endpoint and
api server is the entry point in case
you don't want
uh you know somebody to access your
cluster in case you want only specific
people
or specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set
all those role-based access control for
this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick
overview about the master node what what
are the important components of a master
node now let's go over to what
runs in a worker or a slave node as i
mentioned earlier
slave nodes are something where the job
that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run
as a pod as a service as a container so
in kubernetes world
there is something called as a pod a pod
is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a
wrapper around your running containers
so
slave nodes or the worker nodes
typically run
these parts so that is where the whole
workload typically gets run but there
are a bunch of other components in the
in the node which also manages what runs
in the pod who has to have access to the
pod
what is the state of the pod is it in a
running state is it going down for some
reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over
those components that is there in the
slave node the most important component
in my opinion
that should be on the on the node should
be the container runtime as i mentioned
earlier
kubernetes can run any different types
of containers not just docker so in case
you want to have a node
which wants to have docker running on it
rkt running or
lkc running on it or any other container
environment that is running on it you
have to ensure that the specific
container runtime environment is
available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted
description of what needs to be run as a
part of the pod what should be the image
with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned
to this particular node it would
definitely need a container runtime to
be
up and running so that exists only if at
all the container runtime is installed
and running
on your kubernetes worker node okay now
that we know
what our kubernetes node can run how
would somebody assign
a job to our node that is using
something called as a cubelet as the
name says
cubelet or cubelet is a small subset
which
talks to the cube api server so any node
which has to run any kind of a pod all
these instructions are passed around by
the qbps server
to the cube light and cubelet is capable
of processing whatever job that is
assigned to it
and ensuring that so many parts and so
many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists
in the worker node is the cube proxy or
kubernetes proxy
this plays a very very important role
acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running
in nodes the parts can be typically
running in
any node there is no um affinity towards
any node on which these parts are
running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere
so how would somebody reach out to these
applications
that is running in some pod which is
running in one container now and running
in probably another container
another node altogether tomorrow so that
is where your kubernetes proxy contains
a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any part
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts
and kind of connects the endpoints or
acts like a dns server
so that it knows when somebody is trying
to reach out to this
particular service which is the part on
which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a
network proxy now that at a very high
level we know what are all the
components that
make up of our kubernetes cluster let's
go ahead and create a small cluster and
spin up this cluster on
aws platform finally we get to the demo
section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes
you also know at a very very high level
what are the components of a cluster
what is a master node or a control plane
what are the components of a
master node and what should be existing
in a worker node you're probably
thinking that it's maybe pretty hard to
kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo
of how to set up a simple node
kubernetes
cluster using a tool called cops and i
will be doing this whole
setup on my aws cloud okay so what is
cops
cops is nothing but a simple tool this
is an admin tool
that allows you to bring up production
grade kubernetes environments as i said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is
little challenging so that is why i
would use something called as a cops
and i will use this on my cluster which
i'll spin up on my
aws instance so i have an aws account
and what i will do first is
i will first spin up an ec2 server i
will power this with one of the
um linux amis and i will install
cops on it now this will be my starting
point
from where i'm going to trigger running
up a big cluster
in our case i'll try to keep it little
small i don't want too many nodes in my
cluster
i'm going to have one master node and
two worker nodes this whole operation
would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so
as you may know aws is little hard for
me
to programmatically run other components
or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam role
which will
attach to my ec2 server so that my ec2
server gets powered
with all the required role so that it
can go ahead and spin up cluster
based upon my configuration that i am
going to specify all right
so once i have my cluster set up i will
also install cuba ctl
which uh you would probably know by now
is nothing but a command line utility
using which i can
kind of connect to my cluster give it
some jobs put some parts and stuff like
that so i will use cuba ctl i will also
have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get onto the master
node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
begin
by first logging into my aws account
all the steps that i will be following
to bring up my
aws cluster kubernetes cluster will be
documented and i'll be sharing you
this document in a github repository so
that in case anybody wants to try you'll
be more than happy to find
all the required instructions in one
place okay now
the first thing that i would need is to
launch an
aws ec2 instance now this is an instance
where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i am going to find some
commands
which will bring up my kubernetes
cluster so let me log into my aws
account
and let me stick to one particular
region
and let me bring up some a one ec2
instance
all right so let me launch my instance
let me choose
um doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire i would recommend choose free tire
only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
i don't want to change anything here
that looks good maybe i will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag
to my instance i will name this as my
cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
posts to be opened up so what i'll do is
i'll create a new security group called
open
to the world i would not recommend that
you do this
since i don't want to it will take a
long time for me to specifically
to pick and choose the ports that has to
be open
for running my cluster i don't want to
do that i will open up all the
http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp
i would say from anywhere just to be on
the safer side also open http
and https and i will make this
anywhere and anywhere this is good for
me
i will say review and launch all right
so i chose a t2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness i open up
all the ports
and um the instant details are you've
seen what is that i've chosen
all right now important part is like i
would need a keyboard i need to create a
new keypad
i will call this as simply learn
keys i will download this keypair and
then i will
launch the instance it will take some
time for my ec2 instance to come up
in the meanwhile what i'll do is i will
convert i have this pen file
which is the pair of keys the ssh keys
with which i need to login to my ec2
instance so i'll need to convert this
because i'm trying to connect from my
windows box i would need to convert this
into
a ppk file so i have puttygen i'm going
to load
my set of keys here and convert that key
into
a ppk key all right open all right i
would say
save hang on save private key yes
i would say simply learn or simply
learn private private key and save this
here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file
and this is my tpk or my private key now
using the private key
i will log into my ec2 instance okay now
my ec2 instance is up and running it is
running in this
ohio region and this is the ip address
of
my public eye partners of my machine so
let me connect to it
so i use a moba x term which is nothing
but an ssh emulator
you can use putty or any of these
sessions which allow you to do an ssh
this is my ip address of my machine
and since i've spun up an amazon ami
the user this is the default user i
would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session
say okay i am in my amazon
ec2 instance so let me look at what are
the
other things that i need to do all right
so as i said i just brought up my ec2
instance
but i would need my ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket
where i'm going to store the instant
state of my kubernetes cluster
also some sort of an auto scaling group
because i want to spin up more and more
instances i also want to have
a private hosted zone using my route 53
so i would need my ec2 instance to have
all these sort of permissions for my
server so what i would do is i will go
and create
a permission a rule in the ec2
rather in the aws im role and i will
attach this
i am role to my ec2 instance
all right so let me go to my iam which
is nothing but the
identity and access management i will
create
a role called as possibly corpse role i
will create a role this role
will be used by my ec2 so i'm going to
click on ec2
and say next permissions they would need
a lot of permissions
uh specific permissions to be very
honest and the permissions are all
listed out here s3
ec2 and all this stuff just to keep it
pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i will review i'll
create a row name
i will say cops fold for ec2 alright so
i'm going to create a rule
which has got administrative access
rules i'm going to create a rule
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance
from which i'm going to run my cluster
would have all the prerequisite
permissions so that it can go and spin
up instances
talk to us three buckets and all that
stuff all right now let us
have our running instance get powered by
this role so i will connect this role
to my running instance all right so this
is my um
easy to instant that is running i'll say
action attach
attach attach attach replace im rules
so there is no rule as of now i would
want my cops roll for easy this
row that i created so i want this new
room to be assigned to my ec2
all right great now my ec2 instance
which is my cop server has got
all the required permissions so that he
can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo yum
update iphone y so that any of the
because this is a newly provisioned
vm i just want to ensure that all my
library system libraries
are all updated so that when i do
install cop
and cube ctl and all those things none
of them will fail because of some
dependency or packet issues
so i'm just running a sudo update iphone
y
so that all the libraries are updated
okay
looks like it is done so let me go ahead
and
install cops cups is a pretty simple
installation
it is available in a particular location
i have to just copy this
and ensure that i do a curl and i
install this particular stuff
all right so it is fetching uh the cops
tool is installing for me
once it is copied down let me change the
mode
so that i can execute it and then also
let me move it to my user local bin
so that it is available for me in my
path okay that's pretty much
the corpse installation let me also do
one other thing let me
install something called as cuba ctl so
this is what would be
you know a tool using which i'm going to
be firing my uh commands to my
kubernetes cluster once it comes up
right this is a pretty smaller
executable so
ctl all right so i have cuba ctl as well
as
cops installed on my ec2 server now okay
now what i'll do next is i'm going to
create an s3 bucket
in aws so that the equivalent is a
cluster state is persisted in this
bucket so let me create a simple bucket
with this name s3 bucket with this name
so let me go to
s3 and let me create a simple bucket
with this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so
the simply learn.kubernetes is the
bucket that i
created so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster
let me now uh go and create a dns entry
or a dns zone
or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that
i'm coming up so i will create a private
hosted zone and possibility
possibly i will call this as simply
learn dot in so this will be my
name of my private hosted zone in case
you already have any other
public hosted zones in your name you can
always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me
head down to route 53 click on any of
these and you'll get these
hosted zones out here so i'm going to
create a hosted zone here i'm going to
create a hosted zone
click on create hosted zone um this
would be
simply learn lot in i want to create a
public no i don't want
public i want a private hosted zone and
i'm going to associate my vpc id
for this hosted zone since i'm going to
try out all my exercises in the
ohio region i will associate the vpc of
the ohio region for this
all right so this is the one that is
specific to the ohio region
so i will say this one i'll say create a
hosted zone great
now let me come back to my ec2 box my
ec2 is all
powered with uh whatever it needs in
order to uh go ahead with the
installation of my cluster only a few
things that i need to take care of
is that you know now that i put a name
for my cluster
i also have an s3 bucket that i've
configured for my cluster i will have to
ensure that i need to put in these two
configurations as a part of my cluster
building activity
so i will open my bash rc file and i'm
going to export these two variables if
at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is
nothing but the public oh sorry the
private hosted zone that i created
and the s3 bucket where i'm going to
create or rather i'm going to store my
cluster state so let me copy these two
and open up my
bashrc file all right so i will just add
these two and copy these
add export them out as my variable i'm
going to save this here
now let me ensure that this gets picked
up all right i've got these two that
have configured
and i also ensure that these environment
variables are set
now let me create a pair of ssh keys
this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh
hyphen keygen i don't want to give any
parameters let it go to the home
directory with
the default name and without any
passphrase
all right so i created a bunch of my
keypair now i'm all set to go ahead and
run my cops
now cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
cops command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster
the state of the cluster will be stored
in this particular variable which is
what
i have exported out the number of node
count is two
node count is the worker node count if
at all i don't specify configuration for
specifying
the master or the control pane as well
if i don't specify that the default one
is one so i'm going to create
one primary or the master node and two
uh worker nodes uh size of my master
node size of the worker nodes uh what
are the zones where i want
this to be created and where do i store
the cluster information
and uh okay i've already added this
master account this is actually not
required but this is
the command that i'm going to fire off
so that i bring up my cluster
all right that went off uh very fast but
um this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster
and that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with uh
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse
update cluster iphone iphone 8 yes now
this
will take some time a good five to ten
minutes for it to because this will
actually start provisioning the servers
and as i mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and two nodes or the
worker nodes
all right so this is the command for me
to validate the cluster and i'm going to
try it out first i'm pretty sure that it
will fail
because all my servers are not up yet
it is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me
try to look at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see
i had only one server that i had started
which was my cop server
and automatically the other three
instances one is called not start simply
not in
this these two are the nodes and this is
the master node
so these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran
all right so this may take a while for
it to get validated
a good 5 to 10 minutes so what i'll do
is i'll pause the video now
and i'll come back once on the server
the cluster is up and running
it's been a good eight to nine minutes
since i started my cluster
so let me validate now okay seems good
so there's a master node minimum one max
one
some nodes which are nothing but the
slave nodes or the worker nodes there
are two of them due to micro
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running
and my cluster name is simply learn.n so
what i would want to do is
now let me just log into the master and
see if i can run some
parts so let me get back to my
installation steps here the validation
cluster is done so let me log into my
since
my cluster name is simplyland. and this
is the way to log into my box
so let me get into my box so if you see
here uh this is the hostname
of the machine that i'm currently in if
you see this this is
nothing but our this cop server this is
the server
now from here i'm trying to get into the
master box all right so if you see the
ip address has changed i was in a
different box i'm in a different box now
if i see
host name you'll find a different host
name so this is 153
which is nothing but the master node yep
it's 153 this is the particular host so
i'm getting into this machine now
so i started the cluster from my cop
server here it ran and brought up three
nodes so i'm actually getting into my
master node and see if i can run some
parts on it all right so let me try
kubectl
uh get cluster info try cube ctl
get nodes all right so there are three
nodes here master node
and um one master node and two worker
nodes
so let me see if i have some pods here
cubic ctl get pods
so there's no port as of now so what
i'll try to do is let me just pin up a
very very simple part
just to check if my connections is
everything is correct or not correct
i have a simple node.js application that
i've built
uh i've got a container for that this is
already pushed to the docker i've
registered is called simply learn docker
hub
and the image name that i have here is
called my node app
and i will use this image to power one
of my
ports that i will run so this is the way
in which i'm going to launch my pod
let me show you these commands cube ctl
run
the name for my deployment that i'm
going to run hyphen iphone image
and this is the image that is going to
be powering my container so this is
simply learn docker hub
forward slash my node app hyphen f1
replica is equal to i want two replicas
to be running and the port that i want
to expose this particular part is on
eight zero eight zero so let me run this
as soon as this is run
it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
um i'm not really interested in the
deployment i'm interested in checking if
all the parts are up and running so i
will say cube ctl
get both all right so that was pretty
fast so i have two parts that are
running here these are two replicas
because i asked for two replicas these
parts are running so i can
run cube ctl describe pod
pickup all right i can pick up any of
the pod name and see what is the pod
what is the information does it contain
from what is the image that is pulling
what is the image image
name id this is actually running my
pod which is actually spinning up a
container great so far so good
so in kubernetes the pods can
are ephemeral so they can be there at
any time cannot beat any time if i need
to expose my pot outside
i will have to create a service for my
part so
what i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple service by exposing this
particular
deployment before that let me check cube
cdl
get deployment so there's a deployment
that is created the deployment name is
simply run app so i'll expose my
deployment simply learn
app as uh yeah i'll just expose this let
me see all right i am not specifying
what type and all i don't want to get
into the complications of
uh what are the different types of
exposing the service and all that stuff
so if i don't specify anything uh it
gives me something closer cluster
ip so this is where my pod is actually
exposed
so let me just check if at all this part
is up and running i'll just try a simple
curl command
curl http colon this is my cluster ip
and uh the port is 8080 if at all i had
this it's actually hitting my
application and giving me uh whatever um
i put a simple
uh sys dot out kind of a thing where i'm
just printing um
the container id of whatever pod is
serving uh being sold out of
so i'm actually hitting my container and
i'm getting this output from the content
so everything looks good my content is
up and running
uh so let me just go and clean it up
i'll say equip ctl
uh delete deployment simply learn app
this should get rid of all the parts
that i created cube ctl
getpod all right these parts are
intimidating things let me just check
cubectl
get services there's one service i don't
want this service let me delete that
cubectl
delete service i want this all right
that sounds good so let me come back to
my
host my cop server from where i'm
running so
i managed to successfully verify this
part see if everything is up and running
so what i'll do is i'll just go ahead
and
complete this demo by going and
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1
yes all right so this will ensure that
it will clean up my complete
cluster that i created so i had three or
four running instances if you see that
all the three are shutting down because
you know the cop server which had cops
installed on it uh has now got a mandate
to go ahead and
shut down and clean up the whole
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my
deployment today i'm going to tell you
how you can become
an aws solutions architect so who is an
aw solutions architect
now the main role of an aws solutions
architect is to help you deploy
your applications on the aws platform
now this is nothing but a cloud
computing platform
so it's not to say that you can't deploy
your applications on the cloud computing
platform yourself
it's just that when it comes to
organizations the applications that you
need to deploy become a whole lot more
complex
that's where an aw solutions architect
can help ever since cloud computing
became a thing
companies around the world have started
migrating their physical infrastructure
onto the cloud that's what an aws
solutions architect does
they help you migrate your physical
infrastructure onto the aws cloud
companies around the world work on a
budget an aws solutions architect will
help design a cloud infrastructure
based on the organization's budget
before that can be done however
an aw solutions architect has to create
a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now aw solutions architects also have to
focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability
reliability scalability and performance
of the cloud infrastructure
they're also responsible when it comes
to minimizing risks that an organization
can face when it comes to cloud
computing platforms
now they could face risks like security
leaks calculation mistakes and
application down times
an aw solutions architect has to ensure
that these don't happen
before we can talk about how you can
become an aws solutions architect i have
some exciting news for you guys
we've launched our own youtube community
you'll get to see a lot of quizzes
polls offers and much more to make your
learning experience
a whole lot more fun you can find all of
this on your subscription feed or you
can also click on the top right corner
right now to get started
and let's get back to how can you become
an aws solutions architect
now to become an aw certified solutions
architect you need to clear the aw
certified
solutions architect associate level
examination now
here's some details about it the exam
score ranges from 100 to 1000 marks
and the minimum passing score is 720.
however there's a catch
the passing marks are actually set using
statistical analysis
so they can be changed based on how
difficult the examination actually is
the exam fee is 150 and you can also
take a practice examination
which costs 20 dollars now regardless of
the examination you take
be it solutions architect sysops
administrator or developer
any associate level examination costs
hundred and fifty dollars
for the professional level examination
it's three hundred dollars
now if you want to learn more about the
aws certifications i suggest you click
on the top right corner
and watch our video aw certifications in
10 minutes
to learn more now the exam duration is
of 130 minutes
and you have two types of questions
multiple choice and multiple answer
now the multiple choice questions have
four options on which one of them is
right
and you have multiple answer where you
have five options out of which two of
them are correct
you can take the examination in english
japanese korean
and simplified chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination
first let's go to google and search for
aws
certifications
click on the first link
so on this page you can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications
aws provides
click on architect and select the awa
certified solutions architect associate
certification
click on register now
and here you need to click on the aw
certification account
you can sign in with your amazon account
or create a new one
i already have an amazon account that
i'll be using for signing in here
in case you don't you can click on the
create your amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
now after that is done you can schedule
a new examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here aw certified solutions architect
associate level certification
click on schedule exam press continue
and here you need to select your
language which i'm assuming is english
i'm from india so i don't need to change
anything here but you can change your
country your time zone and other details
based on your requirement
and select your preferred month i want
to do it in october
now select search for exam center
select the one that's closest to you i'm
going to select
this one and here you can select the day
that you want to take your test and the
time available
i want to do it on 15 select the time
that i want
and press continue now you can go
through all the details here
change them if you want to otherwise you
can press continue
after this is done close
and here we have the final step which is
the fees
you can enter your details here and pay
now to finish the process
now let's look at an outline of the exam
content
now what you're going to see in the exam
are five major domains
and here you have each of the domains
with their respective weightages
first you have at 34 designing resilient
architectures
at 24 percent you have both defining
performant architectures
and specifying secure applications and
architectures
at ten percent you have designing cost
optimized architectures
and at six percent you have defining
operationally excellent architectures
now let's look at each of these domains
in detail now
the first domain or design resilient
architectures can be divided into four
parts
firstly you need to know how you can
choose reliable or resilient storage
using services like aws s3 aws glacier
and aws ebs then you have how you can
design decoupling mechanisms using aws
services
now this is possible with the help of
aws sns now these aren't the only
services that
enable this these are just some of the
services then how you can design a
multi-tier architecture solution
now this is important because you need
to know how you can create a solution
that involves several other services
then you need to know
how you can design highly available and
fault tolerant architectures
now for the second domain defining
performance architectures
first you have how to choose performance
storages and databases
services that are used are aws rds aws
redshift and aws dynamodb
the second step is how you can apply
caching to improve performance
a service that can be used for this is
aws elastic cache
third how you can design solutions with
elasticity and scalability
you have aws lambda aws cloud watch and
aws data pipeline
now for the third domain which is
specifying secure applications and
architectures
you need to know how you can secure
applications using services like aws
inspector
aws cloudtrail and aws iam you need to
know how to secure data using
cloud hsm and aws macy and how you can
define the networking infrastructure
using cloudfront vpc
and elastic load balancer for the fourth
domain you have designing cost optimized
architectures
firstly you need to know how you can
design cost optimized compute solutions
you can use aws ec2 elastic bean stock
lambda and aws light sale then you need
to know how you can design
cost optimized storage solutions using
aws s3
glacier ebs and elastic file system and
the final domain
to define operationally excellent
architectures you need to set up design
features and solutions
that enable operational excellence now
some of the features are that you
perform operations as code
you annotate documentation you make
frequent
and small reversible changes and
anticipate and tackle failures
now let's have a look at the job
opportunities when it comes to aw
solutions architects
now if you have a look at this graph you
can see that aws has always provided
a lot more job postings as compared to
the other two giants in the cloud
computing domain
which are microsoft azure and google
cloud platform now if you do a little
bit of research you'll find out that
there's a
significant lacking of experienced
personnel when it comes to aws
so i would suggest this is the best time
for you to get certified
in aws so how can simply learn help you
with your aws certifications
now we are on the sampler on home page
and here we are the adw solutions
architect course
on this course which is the aws
solutions architect certification
training course
we have 36 hours of instructor-led
training 20 hours of self-paced learning
16 live demos
three simulation exams three hands-on
practice projects and so much more
here our main emphasis is on making sure
that you have enough hands-on experience
with the services
that you crack the examination at your
first attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like
iam vpc ec2 s3 and so much more
we'll also talk about databases
application services security practices
disaster recovery
and so on we even have practice
examinations
to help you prepare for the real one
choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more i'm here to walk you
through some of the aws interview
questions
which we find are important and our hope
is that
you would use this material in your
interview preparation
and be able to crack that cloud
interview and step
into your dream cloud job by the way i'm
and cloud technical architect trainer
and an interview panelist
for cloud network and devops
so as you progress in watching you're
going to see that
these questions are practical scenario
based questions
that tests the depth of the knowledge of
a person
in a particular aws product or in a
particular aws architecture
so why wait let's move on all right so
in an interview
you would find yourself with a question
that might ask you
define and explain the three basic types
of cloud services
and the aws products that are built
based on them
see here it's a very straightforward
question just explain
three basic types of cloud service
and when we talk about basic type of
cloud service
it's compute obviously that's a very
basic service
storage obviously because you need to
store your data somewhere
and networking that actually connects a
couple of other services
to your application these basic will not
include monitoring
these basic will not include analytics
because they are considered as optional
they are considered as advanced
services you could choose a non-cloud
service or a product for
monitoring of and for analytics so
they're not considered as basic so when
we talk about basics they are
compute storage and networking
and the second part of the question says
explain some of the
aws products that are built based on
them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's
that's the major share of the compute
resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock
and then function as a service which is
lambda auto scaling and light cell
are also part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run
any application and the compute service
helps us
in managing the scaling and deployment
of an application again lambda is a
compute server so the compute service
also helps in
running event initiated stateless
applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis
is on storage these days because if
there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have
new data to store process manage so
storage is again a basic and an
important cloud service and the products
that
are built based on the storage services
are
s3 object storage glacier for archiving
ebs elastic block storage as a
drive attachment for the ec2 instances
and the efs
file share for the ec2 instances so the
storage domain helps in
the following aspects it holds all the
information that the application
uses so it's the application data and
we can also archive old data using
storage which would be glacier
and any object files and any requirement
for
block storage can be met through elastic
block store
and s3 which is again an object storage
talking about networks it's just not
important
to answer the question with the name of
the services and the name of the product
it'll also be good if you could go in
depth
and explain how they can be used
right so that actually proves you to be
a person
knowledgeable enough in that particular
service or product so
talking about networking domain vpc
networking can't imagine networking
without vpc
in in the cloud environment especially
in aws cloud environment
and then we have route 53 for domain
resolution
or for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an edge
caching service that helps customers get
our customers to read their application
with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following
use cases it controls and manages the
connectivity
of the aws services within our account
and we can also pick an ip address
range if you're a network engineer or
if you are somebody who works in
networks or planning to work a network
you will soon realize the importance of
choosing your own ip address for easy
remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud
owned range of ip address in the cloud
it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that get asked would
be
the difference between the availability
zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked so to test
how well you can actually differentiate
and also correlate the availability zone
and the region relationship right so
a region is a separate geographic area
like the us2s1 i mean which represents
uh north california or the ap south
which
represents mumbai so regions are a
separate
geographic area on the contrary
availability zone
resides inside the region you shouldn't
stop there you should go further and
explain about availability zones and
availability zones are
isolated from each other and some of the
services will replicate themselves
within
the availability zone so availability
zone does replication within them but
regions they don't generally do
replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is
what is auto scaling what do we achieve
by
auto scaling so in short auto scaling it
helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances
whenever there is an demand it not only
helps us
meeting the increasing demand it also
helps in
reducing the resource usage when there
is
low demand so auto scaling also allows
us to decrease
the resources or resource capacity as
per the need of that particular r
now this helps business in not worrying
about
putting more effort in managing or
continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because auto
scaling
is going to handle it for us so business
does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially an
aws service the ability to increase and
shrink
based on the need of that r that's how
powerful is auto scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's due
targeting in cloud front now we know
that cloudfront is caching and it caches
content globally
in the amazon caching servers global
wide
the whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest
server possible that's the whole point
in using or going for
cloudfront then what do you mean by
geotargeting geotargeting
is showing customer and specific content
based on language we can customize the
content
based on what's popular in that place we
can actually customize the content the
url is the same
but we could actually change the content
a little bit
not the whole content otherwise it would
be dynamic but we can change
the content a little bit a specific a
file or a picture or a particular link
in a website and show customized content
to users
who will be in different parts of the
globe so how does it happen
cloudfront will detect the country where
the viewers
are located and it will forward the
country code to the origin
server and once the origin server gets
the specialized
or specific country code it will change
the content
and it will send to the caching server
and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country
they are in the other question you could
get asked is
the steps involved in using cloud
formation or creating a cloud formation
or
backing up an environment within cloud
formation template we all know that if
there is a template
we can simply run it and it provisions
the
environment but there is a lot more
going into it so the first step in
moving towards infrastructure as a code
is to create the cloud formation
template
which as of now supports json and yaml
file format so first create the cloud
formation template and then
save the code in an x3 bucket s3 bucket
serves as
the repository for our code and then
from the cloud formation
call the file in the s3 bucket and
create a stack
and now cloud formation uses
the file reads the file understands
services that are being called
understands the order understands how
they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service
it understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship
between the different services and it
would set an order for itself
and then would provision the services
one after the other let's say
a service has a dependency and the
dependent service
the other service which this service
let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision
resource b what happens if we inverse
the order if we inverse the order
resource b first gets provision and
because it does not have dependency
changes that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly
something is not healthy it could roll
back chances that
the environment provisioning will roll
back so
to avoid that cloud formation first
provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent
on that's depended by another service
so it provisions those service first and
then provisions the services
that has dependencies and if you're
being
hired for a devops or you know if the
interview wanted to test your skill
on systems side this definitely
would be a question in his list how do
you upgrade or downgrade a system with
near zero downtime now everybody's
moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them
want their application to be highly
available so the question would be how
do you
actually upgrade or downgrade a system
with near zero downtime now we all know
that
i can upgrade an ec2 instance to a
better ec2 instance by
changing the instance type stopping and
starting but stopping and starting
is going to cause a downtime right
so that's you should be answering or you
shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically
the interviewer wants to know how do you
upgrade a system with zero downtime
so upgrading system with zero downtime
it includes
launching another system parallelly with
the bigger
ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity
and install all that's needed if you are
going to use an ami of the old machine
well and good you don't have to go
through installing all the updates and
installing all the application
from the ami once you have launched it
in a bigger instance
locally test the application to see if
it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working
and if the application works we can
actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind route 53 let's say all that
you could do is go to rot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of
the new server and that's going to send
traffic to the new server now
so the cutover is handled or if you're
using static ip
you can actually remove the static ip
from the old machine and assign it to
the new machine that's one way of doing
it
or if you are using elastic nic card you
can actually
remove the new card from the old machine
and attach the new card to the
new machine so that way we would get
near zero
downtime if you're hired for an
architect
level you should be worrying about cost
as well
along with the technology and this
question would test
how well you manage cost so what are the
tools and techniques we can use in aws
to identify and correct identify and
know that
we are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your aws resources running one way is to
check the billing there is a place where
you can check the
top services that were utilized it could
be free and it could be paid service as
well
top services that can be utilized it's
actually in the
dashboard of the cost management console
so that
table here shows the top five
most used services so looking at it you
can get it all right so i'm using a lot
of storage i'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that
and you will find if you are storing
things that
should be storing and then clean it up
why is compute capacity so high
why is data transfer so high so if you
start thinking in those levels you'll be
able to dig in
and clean up unnecessary and be able to
save
your bill and there are cost explorer
services available which will help you
to view
your usage pattern or view your spending
for the
past 13 months or so and it will also
forecast for the next three months now
how
much will you be using if your patent is
like this
that will actually help and will give
you a visibility
on how much you have spent how much you
will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent
a way to control cost you can actually
set up budget alright this is how much
i am willing to spend for this
application for this team or
for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget
mark and anytime it exceeds any time
it's
nearing you would get an alarm saying
that well we're about to
reach the allocated budget amount stuff
like that
that way you can go back and know and
you know that how much
the bill is going to be for that month
or you can take steps to control
bill amount for that particular month so
aws budget
is another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags
helps in identifying which team or which
resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of
looking at the bill as one list with no
specifications into it and looking at it
as an expenditure list you can actually
break it down and tag the expenditure to
the teams with cost allocation tax
the dev team has spent so much the uh
production team has spent so much
the training team has spent more than
the dev and the
production team why is that now you'll
be able to you know think in those
levels only if you have cost allocation
tax
now cost allocation tags are nothing but
the tags that you would put when you
create a resource so for production
services you would put as a production
tab you would
create a production tag and you would
associate that resources to it and
at a later point when you actually pull
up your bill that's going to show a
detailed
a list of this is the owner this is the
group
and this is how much they have used in
the last month
and you can move forward with your
investigation and encourage or
stop users using more services with the
cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource
other than the console console is gui
right
so in other words other than gui how
would you use the aws resource and how
familiar are you with those
tools and technologies the other tools
that are available
that we can leverage and access the aws
resource are
of course hoodie you can configure puri
to access the aws
resources like log into an ec2 instance
and ec2 instance does not always have to
be logged in
through the console you could use putty
to log into an ec2 instance
like the jump box like the proxy machine
and
like the gateway machine and from there
you can
actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an
alternative to the console and of course
we have the
aws cli in any of the linux machines
or windows machines we can install so
that's
point two three and four we can install
aws cli
for linux windows also for mac so we can
install them
and from there from your local machine
we can access
run aws commands and access provision
monitor
the aws resources the other ones are we
can access the
aws resource programmatically using aws
sdk
and eclipse so these are a bunch of
options we have to use the aws resource
other than the console if you're
interviewed in a company or
by a company that focuses more on
security and want to use
aws native services for their security
then
you would come across this question what
services can be used to create
a centralized logging solution the basic
services we could use our cloud watch
logs
store them in s3 and then use
elasticsearch
to visualize them and use kinesis to
move the data from
s3 to elasticsearch right so log
management it actually helps
organizations to track the relationship
between
operational and security changes and the
events that got triggered
based on those logs instead of logging
into an instance or instead of
logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically
i can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs
every time there's a change the system
will scream and it gets tracked
in the cloud watch and then cloud watch
pushes it to s3
kinesis pushes the data from s3 to
elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an
a fair understanding of what was going
on in the environment for the past
one or whatever the time window that i
wanted to look at
so it helps in getting a good
understanding of the infrastructure as a
whole
all the logs are getting saved in one
place so all the infrastructure logs
are getting saved in one place so it's
easy for me to look at it in an
infrastructure perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect
to each other it could be logs that
belongs to
a one account it could be logs that
belongs to multiple accounts
it doesn't matter you know those three
services are gonna work fairly good
and they're gonna inject or they're
gonna like
suck logs from the other accounts put it
in one place and help us to monitor
so as you see you have cloud watch here
that actually
tracks the metrics you can also use
cloud trail if you want to log
api calls as well push them in an s3
bucket so there are different types of
block
flow logs are getting captured in an
instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account
from a different account and all of them
are analyzed using elasticsearch
using the kibana client so step one is
to
deploy the ecs cluster step two is to
restrict access to the ecs cluster
because it's valid data
you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so
resting access to the ecs dashboard and
we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloudwatch to the elasticsearch
domain and then kibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize
the logs instead of looking at log as
just statements or
in a bunch of characters a bunch of
files kibana helps us to analyze
the logs in a graphical or a chart or a
bar diagram
format again in an interview the
interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on aw security products
especially on the logging monitoring
even management or incident management
then you could have a question like this
what are the native aws
security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging
in them like have their own logging like
s3 s3 has its own login
and cloudfront has its own logging ds
has its own logging vpc has its own
logging
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and
aws config services so there are variety
of
logging options available in the aws
like cloud soil
config cloudfront redshift logging rds
logging vpc flow logs
s3 object logging s3 access logging
stuff like that so we're going to look
at two servers in specific
cloud trail now this cloud trail the
very first product
in that picture we just stopped the
cloud trail provides an
very high level history of the api
calls for all the account and with that
we can actually perform
a very good security analysis a security
analysis
of our account and these logs are
actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to s3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also
send an email notification to us saying
hey just got this error
thought i'll let you know stuff like
that the other one is config service
a config service helps us to understand
the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also
set up notifications based on the
configuration changes
so it records the cumulative changes
that are
made in a short period of time so if you
want to go through
the lifetime of a particular resource
what are the things that happened
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using
aws config all right the other question
you could get
asked is if you know your role includes
taking care of cloud security as well
then the other question you could get
asked is the native services that amazon
provides
or to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service
now not all companies would go with
amazon native
services but there are some companies
which
want to stick with amazon native
services just to
save them from the headache of managing
the other softwares or
bringing in another tool a third-party
tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary
amazon native services and a lot of
companies
are using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service
now denial of service is if you already
know what denial of service is well and
good if you do not know then
let's know it now denial of service is a
user trying to or maliciously making
attempt
to access a website or an application
the user would actually create multiple
sessions and
he would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let
legitimate users access the servers so
he's in turn denying the service for the
user a quick
picture review of what denial of
services
now look at it these users instead of
making one connection they are making
multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available
that would actually trigger connections
from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so
everything kind of looks legitimate for
the server and it would accept those
connections
and it would keep the sessions open the
actual users won't be able to use them
so that's denying
the service for the actual users denial
of service
all right and distributed denial of
service is generating attacks from
multiple places you know from
a distributed environment so that's
distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent
the denial of service attacks in aws is
cloud shield
and web access firewall aw swap
now they are the major ones they are
designed to mitigate
a denial of service if your website is
often bothered by
denial of service then we should be
using aws shield
or aws vaf and there are a couple of
other tools that
also does when i say that also does
denial of service is not their primary
job
but you could use them for denial of
service
route 53's purpose is to provide dns
cloudfront is to provide caching elastic
load balancer
elbs work is to provide load balancing
vpc is to create and
secure a virtual private environment but
they also support
mitigating denial of service but not to
the extent
you would get in aws shield and aws web
so aws shield and waff are the primary
ones
but the rest can also be used to
mitigate
distributed denial of service the other
tricky question is this
actually will test your familiarity with
the region
and the services available in the region
so when you're trying to provision a
service in a particular region
you're not seeing the service in that
region how do we go about
fixing it or how do we go about using
the service in the cloud
it's a tricky question and if you have
not gone through such situation
you can totally blow it away you really
need to have a good understanding on
regions the services available in those
regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it
the answer is not all services are
available in
all regions anytime amazon announces a
new service they don't
immediately publish them on all regions
they start small
and as in when the traffic increases as
and when it becomes more likeable to the
customers
they actually move the service to
different regions
so as you see in this picture within
america not virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california
so within not america itself north
virginia is the preferred one
so similarly there are preferred regions
within
europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime
we don't see a service in a particular
region chances that the service is not
available in that region yet we got to
check the documentation and find the
nearest
region that offers that service and
start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it
you could but you know that's going to
add more latency
to your application so that's why we
need to check for application which is
check for region which is very near
to the place where you want to serve
your customers and find
nearest region instead of always going
back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again
there's a place there's a link in
aws.com
that you can go and look for services
available in
different region and that's exactly what
you're seeing here
and if your service is not available in
a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest
other region that provides that service
and start using service from there
with the uh coming up of cloud a lot of
companies have turned down their
monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least
new startups and new companies that are
thinking of
having a monitoring environment that
they don't want to go with traditional
knock monitoring instead they would like
to leverage aws
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability
but it monitors a lot of stuff like
failures errors
it also triggers emails stuff like that
so
how do you actually set up a monitor to
website
how to set up a monitor to monitor the
website metrics
in real time in aws the simple way
anytime you have a question about
monitoring
cloudwatch should strike your mind
because cloudwatch
is meant for monitoring is meant for
collecting metrics is meant for
providing graphical representation of
what's going on in a particular network
at a particular point of time
so cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor
the state changes not only the state
changes the auto scaling
life cycle events anytime there are
there are more services added there is a
reduction in the number of servers
because of less usage
a very informative messages can be
received through cloud watch
any cloud watch can now support
scheduled events
if you want to schedule anything
cloudwatch has an event
that would schedule an action right
schedule a trigger
time based not incident based you know
anything happening and then
you get an action happening that's
incident based
on the other hand you can simply
schedule few things on time based so
that's possible with cloud watch
so this cloud watch integrates very well
with a lot of other services like
notifications for notifying the user
or for notifying the administrator about
it and it can integrate
well with lambda so to trigger an action
anytime you are designing an auto
healing environment
this cloud watch can actually monitor
and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can
monitor and based on what's happening it
can trigger an
event in lambda and that would in turn
run a function till the environment
comes back to
normal so cloudwatch integrates well
with a lot of other
aw services all right so cloudwatch has
uh
three statuses green when everything is
going good
yellow when the service is degraded and
red
when the service is not available green
is good so we don't have to do anything
about it
but anytime there's an ello the picture
that we're looking at
it's actually calling and lambda
function
to debug the application and to fix it
and
anytime there's a red alert it
immediately notifies the
owner of the application about well the
service is down
and here is the report that i have here
is the metrics that i've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role
requires you to manage the servers as
well
there are certain job roles which are on
the system side
there are certain job roles which is
development plus
system side now you're responsible for
the application and the server as well
so if that's the case you might be
tested with some basic questions like
the different types of virtualization
and aws and what are the difference
between them
all right the three major types of
virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization
on hardware virtual module all right the
difference between them or actually
describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
hardware you know the whole hardware
is virtualized and all virtual machines
act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing
master boot record in the root block and
when we talk about para virtualization
paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots
the pv amis and when we talk about
pv on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between
hvm and pv and this para virtualization
on hvm in other words pv on hvm
it actually helps operating system take
advantage
in storage and the network input
output available through the host
another good question is
name some of the services that are not
region specific
now you've been thought that all
services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability zone
ebs is within an availability zone s3 is
region specific
dynamodb is region specific stuff like
that
vpc is both availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and
vpcs region specific stuff like that so
you might have thought you might have
learned in that combination
but there could be some tricky questions
that tests you how well you have
understood the region
non-region and availability
non-availability
services i should say there are services
that are not
region specific that would be iam
so we can't have im for every
availability zone
and for every region which means you
know users will have to
use one username and password for one
region and anytime they switch
to another region they will have to use
another username and password that
that's more work and that's not a good
design as well
authentication has to be global so im is
a global service
and which means its not region specific
on the other hand
route 53 is again a regional specific so
we cannot have
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region
specific service it's a global service
and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each
region if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall
works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region
based service so the web application
firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service
though you can you know cache content on
a continent
and country basis it's still considered
a global service
right it's not bound to any region so
when you activate cloud front
you're activating it away from region or
availability zone so when you're
activating
a web application firewall because it's
not a region-specific service you're
activating it
away from availability zone and regions
so a quick recap i am users groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used
globally all 53 services are offered
at edge locations and they are global as
well
web application firewall a service that
protects our web application from
common web exploits they are global
service as well
cloudfront cloudfront is global content
delivery network
cdn and they are offered at edge
locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific
service or beyond region service
all right this is another good question
as well in the project that you are
being interviewed if they really want to
secure
their environment using nat or if they
are already securing their environment
using nat
by any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances
you can expect this question what are
the difference between
and that gateway and that instances now
they both saw the same thing
right so they're not two different
services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing
but still they do have differences in
them
right on a high level they both achieve
providing
netting for the service behind it but
the difference comes
when we talk about the availability of
it
that gateway is a managed service by
amazon whereas nat
instance is managed by us now i'm
talking about the third point
maintenance here nat gateway is managed
by amazon
that instance is managed by us and
availability of nat
gateway is very high and availability of
that
instance is less compared to
the nat gateway because it's managed by
us
you know it's on an ec2 instance which
could
actually fail and if it fails we'll have
to relaunch it but if it is not
gateway if something happens to that
service amazon would take care of
reprovisioning it and talking about
bandwidth it can
burst up to 75 gigabits now traffic
through the net gateway can burst up to
75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and
if we are launching a t2 micro it barely
gets any bandwidth
so there's a difference there and the
performance because
it's highly available because of the
bigger pipe 75 gigabits
now the performance of the nat gateway
is very high but the performance of the
nat
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of
the net instance that we pick and
billing
a billing for nat gateway is the number
of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the nat gateway
but billing for that instance is number
of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration
and the type of instance that we use
security in that gateway cannot be uh
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance
security is a bit customizable i can go
and change the security because it's a
server managed by
me or managed by us i can always change
the security well allow this allow
don't allow this stuff like that size
and load of the night gateway
is uniform but the size and the load of
the uh that instance changes as per an
gateway is a fixed product but not
instance can be small instance can be a
big instance so
the size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have
your instance stopped and where you have
your instance terminated
if you have only used lab and are
attending the interview chances
are that you might you always lost when
answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same
but there is a difference in it so when
you stop an
instance it actually performs a normal
shutdown
on the instance and it simply moves the
instance to the
stopped state but when you actually
terminate the instance
the instance is moved to this stop state
the ebs volumes
that are attached to it are deleted and
removed
and we'll never be able to recover them
again so that's
a big difference between stopping and
terminating
an instance if you're thinking of using
the instance again along with the data
in it you should only be thinking of
stopping the instance but you should be
terminating the instance only if you
want to get rid of that
instance forever if you are being
interviewed for an architect level
position or a junior architect level
position or even a
cloud consultant level position or even
in an engineering
position this is a very common question
that gets
asked what are the different types of
easy to instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity
for example the different types are on
demand instances
spot instances and reserved instances it
kind of
looks the same they all provide the
compute capacity they all provide the
same
type of hardwares for us but if you are
looking at
cost saving or optimizing cost in our
environment we got to be very careful
about which one are we picking now we
might think that well i'll go with
demand instance because i pay on a per
hour basis
which is cheap you know i can use them
anytime i want and anytime i don't want
i can simply get rid of it by
terminating it
you're right but if the requirement is
to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances
you'll be wasting a lot of money paying
on an hourly basis
instead we should be going for reserved
instance
where we can reserve the capacity for
the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount
in buying reserved instances all right
so under man is cheap to start with
if you're only planning to use it for a
short while but if you're planning
to run it for a long while then we
should be going for reserved instance
that is what is cost efficient so spot
instance
is cheaper than on-demand instance and
there are different use cases for spot
instance as well so let's look at one
after the other
the on-demand instance the on-demand
instance is purchased at a fixed rate
per r this is very short-term and
irregular
workloads and for testing for
development
on demand instance is a very good use
case we should be using on demand
for production spot instance spot
instance
allows users to purchase ec2 at a
reduced price
and anytime we have more instances we
can always go and sell it
in spot instances i'm referring to
anytime we have more reserved instances
we can always sell them in spot instance
catalog and the way we buy spot instance
is we actually put a budget this is how
much i'm willing to pay
all right would you be able to give
service within this cost so anytime the
price
comes down and meets the cost that we
have put in
will be assigned an instance and anytime
the price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us
but in case of on demand instances we
have bought that instance for that
particular r and it stays with us but
with spot instances
it varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price
goes away to somebody else and the spot
instance availability is actually based
on supply and demand in the market
there's no guarantee that you will get
spot instance at all time
all right so that's a caveat there you
should be familiar with
that's a caveat that you should be aware
when you are proposing somebody that we
can go for spot instance and save money
it's not always going to be available if
you want your spot instance to be
available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this month so how can i code or
how much can i code stuff like that
so you got to look at those history
before you propose somebody that
well we're going to save money using
spot instance on the other hand
reserved instance provide cost savings
for
the company we can opt for reserved
instances
for you know one year or three years
there are actually three types of
reserved instances
light medium and heavy reserved
instances
they are based on the amount that we
would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on
are we doing all upfront or no upfront
or partial payment
then split the rest as monthly payments
so there are many purchase options
available but overall
if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years
you should not be going for on-demand
instance you should be going for
reserved instance and that's what gives
you the cost
benefit and in an aws interview
sometimes you might be asked
you know how you interact with the aws
environment are you using cli
are you using console and depending on
your answer whether console or a cli
the panelist put a score okay this
person is cli specific this person is
console specific or
this person has used aws environment
through the sdk
stuff like that so this question tests
whether you are a cli person
or an console person and the question
goes like this
how do you set up ssh agent forwarding
so that you do not have to copy the key
every time you log in if you have used
puri
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have
to put the ip and the port number along
with that you will have to map
or we will have to map the key in the
puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments
right but in production environment
using the same key or mapping the same
key again and again
every time it's actually an hassle it's
considered as a blocker
so you might want to cache it you might
want to permanently
add it in your putty session so you can
immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a
quick button that actually fixes or that
actually
binds your ssh to your instance so we
can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key
to the ssh and next time when we try to
log in
you don't have to always go through
mapping the key and trying to log in
all right this question what are solaris
and ax operating systems are they
available with aws
that question generally gets asked to
test how
familiar are you with the amis available
how familiar are you with ec2 how
familiar are you with the ec2 hardwares
available that basically test that now
the first question
or the first thought that comes to your
mind is well everything is available
with
aws i've seen windows i've seen ubuntu
i've seen red hat i've seen
amazon amis and if i don't see my
operating system there i can always go
to marketplace and
try them if i don't find a marketplace i
can always go to community and try them
so a lot of ami is available there a lot
of operating systems available
i will be able to find solaris and ax
but that's not the case
solar s and ax are not available with
aws
that's because solaris uses a different
and solaris does not support the
architecture does not support
public cloud currently the same goes for
ax
as well and they run on power cpu and
not on intel
and as of now amazon does not provide
power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a
high performance computing should not be
confused with that now these are
different hardwares different cpu itself
that the cloud providers they
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in
organizations that would want to
automate their infrastructure
using amazon native services would be
how do you actually recover
an ec2 instance or auto recover an ec2
instance
when it fails well we know that ec2
instances
are considered as immutable meaning
irreparable
we don't spend time fixing bugs in an os
stuff like that you know once an ec2
instance crashes like
it goes on a always panic or there are
various reasons why it would
fail so we don't have to really worry
about fixing it we can always
relaunch that instance and that would
fix it but
what if it happens at two o'clock in the
night what if it happens that
during a weekend when nobody's in office
looking or monitoring those instances so
you would want to automate that
not only on a weekend or during midnight
but
it's general practice good to automate
it so you could
face this question how do you actually
automate an ec2 instance once it fails
and the answer to that question is using
cloudwatch we can recover the instance
so as you see
there is an alarm threshold a set in
cloud watch
and once the threshold is met meaning if
there is an error if there is a failure
if the ec2 instance is not responding
for a certain while we can set an alarm
and once the alarm is met let's say the
cpu utilization
stayed high for five minutes all right
it's not taking any
new connections or the instance is not
pinging
for five minutes or in this case it's
two minutes
it's not pinging so it's not going to
respond connection so in those cases you
would want to automatically recover
that ec2 instance by rebooting the
instance
all right now look at this the take this
action section under the action
so there we have a bunch of options like
recover this instance meaning
reboot the instance so that's how we
would recover the other two options are
beyond the scope of the question
but still you can go ahead and apply
just like i'm going to do it
so the other option is stop the instance
that's very useful
when you want to stop instances that are
having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running
and wasting the cloud expenditure so you
can actually set an alarm
that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and
they left it without or they forgot to
shut down that instance and
it gets i mean they will only use it
again the next day morning so in between
there could be like
12 hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it
so you can identify such instances and
actually stop them
when the cpu utilization is low meaning
nobody is using it
the other one is to terminate let's say
you want to give
system to somebody temporarily and you
don't want them to hand the system back
to you
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system
so you could instruct the other person
to terminate the system when they're
done
and they could forget then the instance
could be running forever
or you can monitor the system after the
specified time is over and you can
terminate the system or
best part you can automate the system
termination so you assign a system to
somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning
they've already left or cpu is low for
30 minutes meaning they've already left
stuff like that so that's possible and
if you're getting hired for an
system side architect or even on the
sysop side
you could face this question what are
the common and different types of ami
designs
there are a lot of ami designs the
question is the common ones
and the difference between them so the
common ones are the full back
a mice and the other one is just enough
os ami j e os ami
and the other one is hybrid type amis
so let's look at the difference between
them the full backed ami
just like the name says it's fully baked
it's uh
ready to use ami and this is the
simplest ami to deploy
can be a bit expensive it can be a bit
cumbersome because
you'll have to do a lot of work
beforehand you could use
the a mice a lot of planning a lot of
thought process will go into it and
the ami is ready to use right you hand
over the ami to somebody and
it's ready to use or if you want to
reuse the ami it's already ready for you
to use so that's
full baked ami the other one is just
enough operating system ami just like
the name says
it has i mean as you can also see in the
diagram
or in the picture it covers a part
of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging
and the other stuff are configured at
the time of deployment or at the time
you would be using it
so not much thought process will go in
here the only focus is on
choosing the operating system and what
goes the operating system specific
agents or bootstraps that goes into the
operating system that's all
we worry about the advantage of this is
it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time
of deploying but that's going to require
an additional
expertise on the person who will be
using the ami so that's
another overhead there but the advantage
is that it's kind of
flexible i can change the configurations
during the time of
deployment the other one is a hybrid ami
now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between the fully baked ami
and just enough operating system options
so these amis have some features of the
big type and some features of the just
enough os type
so as you see the security monitoring
logging are
packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed
during the time of a deployment so this
is where the strict company policies
would go into the ami company policies
like you gotta log this
you gotta monitor this these are the
ports that generally gets open in all
the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an ami format and during
deployment you have the flexibility of
choosing the different runtime and the
application that sits in an
ec2 instance another very famous
question you would face in an interview
is
how can you recover login to an ec2
instance to which
you lost the key well we know that if
the key is lost
we can't recover it there are some
organizations that integrate their ec2
instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the 80 and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific
tricky question is you are using a key
to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key
generally companies would have made a
backup of the key so we can pick from
the backup but
here the specific question is we have
lost the key literally no backups on the
key at all so how can we log in and we
know that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover
is that make the instance use another
key and use
that key to log in once the key is lost
it's lost forever we won't be able to
recover it you can't raise the ticket
with amazon not possible
they're not going to help it's beyond
the scope so make the instance
use another key it's only the key that's
the problem
you still have valid data in it you got
to recover the data it's just the key
that's having the problem
so we can actually focus on the key part
alone and change the key
and that will allow us to log in so how
do we do it
step by step procedure so first verify
the ec2 config service is running in
that instance
if you want you can actually beforehand
install
the easy to config in that service or
you can actually make the easy to config
run through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run
in that ec2 instance and then detach the
root volume for
that instance of course it's going to
require a stop and start
to detach the root volume from the
instance attach the root volume
to another instance as a temporary
volume or it could be a temporary
instance that you've launched only to
fix this issue
and then login to that instance and to
that
particular volume and modify the
configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key
and then move the root volume back to
its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can
log in so that's how we go ahead and fix
it
now let's move on to some product
specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably
and the interviewer would want to test
your knowledge on s3
and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences
between aws s3 and ebs well the
differences are
s3 is an object store meaning you can't
install anything in it you can store
drive files but you can't actually
install in it it's not a file system
but ebs is a file system you can install
services i mean install applications in
it and that's going to run
stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is
much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because
from the instance if you need to access
s3 you will actually have to go out
through the internet and access the s3
or
s3 is an external server it's a very
external service you'll have to
go through or you'll have to go outside
of your vpc to access
s3 s3 does not come under a vpc but ebs
comes under a vpc
it's on the same vpc so you would be
able to use
it kind of locally compared to s3 ebs is
very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy
talking about redundancy of s3 and ebs
s3
is replicated the data in s3 is
replicated across
the data centers but ebs is replicated
within the data center meaning
s3 is replicated across availability
zones
ebs is within an availability zone so
that way the redundancy is
a bit less in ebs in other words
redundancy is higher
in s3 than eps and talking about
security of s3 is3 can be made private
as well as public meaning
anybody can access s3 from anywhere in
the internet that's possible with s3 but
ebs can only only be accessed when
attached to an ec2 instance
right just one instance can access it
whereas s3 is publicly directly
accessible
the other question related to s3
security is how do you allow access to a
user
to assert in a user to a certain bucket
which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all
but this user needs to be given access
to a certain bucket how do we do it
the same case applies to servers as well
in few cases
there could be an instance where a
person is new to the team and
you actually don't want them to access
the production service
now he's in the production group and by
default he or she is granted access to
that server but you specifically want
to deny access to that production server
till the time
he or she is matured enough to access or
understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances
and we would actually uh put a tag on
them that's how we categorize
right so you put a tag on them put a tag
saying well they are highly
critical they are medium critical and
they are not critical at all
still there in production stuff like
that and then you would pick the users
who wants to or who should be or should
not be given access to a certain
server and you would actually allow the
user
to access or not access servers based on
a specific tag in other words
you can use actually tags in in the
previous step we put tags on the
critical server right so you would
define that this user is not going to
use this tag
all right this user is not allowed to
use the resources with this stack so
that's how you would
make your step forward so you would
allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case
he or she will not be allowed to servers
which are
tagged critical servers so that's how
you allow deny access
to them and the same goes for bucket as
well or if an organization is
excessively using s3 for their data
storage because of
the benefit that it provides the cost
and the
durability you might get asked this
question
which is organizations would replicate
the data from
one region to another region for
additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy
not only for that they would also do
that for dr purposes
for disaster recovery if the whole
region is down you still have the data
available somewhere else and you can
pick and use it some organizations
would store data in different regions
for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users
who are local to that region stuff like
that so when companies do replication
how do you make sure that there is
consistency in the replication how do
you make sure that the replication is
not failing
and the data gets transferred for sure
and there are logs
for that replication this is something
that the companies would use
where they're excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on
the replication in running their
business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that
the cloud replication a region level
replication is happening properly so
this is how
it happens now on this side on the left
hand side we have the region 1
and on the right hand side we have
region 2 and region one is the source
bucket and region two is the
destination bucket right so object is
put in the source bucket
and it has to go directly to the region
to bucket or
or made a copy in the region to bucket
and the problem is sometimes it fails
and
there is no consistency between them so
the way you would do it is
connect these services together and
create and cross replication
or cross region replication monitor that
actually monitors
that actually monitors your environment
so there are cloud watch that make sure
that
the data is uh moved no data is failing
again there's cloud watch on the other
end make sure that the data is
moving and then we have the logs
generated
through cloud trail and that's actually
written
in dynamodb and if there is an error if
something is failing
you get notified through an sms or you
get notified through an
email using the sns service so that's
how we could
leverage these tools and set up and
cross region replication
monitor that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc
is that we all know that i can use route
to resolve an ip address externally from
the internet but
by default the servers won't connect to
the other servers
using our custom dns name that does not
do that
by default so it's actually a problem
there are some additional
things that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it
you will have to do and that's what
we're going to discuss so
the question could be a vpc is not
resolving
the server through the dns you can
access it through the ip but not through
the
dns name and what could be the issue and
how do you go about
fixing it and you will be able to answer
this question only if you have
done it already it's a quick and simple
step by default vpc does not allow
that's the default feature and we will
have to enable the uh
dns hostname resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns
that comes along this is for the custom
dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution
so our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution
so they actually resolve let's say i
want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to server
one simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and
they have a head office in a central
place and the rest of them are branch
offices and they are connecting to the
head office
for access or you know for saving data
or for accessing certain files or
certain data
or storing data all right so they would
actually mimic
the hubban spoke topology where you have
the vpc which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then
you would have a local vpcs or branch
offices
in different other regions and they get
connected to the
vpc in the central location and the
question is how do you actually
connect the multiple sites to a vpc and
make
communication happen between them by
default
it does not do that we know that vpcs
they need to be
paired between them in order to access
the resources
let's look at this picture right so i
have like a customer
network or branch offices in different
parts
and they get connected to a vpc that's
fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices the remote
offices
they are connecting to the vpc and
they're talking but they can't
connect or they can't talk to each other
that's what we have built but the
requirement
is the traffic needs to or
they should be able to talk to each
other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit
the vpc and then reach the other
customer network
which is in los angeles or which is in
new york all right that's the
requirement so that's possible with some
architecting in the cloud so that's
using vpn cloud hub
you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate
networks to talk to each other through
the vpc
again by default it doesn't happen cloud
hub
is an architecture that we should be
using to make
this happen and what's the advantage of
it as
a central office or as the headquarters
office which is in the vpc
or headquarters data center which is in
the vpc you have control or the vpc has
control
on who talks to who and what traffic
can talk to i mean what traffic can be
routed to the other head office
stuff like that that centralized control
is on the vpc
the other question you could get asked
is neiman explain some security products
and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products
that can actually secure the vpc or
the vpc delivers those products to
secure
the application access to the vpc is
restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security
product in vpc and a vpc has security
groups
that protects the instances from
unwanted inbound and outbound traffic
and network access control list protects
the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access and there are flow logs we can
capture in vpc that captures incoming
and outgoing traffic
through a vpc which will be used for
later analysis
as in what's the traffic pattern what's
the behavior
of the traffic pattern and stuff like
that so there are some security products
and features available in vpc now how do
you monitor vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc
except for lambda and s3 and dynamodb
and couple of other services most of
them sit in a vpc for security reason
so how do you monitor your vpc how do
you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc
using vpc flow log that's the basic
service as you see it actually captures
what's allowed what's not allowed
stuff like that which ips allowed which
ip is not allowed
stuff like that so we can gather it and
we can use that
for analysis and the other one is uh
cloud watch and cloud watch logs
the data transfers that happen so this
is you know who gets allowed and who
does not get allowed
i mean the flow logs is who is allowed
and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer
how much data is getting transferred we
can actually
pick unusual data transfers if there is
a sudden hike in the graph
there's a sudden hike and something
happens at 12
on a regular basis and you weren't
expecting it there's something
suspicious it could be valid backups
it could be a malicious activity as well
so that's how you know by looking at
cloudwatch logs and cloudwatch dashboard
now let's talk about multiple choice
questions
when going for an interview you might
sometimes
find yourself that the company is
conducting
an online test based on the score they
can put you
to a panelist and then they would take
it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to
help you better handle such situation if
you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key
to clear them is to understand the
question properly
read between the lines that's what they
say you know there can be like
a big paragraph with three lines or ten
lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about
and then try to find answer for that
question so that's
a thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast
the services mentioned or try to compare
and contrast the answers
you can easily read out one or two
answers
and then you will be left with only two
to decide from you know so that also
helps you with time and
that's all that also helps you with some
precision in your answer so
number one read between the lines number
two compare and contrast the services
and you'll be able to easily weed out
the wrong ones so let's try answering
this question
suppose you are a game designer and you
want to develop a game
with a single digit millisecond latency
which of the following database services
would you choose so we know that
the following are database services are
good enough all right
and it talks about millisecond latency
that's a key point and the third thing
is
it's a game it could be a mobile game
it's a game that you are trying
to design and you need a millisecond
latency and
it has to be a database all right so
let's talk about the options available
rds
rds is a database for sure is it good
for
a game design we'll come back to that
neptune
neptune is a graph a database service in
amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation
and snowball is actually a storage all
right it's
it's a transport medium i would say so
that's again
out of the equation so the tie is
between rds and
dynamodb if we need to talk about rds
rds is an a platform as a service it
provides cost efficient resizable
capacity but
it's an sql database meaning the tables
are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other
type of applications but not really good
for anything that has to do with
gaming so the only option left is
dynamodb
again it's the right answer dynamodb is
actually an
fast and flexible nosql database
service and it provides a single digit
millisecond latency at any scale
and it's a database at the same time
it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question
if you need to perform real-time
monitoring of aws services
and get actionable insights which
service
would you use all right let's list the
services
so it talks about real-time monitoring a
firewall manager
what does it provide now firewall
manager is
not really a monitor just like the name
says it's a manager
it manages multiple firewalls and aws
guard duty
is an threat detection service
it does monitoring it does continuously
monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about
cloud watch a cloud watch is a service
that
helps to track metrics it's a service
is used to monitor
the environment and give us a system
wide
visibility and also it helps us to store
logs so
at the moment it kind of looks like that
could be the right answer we don't know
that yet but i mean we have one more
option left that's uh
ebs so what's ebs ebs is a block
storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so
all three of them are easily out of the
question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats of course
it does monitoring so there's
i mean if there is one relation between
cloud watch and god duty that's
monitoring so easily we can
actually find ourselves slipped towards
picking god duty but know that god duty
is only for
gaining security inside but not about
gaining
aws service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to
get a system wide or an aws wide or an
account wide
it has number of metrics we can monitor
and get a very good insight of
how a service is performing be it cpu
be it ram bit network utilization beat
connection failures cloud watch is a
service that helps us
perform a real-time monitoring and get
some actionable
insights on the services all right let's
talk about this 33rd question
as a web developer you are developing an
app especially for the mobile platform
all right there is a mention that this
is especially for the mobile platform
so a lot of services gets filtered out
mobile platform
right which of the following lets you
add user sign up
sign in and access control to your web
and mobile app
quickly and easily all right so this is
all about signing in
to your mobile app so if we need to read
between the lines that's how we can read
sign up
or sign in into a mobile platform all
right so we have like four options here
uh shield aws massey aws inspector
amazon cognito so let's try to weed out
services
which are not relevant to it so what's
aws shield aws shield is actually a
service that provides
a ddos mitigation or ddos protection
denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws
maxi is again a security service that
uses machine learning to automatically
discover and classify
the data it again talks about security
and
this security is all about encrypting or
saving the data
does not come close with signing up and
mobile platform
all right let's talk about the other one
aws inspector
now aws inspector has something to do
with
apps it definitely has something to do
with apps so
kind of looks like that's relevant as of
now so it actually helps with
the improving the security and
compliance of
the apps that we deploy in the cloud
so kind of looks like it could be
because it has to do with apps
the last one cognito now cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator
to have control access over
web and mobile apps and it's a service
that helps us to sign up
and uh sign in to an mobile and web app
so that
very much looks like we found the answer
so cognito is a service that helps
web app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also
gives the administrator to have control
over who has i mean access control over
the web and the mobile app pretty much
we found it so it's cognito cognito is a
service that
helps us to set up sign up sign in and
have access control over
the users who would be using our mobile
and web app all right how about this
question
uh you are an ml engineer or a machine
learning engineer
who is on the lookout for a solution
that will discover
sensitive information that your
enterprise stores
in aws and then uses nlp
to classify that data and provide
business
related insights which among the
following services would you choose so
we have
a bunch of services that's going to help
us achieve or one of it is going to help
us achieve
the above requirement so it's a service
that
deals with machine learning you're a
machine learning engineer
who's looking for a service that will
help you to discover
information at your enterprise store so
we're talking about storage
discover information in store and then
classify
uh the data depending on severity the
sensitivity
classify the data so which service is
that so firewall manager just like the
name says it's
a manager and the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access
management so it's identity and access
management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two
is already out of the equation and then
uh the aw is massy
we already had a quick definition
description
for aws massey that it's actually a
security service that
uses machine learning it kind of looks
like it could be it
it's a security service that uses
machine learning and it discovers and
classifies
the sensitive information not only that
it does not stop there
it goes beyond and protects the
sensitive data aws massey kind of looks
like but we still have one more
option to look at which is cloud hms
cloud hms
is also a security service kind of looks
like that could be the answer as well
and
it enables us to generate encryption
keys
and save the data so kind of fifty
percent of it it's a security service
it encrypts helps us protect the data
but
aws maxi is right on spot it's a machine
learning service
it helps us to classify the data and
also to protect the data so the answer
for
this question would be aws messy so hope
you kind of get it how this is
going so first we apply the thumb rule
identify
the question that's being asked read
between the lines and then
try to find the service that meets your
requirement then
finding the service is by first weeding
out the wrong ones
recollect everything that you've learned
about the service
and see how well that matches with those
hints that you have
picked up and if that doesn't match weed
that out then you'll end up with
two just to to decide from at some point
and then it becomes easy for you to
decide click on the question
submit it and then move on to the other
question in your interview
all right so how about this one you are
a system administrator in your company
which is running most of its
infrastructure on aws
you are required to track your users and
keep
a look on how your users are being
authenticated all right so this is where
the problem statement starts
right you need to keep track of how your
users are being authenticated and you
wish to create and manage
aws users and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to the aws
resources right
you are to give them permission number
one
and then i mean if we put them in the
right order first giving them
permissions and then tracking their
usage let's see which of the service
will help us achieve it
iam is a service that helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not
so that helps us to get a track of who
is able to use who's not able to use
certain servers
and all that stuff so it kind of looks
like but we have other three options
left let's look at aws firewall manager
just like the name says it's actually a
firewall manager it helps us to manage
multiple firewalls simple as that
and shield is a service it's a service
that's used to protect
denial of service or distributed denial
of
service an api gateway is a service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish
maintain and monitor and secure
api so i mean it's completely on the api
side
very less on user and how you
authenticate
your user we can get that by looking at
the name itself
right if you abbreviate it or if you if
you try to find a definition
for the name api gateway you would get
it it has to do with api
but if you aggregate aws iam its
identity and access management
pretty much meets the requirement for
the problem statement about its aws
identity and access management that's
the right answer all right let's look at
this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public ip address
in order to make them communicate with
the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using
public and private ip address so this
service
uses ip address and then this service
helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and
to the other instances so you get the
question is it
let's pick the service that helps us
achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or
deny no it does not do that vpc vpc uses
public and private ip address
yes so kind of looks like a vpc
helps us to allow i mean the security in
vpc the security group
the network access control list in a vpc
that routing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection
to a particular ip address or to a
particular service within
the vpc or outside of the vpc so as of
now it kind of looks like
it could be but let's look at the other
services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches
to the above requirement than the amazon
vpc
gateway api gateway we know that it's a
managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish
maintain and monitor apis and secure api
so that has
completely do with api not with ip cloud
cloudfront
we know about cloudfront that it's a
content delivery network
and it provides global distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or bulk media or
anything else
they can be cached locally so users can
easily access them and
download them easily right so that's
cloud front
now at this point after looking at all
four it looks like vpc is the right
answer and in fact vpc is the right
answer vpc has public ip address vpc can
help us with a private ip address
vpc can be used to allow deny connection
based on the security group access
control list
and routing table it has so that's right
answer is vpc
all right how about this one this
platform as a service
or platform as a db service provides us
with the cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative
tasks so this question is very clear
it's a db service we got to look for
and it's a service that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
tasks it has to be
resizable at the same time so let's talk
about amazon rational
database it's a database kind of matches
the requirement
we can resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now
it actually automates some of the time
consuming work
looks like it's a fit as of now let's
move on to elastic cache and then
try to see if that matches the
definition
that we've figured out about elastic
cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving
high throughput and low latency in
memory data stores so it's not a
full-blown
database and it does not come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything
like that yeah we can resize the
capacity as and when needed but
automation it's not there yet and
moreover it's not a database so that's
out of the equation
vpc is not a recessible one
you know once we have designed vpc it's
fixed
it can't be resized so that's out of the
equation
and amazon glacier glacier is a storage
but
not a database right so that's again of
the equation so that tie
is kind of between amazon rational
database service and amazon elastic
cache
because they both aid the database
service but elastic cache
is not a full-blown database it actually
helps database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's amazon
relational database so that's the one
which is a platform as a service
it's the one which can be resized it's
the one which can be used to
automate the time consuming
administrative tasks all right let's
talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing
human researchers or consultants to help
solve a problem
on a contractual or a temporary basis
all right let's read the question again
which of the following is a means for
accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like signing task or hiring aws experts
for a temporary job so let's try to find
that kind of service in the four
services that are listed
amazon elastic mapreduce mapreduce is
actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost
effective to analyze large amount of
data but
that has nothing to do with accessing
human researchers
all right let's talk about mechanical
term it's a web service that provides
a human workforce that's the definition
for it uh for example
automation is good but not everything
can be automated for something to
qualify for automation it has to be
an repetitive task one time task can't
be automated or
the time and money that you would be
spending in automation is not worth it
instead you could have done it manually
so that does not qualify for automation
and anything that requires
intelligence right anything that's a
special case
right automation can do repetitive task
automation can do precise work but
it has to be repetitive task the
scenario you know it should have been
there already
only then that can be executed but if
it's a new scenario and it requires
uh appropriate addressing then it
requires human thought so
we could hire researchers and
consultants who can help solve a problem
using amazon
mechanical turk the other two are
already out of the equation
now dev pay is actually a payment system
through amazon and multi-factor
authentication as it says it's an
authentication system
so the right answer is amazon mechanical
turk
all right this sounds interesting let's
look at this one this service is used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws
which of the following is this aws
service so it's a service to deploy
manage
and scale containerized application so
it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is and container
orchestration
service all right the first one amazon
elastic container service
kind of looks like it's the one the name
itself has
the word and the relation we're looking
for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable
high performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one
aws batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute uh
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock
that's another service that helps us to
deploy manage
and scale but it helps us with easy two
instances
not with containerized instances so
that's
again out of the equation would light
scale be a good tie
for elastic container service what's
light sale
now lightsail is a service it's called
as
a virtual private server without a vpc
it's called as a virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage
networking capacity it's actually a
server
not a container right so at this point
that also
becomes out of the equation so it's
amazon elastic container service that's
the one that helps us to
easily deploy manage scale container
services
and it helps us orchestrate the
containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service
lets us to run code without provisioning
or
managing servers so no servers run code
select the correct service
from the below option all right so no
servers but we should be able to run
code amazon easy to auto scaling easy to
auto scaling
ec2 is elastic compute cloud which is
a server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling
the server so that's the definition for
it could be
that's out of the equation aw is lambda
now lambda
is a service it's actually event driven
serverless computing platform
and lambda runs code in response to the
event
that it receives and it automatically
manages the
compute resource that's required for
that code
as long as we have uploaded a code
that's correct and set up
events correctly to map to that code
it's going to run
seamlessly so that's about lambda it
kind of looks like it could be the
answer because
lambda runs code we don't have to manage
servers it
manages servers by itself but we can't
conclude as of now we have other two
servers to talk about
aws batch all right batches service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that
and about inspector amazon inspector
it's actually a service that helps us to
increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance
well that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement and the
question was
run code without provisioning your
server and without any more
space for confusion aws lambda is a
service or is the
service that runs code without
provisioning and managing
services right the right one would be
aws lambda
i'm very excited that you're watching
this video and i'm
equally glad that we were able to
provide you
a second part in aws interview questions
all right let's get started so in an
environment where
there is a lot of automation
infrastructure automation
you'll be posted with this question how
can you add an existing instance
to a new auto scaling group now this is
when
you are taking an instance away from the
auto scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs
or if you have suspended the auto
scaling you know you might need to
re-add that instance to the auto scaling
group
only then it's going to take part in it
right only then the auto scaling is
going to count
it has part of it it's not a straight uh
procedure you know when you remove them
you know it doesn't get
automatically re-added and i've had
worked with some clients so
when their developers were managing
their own environment they had problems
adding the instance
back to the auto scaling group you know
irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group
and whatever they fixed that they were
provided or whatever fix that they have
provided were not you know getting
encountered
in the auto scaling group so like i said
it's not a straight
you know a click button procedure there
are ways we'll have to do it so how can
you add an
existing instance uh to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that
we need to follow so the first one would
be to under the ec2
instance console right under the uh
instance
under actions in specific you know
there's an
option called attach to auto scaling
group right if you have multiple auto
scaling groups
in your account or in the region that
you're working in
then you're going to be posted with the
different auto scaling groups that you
have
in your account let's say you have five
auto scaling groups for five different
application
you know you're going to be posted with
five different auto scaling
groups and then you would select the
auto scaling
the appropriate auto scaling group and
attach the instance
to that particular auto scaling group
while adding to the auto scaling group
if you want to change the instance
type and that's possible as well
sometimes
when you want to add the instance back
to the auto scaling group there would be
requirement that you change the instance
type to a better one
to a better family to the better
instance type you could do that
at that time and after that you are or
you have completely added
the instance back to the auto scaling
group so it's actually an seven
step up process adding an instance back
to the
auto scaling group in an environment
where they're dealing with migrating the
instance
or migrating an application or migrating
an instance
migrating and vm into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations
you could be posted this question what
are the factors you will consider
while migrating to amazon web services
the first one is
cost is it worth moving the
instance to the cloud given the
additional
bills and whistles features available in
the cloud is this application going to
use
all of them is moving into the cloud
beneficial to the application in the
first place you know beneficial to the
users who will be using the application
in the first place so that's a factor to
think of so this actually includes
you know cost of the infrastructure and
the ability to match the demand and
supply
transparency is this application and
high demand you know
is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes
unavailable for some time so there are a
few things that needs to be considered
before we move the application to the
cloud and then if
uh the application does the application
needs to be
provisioned immediately is that an urge
is there an urge to provision the
application
immediately that's something that needs
to be considered if the
application requires to go online if the
application
needs to hit the market immediately then
we would
need to move it to the cloud because in
on-premises procuring or buying an
infrastructure buying the bandwidth
buying the switchboard you know buying
an instance
you know buying their softwares buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time
at least like two weeks or so before you
can bring up
an server and launch an application in
it right so the
application cannot wait you know waiting
means uh
you know workforce productivity loss is
it so we would want to
immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is urge in making the application
go online as soon as possible then
that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if
the the software or if the product that
you're launching
it requires hardware it requires an
updated
hardware all the time that's not going
to be possible in on premises
we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time
in on premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardwares
only then they can
keep themselves up going in the market
so they constantly the cloud providers
are constantly updating their hardwares
and if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the hardwares
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible
the software version the licensing is as
latest as possible
then that's a candidate to be moved to
the cloud and if the application
does not want to go through any risk if
the application is
very sensitive to failures if the
application is
very much stacked to the revenue of the
company and you don't want to take a
chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop
then that's a candidate for moving to
the cloud and business uh
agility you know moving to the cloud at
least half of the responsibility is now
taken care
by the provider in this case it's amazon
at least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them
like if the hardware fails amazon makes
sure that they're fixing the hardware
immediately and notifications you know
if something happens
you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and
make ourselves aware that something has
broken
and we can immediately jump in and fix
it so
you see there are the responsibility is
now being shared between amazon
and us so if you want to get that
benefit for your application for your
organization
for the product that you're launching
then it needs to be moved to the cloud
so you can
get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get
asked is what is rto and rpo in aws
they are essentially disaster recovery
terms when you're planning
for disaster recovery you cannot avoid
planning
disaster recovery without talking about
rto and rpo now what's the rto
what's the rpo in your environment or
how do you define rto how do you define
rpo
or some general questions that get asked
rto is recovery
time objective rto stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait
for the recovery to happen or for the
recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is uh
in the future right how much time is it
going to take
to fix and bring everything to normal so
that's rtu
on the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data loss
your company is willing to accept as
measured in time
rpo always refers to the backups
the number of backups the the frequency
of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the
latest backup right and if the latest
backup was before 12 hours
you have lost the in between 12 hours of
data data storage right so rpo is the
acceptable amount
if the company wants less rpo
rpo is 1r then you should be planning on
taking backups every one hour if rpo is
12 hours then you should be planning on
taking backups every 12 hours so that's
how rpo
and rto you know helps disaster recovery
the fourth question you could get asked
is
if you would like to transfer huge
amount of data which is the best
option among a snowball snowball edge
and snowmobile again this is a question
that get asked if
the company is dealing with a lot of
data transfer
into the cloud or if the company is
dealing with the
migrating data into the cloud i'm
talking about a huge amount of data
data in petabytes snowball and all of
the snowball series
deals with the petabyte-sized data
migrations so
there are three options available as of
now aws
snowball is an data transport solution
for moving
high volume of data into and out of a
specified aws
region on the other hand aws snowball
edge
adds additional computing functions
snowball is simple storage and movement
of data and snowball edge has
a compute function attached to it snow
mobile
on the other hand is an exabyte scale
migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer
from our data center to the cloud we can
hire
we can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions
this is a classic question how is aws
cloud formation
different from aws elastic bean stock
you know from the surface
they both look like the same you know
you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli
and provision resources both of them
provision resources
through click button right but
underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question
a lot better let's talk about the
difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or
the panelist so the cloud formation the
cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand
elastic bean stock provides an simple
environment
to which we can deploy and run
application
cloud formation gives us an
infrastructure and
elastic bean stock gives us an small
contained
environment in which we can run our
application and
cloud formation supports the
infrastructure needs
of many different types of application
like
the enterprise application the legacy
applications
and any new modern application that you
want to have
in the cloud on the other hand the
elastic bean stock
it's a combination of developer tools
they are tools that helps manage the
life cycle of
a single application so cloud formation
in short is managing the infrastructure
as a whole
and elastic bean stock in short is
managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using uh
cloud formation to manage their
infrastructure
using or if they're using infrastructure
or any of the infrastructure as a code
services then you would definitely face
this question
what are the elements of an aws cloud
formation
template so it has four or five
basic uh elements right and the template
is in the form of
json or in yaml
format all right so it has parameters it
has
outputs it has data it has resources
and then the format or the format
version
or the file format version for the cloud
formation
template so parameter is nothing but
it actually lets you to specify the type
of ec2 instance
that you want the type of rds that you
want all right
so ec2 is an umbrella rds is an umbrella
and parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that
rds are the specific details of the ec2
or the specific details
of the rds service so that's what
parameters
in a cloud formation template and then
the element of the cloud formation
template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want to output the name
of the ec2 instance
if you want to output the name of some
resources that have been created
instead of looking into the template
instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource
we can actually have them outputted in
the result section so we can simply go
and look at all the resources
created through the template in the
output section and that's what
output values or output does in the
cloud formation template
and then we have resources resources are
nothing but what defines what are the
cloud components or cloud resources
that will be created through this cloud
formation template now ec2 is a resource
rds is a resource
and s3 bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource
and nat gateway is a resource vpc is a
reserve so you see all these components
are the resources and the resource
section in the cloud formation defines
what are the aws cloud resources that
will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have a version
a version actually identifies the
capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the
latest version type and the latest
version is
0909 2010 that's the latest version
number
you'll be able to find that on the top
of the cloud formation template and that
version number defines the capabilities
of the cloud formation template so just
need to make sure that it's the latest
all the time
still talking about cloud formation this
is another classic question
what happens when one of the resource in
a stack cannot be created
successfully well if the resource in a
stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back
and terminates all the resources that
was created
using the cloud formation template so
whatever resources that were created
through the cloud formation template
from the beginning
let's say we have created like 10
resources and the 11th resource is now
failing cloud formation
will roll back and delete all the
10 resources that were created
previously and this is very useful
uh when the cloud formation cannot you
know go forward
cloud formation cannot create additional
resources because
we have reached the elastic ip limits
elastic ip limit per region is five
right and if you have already used five
ips and a cloud formation is trying to
buy
three more ips you know we've hit the
soft limit
till we fix that with amazon
cloudformation will not be able to
you know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips
so it's going to cancel and roll back
everything that's true with
a missing ec2 ami as well if
an ami is included in the template and
but the
ami is not actually present then cloud
formation is going to search for the mi
and because it's not present it's going
to roll back
and delete all the resources that it
created so that's what
cloud formation does it simply rolls
back all the resources that it
created i mean if it sees a failure it
would simply roll back all the resources
that it
created and this feature actually
simplifies
the system administration and layered
solutions built on top of aws cloud
formation
so at any point we know that there are
no orphan
resources in the in in our environment
you know because
something did not work or because there
was an you know cloud formation
executed some there are no orphan
resources in our account
at any point we can be sure that if
cloud formation is launching a resource
and if it's going to fail and it's going
to come back and delete all the
resources
it's created so there are no orphan
resources in our account
now let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store
again if the environment deals with a
lot of automation
you could be thrown this question how
can you automate easy to backup
using ebs it's actually a six step
process
to automate the ec2 backups we'll need
to write a script
to automate the below steps using aws
api and these are the steps that should
be
found in the scripts first to get the
list of instances
and then and then the script that we are
writing should be able to connect
to aws using the api and list the amazon
abs volumes
that are attached locally to the
instance and then it needs to list
the snapshots of each volume make sure
the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because
over time the snapshots are going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because
you have captured the latest and 10
snapshot coverage is
enough for you and then the fifth point
is to create a snapshot
of each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot anytime a new snapshot gets
created the oldest
snapshot of the list needs to go away so
we need to include
options we need to include scripts in
our script lines in our script
that make sure that it's deleting the
older
snapshots which are older than the
retention period
that we are mentioning another question
that you could
see in the interview beat written
interview beat online interview or beat
and telephonic or face-to-face interview
is
what's the difference between ebs and
instant store let's talk about ebs first
ebs is kind of permanent storage the
data in it can be
restored at a later point when we save
data in
ebs the data lives even after
the lifetime of the ec2 instance for
example we can stop the instance
and the data is still going to be
present in ebs we can move the ebs
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there
so abs is kind of permanent storage when
compared
to instance on the other hand instance
store
is a temporary storage and that storage
is actually physically attached to the
host of the machine
ebs is an external storage an instant
store is locally attached
to the instance or locally attached to
the host of
the machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance
and attach it to another but we can do
that with eba so that's a big difference
one is permanent data
and another one is ebs is permanent
instant store is
a volatile data and instant store
with instant store we won't be able to
detach
the storage and attach it to another
instance and another feature of instant
store is
data in an instant store is lost if the
disk fails
or the instance is stopped or terminated
so instant store is
only good for storing cache data if you
want to store permanent data then
we should think of using ebs and not
instant store while talking about
storage on the same lines this is
another classic question how can you
take
backups of efs like ebs
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup
the answer is yes we can take efs to efs
backup
solution efs does not support snapshot
like ebs
efs does not support snapshot snapshot
is not an option for
efs elastic file system right we can
only take backup from one efs
to another efs and this backup solution
is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of
the efs and this can be automated but
any data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or
you know the whole ef is is for some
reason interrupted or deleted we can
recover the data from we can use the
other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this
it's not an one-step configuration it's
a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve
efs to efs backup the first thing is to
sign in to the aws management console
and under efs or click on efs to efs
restore button from the services list
and from there
we can use the region selector in the
console navigation bar to select the
actual
region in which we want to work on and
from there
ensure that we have selected the right
template you know some of the templates
would be you know efs to efs backup
granular backups incremental backups
right so there are some templates the
kind of backups that you want to take do
you want to take grant alert do you want
to take
increment backups stuff like that and
then
create a name to that solution the kind
of backup that we have created
and finally review all the
configurations that you have done and
click on save and from that point
onwards
the data is going to be copied and from
that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and
replicate it now you have an efs to efs
backup this is another classic question
in companies which deals with a data
management
there are easy options to create
snapshots but
deleting snapshots is not always
an you know click button or an single
step
configuration so you might be
facing a question like how do you auto
delete old
snapshots and the procedure is like this
now as best practice
we will take snapshots of ebs volume to
s3 all snapshots
get stored in s3 we know that now and we
can use aws
ops automator to automatically handle
all
snapshots the ops automator service it
allows us to create
copy delete ebs snapshots
so there are cloud formation templates
available for aws ops
automator and this automator template
will scan the environment and it would
take snapshots
it would you know copy the snapshot from
one region to another region if you want
i know if you're setting up a dr
environment and not only that
based on the retention period that we
create
it's going to delete the snapshots which
are older than
the retention period so life or managing
snapshot is
made a lot easier because of this ops
automator
cloud formation template moving into
questions and elastic
load balancer this again could be an uh
question in the interview
what are the different types of load
balancers in aws and
what's their use case what's the
difference between them and as
of now as we speak there are three types
of load balancers
which are available in aws the first one
being application
load balancer just like the name says
the application load balancer works on
the application layer and deals with the
http and https
request and it also supports part
based routing for example
simplylearn.com
slash some webpage simplylearn.com
another website so it's going to direct
the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the urls that's path based
routing so it supports that and not only
that it can support a
port-based colon 8080 colon 8081
or colon 8090 you know based on that
port also
it can take a routing decision and
that's what application
load balancer does on the other hand we
have network
load balancer and the network load
balancer makes routing decisions at the
transport level
it's faster because it has very less
thing to work on
it works on lower osi layer it works on
a lower layer so it has very
less information to work with than
compared with application layer so
comparatively it's a lot faster
and it handles millions of requests per
second and
after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the
flow hash routing algorithm it does
simple routing
right it does not do path-based or
port-based routing
it does simple routing and because of it
it's faster and then we have
classic load balancer which is kind of
expiring
as we speak amazon is discouraging
people using classic load balancer but
there are companies
which are still using classic load
balancer they are the ones
who are the first one to step in to
amazon when classic load balancer was
the first load balancer or the only load
balancer available at that point
so it supports http https tcp ssl
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between a load balance report and the
container port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then
at after some point amazon said instead
of having one load balancer address all
type of traffic we're going to have
two load balances called as the child
from the classic
two load balancer and one is going to
specifically address the application
requirement and one is going to
specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how
now we have two different load balancers
talking about load balancer another
classic question could be what are the
different
uses of the various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just
spoke about it application load balancer
is used if we need a flexible
application management
and tls termination and network load
balancer
if we require extreme performance and
the load balancing should happen
on based on static ips for the
application
and classic load balancer is an old load
balancer
which is for people who are still
running their environment
from ec2 classic network now this is an
older version of vpc
or this is what was present before vpc
was created easy to classic network
is what was present before ec2 was
created so they are the three types
and they are the use cases of it let's
talk about some of the security related
questions you would face
in the interview when talking about
security and firewall in aws we
cannot avoid discussion talking about
waff
web application firewall and you would
definitely
see yourself in this situation where
you've been asked
how can you use aws off in monitoring
your
aws applications waff or web application
firewall protects our web application
from
common web exploits and vaf helps
us control which traffic source your
application should be allowed or
a block which traffic from a certain
source you know which source or which
traffic from a certain source
should be allowed or blocked your
application with waff we can also create
custom rules that blocks common attack
patterns you know if it is a banking
application it has a
certain type of attacks and if it is
simple data management data storage
application it has
uh i mean content management application
it has a separate type of attack so
based on
the application type we can identify a
pattern and create rules
that would actually block that attack
based on the rule that we create
and waff can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow
all requests and then block all request
and count all requests
for a new policy so it's also an
monitoring and management service
which actually counts all the policies
or
counts all the requests that matches a
particular policy that we create
and some of the characteristics we can
mention in awsof
are the origin ips and the strings that
appear in the request we can allow
block based on origin ip allow block
based on strings that appear in the
request
we can allow block or count based on the
origin country
length of the request yeah we can block
and count the presence of malicious
scripts
in an connection you know we can count
the request headers or we can allow
block a certain
request header and we can count the
presence of
a malicious sql code in a connection
that we get
and that want to reach our application
still talking about security
what are the different aws im categories
we can control
using aws iam we can do the following
one is
create and manage im users and once the
user database
gets bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups
and in im we can use it
to manage the security credentials kind
of setting the complexity of the
password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like mfa
and you know rotating the passwords no
resetting the password there are a few
things we could do with
iam and finally we can create policies
that actually grants access to aws
services
and resources another question you will
see is what are the policies that you
can set for your
user's password so some of the policies
that we can set for the user password is
at the minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters
in the password so that's one and then
the requirement of a specific character
types
including you know uppercase lowercase
number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for
somebody else to guess what the password
uh would be
and and try to hack them so we can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity in the password and then
we can set an
automatic expiration of the password so
after a certain time the user is forced
to create a new password so the
password is not still old and easy to
guess
in the environment and we can also set
settings like
the user should contact the admin i mean
when the password is about to
expire so you know you can get a hold of
how the user is setting
their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards or
there are few things that we can control
and set for the users when the users are
setting or recreating the password
another question
that could be posted in an interview so
to understand your
understanding of iem is what's the
difference between an
iem role and an im user let's talk about
iem user
let's start small and then go big or
let's start simple and then talk about
the complex one
the im user has a permanent long term
credential and it's used to interact
directly with aws services
and on the other hand iem role is an iem
entity that defines a set of permissions
for making aws service
request so i am user is an permanent
credential and role
are temporary credentials and iem user
has full access to all
aws iem functionalities and with role
trusted entities such as iem users
application or aws services
assume the role so when an im user is
given
an permission you know it sticks within
the iem
user but with roles we can give
permissions to
applications we can give permissions to
users in the same account in a different
account corporate id
we can give permissions to ec2 s3
rds vpc and lot more role is wide and
im user is is not so wide you know it's
very constrained
only for that i am user let's talk about
managed policies in
aws managed policies there are two types
you know
customer managed and amazon managed so
manage policies are i
am resources that express permissions
using the iam
policy language and we can create
policies
edit them manage them manage them
separately from
the im user group and roles which they
are
attached to so they are something that
we can do to managed policies if it is
customer managed
and we can now update policy in one
place and
the permissions automatically extend to
all the attached
entries so i can have like three
services four services point to a
particular policy and if i edit that
particular policy it's gonna reflect on
those three or four services so anything
that i allow
is going to be allowed for those four
services anything that i denied is going
to be denied for
uh the four services imagine what would
be without the
i am managed policy will have to go and
specifically allow deny
on those different instances four or
five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like i said there are
two types of managed policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policies and then the other is managed
by aws which is aws managed policy
this question can you give an example of
an iem policy
and a policy summary this is actually to
test how
well-versed are you with the aws console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to grant
access to add update and delete objects
from a specific folder now in this case
name of the folder is
example folder and it's present in a
bucket called
example bucket so this is an iam policy
on the other hand the policy summary is
a list of access level
resource and conditions for each service
defined in a policy so im policy
is all about one particular resource and
the policy summary
is all about multiple resources with iem
policy
it was only talking about s3 bucket and
one particular s3 bucket
here it talks about cloud formation
template cloud watch logs ec2
elastic bean stock services summary
summary of
resources and the permissions and
policies attached to them that's what
policy summary is all about
another question could be like this
what's the use case of iam
and how does im help your
business two important or primary work
of
im is to help us manage iam users
and their access it provides a secure
access to multiple users
to their appropriate aws resources so
that's one
it does and the second thing it does is
manage access
for federated users federated users or
non
iam users and through iam we can
actually
allow and provide secured access to
resources in our aws account
to our employees without the im user no
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the facebook
credential
google credential amazon credential and
a couple of other credentials third
party
identity management right so we could
actually trust them
and we could give them access to our
account based on
the trust relationship that we have
built with the
other identity of systems right so two
things one is
manage users and their access for
manage iam user and their access in our
aws environment
and second is manage access for
federated users
who are non-iam users and more
importantly im is a free service
and with that will only be charged for
the
use of the resources not for the im
username and password that we create all
right let's now
talk about some of the questions in
route 53
one classic question that could be asked
in an interview is what is the
difference between
latency based routing and geodns or
jio based dns routing now the geo based
dns routing takes routing decisions on
the basis of the geographic location
of the request and on the other hand the
latency based
routing utilizes latency measurements
between
networks and data centers now
latency based routing is used
where you want to give your customers
the lowest
latency as possible so that's when we
would use
latency based routing and on the other
hand the geo-based routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites
based on the country they are browsing
from
you know you could have you know two
different or three different websites
for the same url you know take amazon
the shopping website for example when we
go to amazon.com
from in the us it directs us to the us
web page where
the products are different the currency
is different right and the flag and
a couple of other advertisements that
shows up are different
and when we go to amazon.com from india
it gets directed to the
amazon.com indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements
they're all different right so depending
on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites
we would use a geo-based routing another
use case of jio based routing is if you
have a compliance that
you should handle all the dns requires
sorry
if you should handle all the requests
you know from
a country within the country then you
would
do jio based routing now you wouldn't
direct the customer to a server which is
in another country all right you would
very local to them that's another use
case of
jio based routing and like i said for
latency based routing the whole
goal or aim is to achieve minimum end
user
latency if you are hired for the
architect role
and if that requires working lot on
the dns then you could be posted with
this question what is the difference
between
domain and a hosted zone a domain is
actually a collection of
data describing a self-contained
administrative
and technical unit on the internet right
so for example
you know simplylearn.com is actually a
domain on the other hand
hosted zone is actually an container
that holds information about how you
want to route traffic on the internet to
a specific domain
for example lms.simplylearn.com is an
hosted zone whereas
simplylearn.com is a domain so in other
words in hosted zone
you would see the domain name plus and a
prefix
to it lms is a prefix here ftp is a
mail.simplylearn.com as a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from route 53
would be
how does amazon drop 53 provide high
availability and
low latency the way amazon rav 53
provides high availability and low
latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services
globally any customer doing a query from
different parts of the world
they get to reach an dns server which is
very local to them and
that's how it provides low latency now
this is not
true with all the dns providers there
are dns providers
who are very local to a country who are
very local to a continent
so they don't they generally don't
provide low latency
service right it's always high latency
it's low latency for
local users but anybody browsing from a
different country or a different
continent
it's going to be high latency for them
but that's not again true with
amazon amazon is a globally distributed
dns provider it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has optimal
locations it has got global servers or
in other words it has got servers around
the globe
different parts in the globe and that's
how they are able to provide
high availability and because it's not
running on
just one server but on many servers they
provide
high availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups
then you can expect questions in aws
config
a classic question would be how does aws
config work along with aws cloudtrail
aws cloudtrail
actually records user api activity on
the account
and you know any http https access or
any any sort of access you know that's
made to the cloud environment that's
recorded
in the cloud trail in other words any
api calls
the time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in
cloudtrail it's actually a log it
actually records
the activity in your cloud environment
on the other hand
config is an uh point in time
configuration details of your resources
for example at a given point what are
all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources
or what are the configuration in those
resources at a given point
they get captured in aws conflict right
so with that information
you can always answer the question what
did my aws resource look like
at a given point in time that question
gets answered
when we use aws config on the other hand
with cloudtrail
uh you can answer the question i mean by
looking at the cloudtrail or with the
help of cloudtrail you can easily answer
the question
who made an apa call to modify this
resource
that's answered by cloud trail and with
the cloud trail we can
detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and
who did that configuration let's say
there happened to be a downtime and you
want to identify
let's say there happened to be a
downtime and you want to identify
who made that change in the environment
you can simply look at cloudtrail
and find out who made the change and if
you want to look at how the environment
looks like before the change you can
always look at aws config
can aws configure or aws config
aggregate
data across different aws accounts yes
it can now this question is actually to
test whether you have used aws config or
not i know some of the services are
very local is it some of these services
are availability zone specific some of
them
are regional specific and some of them
are global
services in amazon and though some of
the services are region services you
still
can do some changes you know add some
configuration to
it and collect regional data in it for
example
s3 is a regional service but still you
can collect logs
from all other regions into an s3 bucket
in one particular region that's possible
and cloud trail is and cloud watch is an
regional service but still
you can with some changes to it with
some adding permissions to it you can
always monitor
the cloud watch that belongs to cloud
watch logs
that belongs to other regions you know
they're not global by default but
you can do some changes and make it
global similarly aws config is a service
that's a region based service but still
you can make it act
globally you can aggregate data across
a different region and different
accounts in an aws
config and deliver the updates
from different accounts to one s3 bucket
and can access it from there
aws config also works or integrates
seamlessly with
sns topic so you know anytime there is a
change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about
the new log or the new config or new
edit that happened
in the environment let's look at some of
the database questions
you know database should be running on
reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer
wants to understand how well you know
that fact by asking this question how
are
reserved instances different from
on-demand db instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are
exactly the same when it comes to their
function
but they only differ based on how they
are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low
per hour pricing because we're paying
upfront it's generally said that
reserved instance is 75 percentage
cheaper
than on-demand instance and amazon gives
you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year
on the other hand on demand instances
are
built on an oddly early price talking
about auto scaling how will you
understand the different types of auto
scaling
the interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and y
the two types of scaling as you would
know now are
vertical and horizontal and in vertical
scaling we can
vertically scale up the master database
with
a couple of clicks all right so that's
vertical scaling vertical scaling is
keeping the same node and making it
bigger
and bigger if previously it was running
on t2 micro now
we would like to run it on m3 two times
large instance previously it had one
virtual cpu one gigabit
now it's going to have eight virtual cpu
and 30 gigabit
of ram so that's vertical scaling on the
other hand horizontal scaling is adding
more nodes to it previously it was
running on one vm now it's going to run
on
2 3 10 vms all right that's horizontal
scaling so database can only be scaled
vertically and there are 18
different types of instances we can
resize our rds to right so this is true
for ids mysql
postgres sql mariadb oracle
microsoft sql servers there are 18 type
of instances we can
vertically scale up to on the other hand
horizontal scaling are good for
replicas so they are read-only replicas
we're not
going to touch the master database we're
not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling
only with amazon aurora and i can add
additional read replicas i can add up to
read replicas for amazon aurora and up
to five
read replicas for rds mysql postgres sql
and
marie db rds instances and when we add
replica
we are horizontally scaling adding more
nodes
right read only nodes so that's
horizontal
scaling so how do you really decide
between vertical and horizontal scaling
if you're looking in to increase the
storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you're looking at increasing the
performance
or of the read heavy database we need to
be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment
still talking about database this is
another good question you can expect in
the interview
what is the maintenance window in amazon
rds
will your db instance be available
during the maintenance
event all right so this is really to
test how well you have understood the
sla
how well you have understood the amazon
rdas uh the failover mechanism of amazon
rdas
uh stuff like that so audio's
maintenance window it lets you decide
when a db instance modification a
database engine
upgrades or software patching has to
occur and you you actually get to decide
should it happen at 12 in the night or
should it happen at
afternoon should it happen early in the
morning should it happen
in the evening you actually get to
decide an automatic scheduling
by amazon is done only for patches that
are security and
durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and
durability and by default the
maintenance window is
is for 30 minutes and the important
point is
the db instance will be available during
that
event because you're going to have
primary and secondary right so when that
upgrade
happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade
and then switch back to the primary
another classic question would be what
are the consistency
models in dynamodb in dynamodb there is
eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model
it actually maximizes your read
throughput
and the best part with eventual
consistency is all copies of data
reach consistency within a second
and sometimes when you write and when
you're
you know trying to read immediately
chances that you you would still be
reading the old
data that's eventual consistency on the
other hand there is
another consistency model called the
strong consistency or strongly
consistent
read where there is going to be a delay
in writing the data
you know making sure the data is written
in all places but
it guarantees one thing that is once you
have done a write
and then you're trying to do a read it's
going to make sure that
it's going to show you the updated data
not the old
data and you can be guaranteed of it
that it is going to show the updated
data and not the old data that's
strongly consistent
still talking about database talking
about
nosql dynamodb or nosql database which
is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of
query functionality does dynamodb
support dynamodb supports get and
put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb
provides flexible querying by letting
you query on
non-primary key attributes using
global secondary index and local
secondary indexes
a primary key can be either a single
attribute partition key or a
composite partition sort key in other
words a dynamodb indexes a composite
partition
sort key as a partition key element and
a sort key element
and by holding the partition key you
know when doing a search
or when doing a query by holding the
partition k element constant
we can search across the sort key
element to retrieve the other items
in that table and the composite
partition sort key
should be a combination of user id
partition
and a timestamp so that's what the
composite partition
sort key is made of let's look at some
of the multiple choice questions you
know sometimes
some companies would have an a written
test
or an mcq type online test before they
call you for
at the first level or before they call
you for the second level so these are
some classical questions that
companies asked or companies ask in
their
multiple choice online questions let's
look at this question as a developer
using this pay-per-use service you can
send
store and receive messages between
software components
which of the following is being referred
here let's look at it right we have aws
step functions amazon mq amazon simple
queue service
amazon simple notification service let's
say the question again as a developer
using this pay-per-use service so the
service that we are
looking for is a pay-per-view service
you can send store and retrieve messages
between two software components kind of
like a queue
there so what would be the right answer
it would be amazon
simple queue service now amazon simply
queue service is the one that's used to
decouple
at the environment it breaks the tight
coupling and then it
introduces decoupling in that
environment by providing a queue
or by inserting a queue between two
software components
let's look at this other question if you
would like to host a real-time audio and
video conferencing application
on aws it's an audio and video
conferencing application on aws
this service provides you with a secure
and easy to use
application what is this service let's
look at the options they are
amazon chime amazon workspace
amazon mq amazon app stream but you
might tend to look at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference
but it's actually for a different
purpose is actually amazon
chime that lets you create chat and
create
a chat board and then collaborate with
the security of
the aws services so it lets you do the
audio it lets you do the video
conference all supported by
aws security features it's actually
amazon
chime let's look at this question as
your company's aw solution architect
you are in charge of designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar
which of the following service best
serves
your requirement in earlier ec2
autoscaling aws
snowball aws fargate aws
batch let's read the question again as
your company's aw solution architect
you are in charge of designing thousands
of
individual jobs which are similar it
looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an
storage uh transport service ec2 auto
scaling is
you know in introducing scalability and
elasticity in the environment and aws
fargate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are
similar aws batch it's the right answer
but let's look at the other one you
are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you
build and train machine learning models
in
aws which among the following are we
referring to so we have amazon sagemaker
and aws
deep lens amazon comprehend aws
device farm let's read the question
again you are a machine learning
engineer and you're looking for a
service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in aws
which among the following are referred
here the answer is
sage maker it provides every developer
and data scientist with the ability to
build train
and deploy mission learning models
quickly that's what sagemaker does
now for you to be familiar with you know
the the products i would
recommend you to you know simply go
through the
product description you know there's one
page available on amazon that explains
all the products
a quick neat and simple that really
helps you to
be very familiar with you know what the
product is all about and what it is
capable of you know is it a db service
is it a machine learning service or is
it a monitoring service is it a
developer service stuff like that so get
that information get that details before
you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face
such questions with a great confidence
so the answer is amazon sagemaker
because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build a train and
deploy machine learning models quickly
as possible all right let's look at this
one
let's say that you are working for your
company's id team and
you are designated to adjust the
capacity of the aws resource based on
the incoming application
and network traffic how do you do it
so what's the service that's actually
helps us to
adjust the capacity of the aws resource
based on
the incoming application let's look at
it amazon vpc amazon
iam amazon inspector amazon elastic
load balancing amazon vpc is a
networking service
amazon iam is an username password
authentication amazon inspector is a
service that
actually does security audit in our
environment and
amazon elastic load balancer is a
service that helps in
scalability that's in one way you know
indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in
through the elastic load balancer we can
actually adjust
the environment that's running behind it
so the answer is going to be amazon
elastic load balancer all right let's
look at this question
this cross-platform video game
development engine
that supports pc xbox playstation ios
and android platforms
allows developers to build and host
their games on
amazon's servers so we have amazon game
lift
amazon green grass amazon lumber yard
amazon sumerian let's read the question
again
this cross-platform video game
development engine that supports pc xbox
playstation ios and android platforms
allows developers to build and host
their
games on amazon servers the answer is
amazon lumberyard this lumberyard is an
free
aaa gaming engine deeply integrated with
aws and twitch with full source this
lumbar yard provides a
growing set of tools that helps you
create and highest
game quality applications and they
connect to
a lot of games and vast compute and
storage in the cloud so it's that
service they are referring to let's look
at this question
you are the project manager of your
company's cloud architect
team you are required to visualize
understand and manage your aws cost
and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have aws budgets we have aws
cost explorer
we have amazon work mail we have amazon
connect and the answer is going to be
cost explorer now cost explorer is an
option in the amazon console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage
the aws cost over time who's spending
more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question you
are a chief cloud architect
at your company and how can you
automatically monitor
and adjust computer resources to ensure
maximum performance and efficiency
of all scalable resources so we have a
cloud formation
as a service we have aws aurora as a
solution we have
aws auto scaling and amazon api gateway
let's read the question again you're the
chief cloud architect at your company
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust
computer resources how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to
ensure maximum performance and
efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer
the answer is auto scaling right that's
a basic service and solution architect
course is it auto scaling is the service
that helps us to easily adjust
monitor and ensure the maximum
performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources it does that by
automatically
scaling the environment to handle the
inputs let's look at this question as a
database administrator
you will use a service that is used to
set up and manage
databases such as mysql maya db and
postgres
sql which service are we referring to
amazon aurora
amazon elastic cache aws rds aws
database migration service amazon arora
is
amazon's flavor of the rds service and
elastic cache is is the caching service
provided by amazon they are not
full-fledged database and database
migration service just like the name
says it helps to migrate
the database from on premises to the
cloud and
from one database flavor to another
database flavor
amazon rds is the service is the console
is the service
is the umbrella service that helps us to
set up
manage databases like mysql money db
and postgres sql it's amazon rts
let's look at this last question a part
of your marketing work
requires you to push messages to onto
google
facebook windows and apple through apis
or aws
management console you will use the
following service so the options are
aws cloudtrail aws config amazon chime
aws simple notification service it says
a part of your marketing work requires
you to push messages
it's dealing with pushing messages to
google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console
you will use the following service it's
simple notification service
simple notification service is an
message pushing
a service and sqs is pulling similarly
sns is pushing right here it talks about
a
pushing system that pushes messages to
google facebook windows and apple
through api
and it's going to be a simple
notification system or a simple
notification
service and with that we have come to
the end of this video on aws full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
about the topics that were covered in
this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
[Music]
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here